ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
NUMBER THREE WERE WELL INTO OUR
SERIES OF INITIAL MEETINGS DOWN
TO. HAVE A- GOOD GROUP OF-
DEPARTMENTS TO HEAR FROM TODAY
RELATIVE TO VARIOUS- OF BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS AND FUNDING
REQUESTS AND WILL CLOSE OFF
WITH OUR- THE BEGINNING OF OUR
ANNUAL FESTIVAL OF G. R. F. OF
FUNDING OF THE GOOD EWS ON
GIGI R. F. IS THAT THE AUCTIONS
HAVE BROUGHT IN MORE MONEY THAN
THAT- WELL IT'S HARD TO SAY
THAN ANTICIPATED BUT MORE
CERTAINLY MORE MONEY- THAN THE
VERY. SMALL AMOUNTS OF RECEIPT
RE RECEIVED BY COMPARISON
ROUGHLY A YEAR AGO SO THERE'S
MORE MONEY TO SPEND- WHICH IN
SOME WAYS MEANS THAT TO.
BECAUSE THESE ARE THIS IS
OFFSET MONEY MEANS THAT THERE'S
MORE CARBON IN THE AIR WE WANT
TO SEE ULTIMATELY THOSE NUMBERS
GO DOWN BECAUSE WE WANT TO SEE
THE CARBON REDUCTIONS FROM THE-
FOLKS WHO WERE GENERATING
CARBON. AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE. IN
ANY EVENT- BEFORE WE BEGIN WITH
THE FORMAL PART OF OUR MEETING
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO READ SOME
DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION AS WE DO IT EVERY
MEETING- TO HELP ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE WHILE.
ALLOWING AS FULL AS POSSIBLE
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION. TODAY
WE ARE HAVING A PHYSICALLY
DISTANT IN PERSON HEARING IN
THE STATE CAPITAL WERE IN ROOM
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN. IN ORDER TO
KEEP SIX FEET OF SPACING WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS.
A MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF-
AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE
PUBLIC AND MEDIA. THERE ARE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE WHO WERE HERE TODAY
TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. AND ALL OF A
REVIEW THIS WHEN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT BEGINS BUT IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WHICH IS. TO SPEAK I ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND. AND WANTED A TIME WILL
ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. AND ASK THAT YOU
RESPECT PHYSICAL DISTANCING AND
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. WHILE
YOU'RE IN THE PROCESS OF GIVING
YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT. ON WHETHER
YOU DO IT HERE IN THIS ROOM OR
REMOTELY- WE'RE ALLOWING ONE
MINUTE FOR EACH PUBLIC COMMENT
ONE MINUTE- I DO TIME THEM AND
TRY TO KEEP. EVERYBODY AS ON
TARGET AS POSSIBLE. YOU CAN
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU.
HAVE GIVEN YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT
OR RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. IF
YOU'RE HER IN THE ROOM BUT
PLEASE OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. THE PANELISTS ON THE
AGENDA AND THE L. A. OR
APPEARING REMOTELY USING.
ONLINE TECHNOLOGY WE ARE NOT
VOTING IN COMMITTEE TODAY THERE
ARE NO VOTES THAT WILL BE
TAKING. WE ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING ON ALL ITEMS. BOTH IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND ON THE
PHONE. THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT WITH US IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD
ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN YOUR
WATCH IF YOU'RE WATCHING OVER
THE INTERNET- BUT THAT NUMBER
IS. PUBLIC TOLL FREE.
877-692-8957 THAT'S.
877-692-8957 AND YOU'LL NEED
THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE WHICH IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN THAT'S ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN IF YOU HAVE
ANY PROBLEMS WHATSOEVER.
CONNECTING IS CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2099 AND ONE OF THE
VERY KIND STAFF MEMBERS WILL
TRY TO ASSIST YOU THAT'S NINE
ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO
ZERO NINE NINE. WE HAVE A
NUMBER AS WE HAVE HAD OF- IN
OUR OUR A PAST COUPLE OF
MEANINGS NON DISCUSSION ITEMS-
ARE WE DO NOT- HAVE
PRESENTATIONS ON THOSE ITEMS.
THAT IS THE OF THOSE- ITEMS
THAT WOULD NORMALLY BE
CONSIDERED THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR BUT BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
TAKING A VOTE- THEY ARE-
LABELED IN THE AGENDA AS NON
DISCUSSION ITEMS BUT- MISTER
SMITH MAY HAVE A QUESTION WELL
I DO A LOT OF THOSE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN ITEM FIVE.
YEARS WHAT HAPPENED TO THE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN FUNDING FOR
THE STAFFING IF THEY GET HIGHER
THOSE STAFF MEMBERS DOES IT
ROLL OVER ASKING FOR THE
FUNDING AGAIN NOW OR DID THEY-
USE THAT FUNDING SOMEWHERE
MAYBE THEY COULD EVEN GET BACK
WITH ME LATER. YES AND IN THE
ARE ARE THOSE YOUR ARE WITH YOU
HAD ANY DISCUSSION WHAT HAPPENS
FUNDING IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
THOSE FIVE OF EIGHT. AT THEY
DID NOT FEEL OF CANCER BECAUSE
THAT'S- IS FIVE PIPELINE SAFETY.
STAFFING YES- TWO FOUR FIVE TO
FIVE THE FIFTH BULLET ITEMS SO
WILL TAKE NOTE OF- THAT
QUESTION AND ASKED THAT THE
RELEVANT. DEPARTMENT TO
INDIVIDUAL FROM THE DEPARTMENT
PLEASE GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT-
SINCE OTHER NOT PRYING TO BE
HERE. TODAY SO WOULD BE ABLE TO
ANSWER. AT THE THAT WILL TAKE
US TO ITEM TO BE HER. WE WITH
THE- CAL DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY
AND FIRE PROTECTION CAL FIRE.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS THAT COULD BE
DESCRIBED FOR US. GOOD MORNING-
CHAIR BLOOM AND- MEMBERS HI MY
NAME'S TOM PORTER I AM THE
STATE FORESTER. AND THE
DIRECTOR OF CAL FIRE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION ON THESE MEASURES
THESE- ISSUES THAT YOU'RE
HEARING TODAY- JUST A LITTLE
BIT OF A FRAME. UP FOR WHERE WE
ARE WITHOUT A DOUBT THE TWENTY
TWENTY FIRE SEASON. WAS AMONG
THE WORST AND MOST DAMAGING. IN
STATES HAS. FOR TWO MILLION
ACRES NINE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED STRUCK WHERE DOES-
TRACTOR THIRTY TWO INDIVIDUALS
LOST THEIR LIVES THREE OF THOSE
FIRST RESPONDERS. AND- WE SIX
THE- TWENTY FIRE HISTORY ALL
BURNING A THE SAME. IN THE MASS.
YES COMPLEX BURKE OVER A
MILLION- IN ANOTHER IN K. THE
MANAGER A AT WHICH CAL OR THE-
TWENTY- SEES BURKE WAS STATUS
TO COMMUNITIES. AND TO THE
RESOURCE THAT THOSE FIRES- WE
AT THE PEAK OF THE C. NINETEEN
THOUSAND FIRE. BATTLING FIRES
THROUGHOUT THE- AND IF OTHER
TAKE IN THE GREAT TOLL ON THOSE
BY- BUT THE- AND THE COUNTRY.
FROM WHICH THEY ARE. RESIDE AND.
RIGHT FROM. SO THE OF THE
IMPACT WENT FAR BEYOND- THOSE
LOCAL AREAS WHERE THE FOR WERE-
SAMPLES HAD DEEP ORANGE SKY AS
WELL AS MUCH OF THE STATE-
REALLY TIP THE EXPANSE NATURE
OF WHAT WE DOING IN THIS IN
THIS- BECAUSE CHANGE- MULTIPLY.
THAT WE'RE SEEING. YEAH OUR
FIRE SUPPRESSION ACT- YEAH
ALTHOUGH I CENTURY OVERGROWN
ALONG DROUGHT- ANNEX TREE MORE
OF EXAM THAT SITUATION WELL WE
THIS- ON THE MEASURE WERE
TALKING ABOUT. FIRST YOUR ISSUE
NUMBER- WE ARE- LOOKING AT-
FACILITY IMPRESSED.
IMPROVEMENTS AND. OUR MAIN OF
THAT HELP US TO FILE PAST.
EIGHT BE PREPARED TO DEPLOY
FROM AND US THOSE IN GO FORWARD
WITH THAT- I'M GOING TO OF IF
THE- HELLO TO A CAL FIRE
ASSISTANT AT TO OF SERVICES.
MIKE OKAY. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING. START GET MORE MR CHU
AND- MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
OF OUR AND SHE TEXTURE- WE'RE
BY DEFEAT TO FABRIC AND
ASSISTANT DEPUTY FOR. YES MA'AM
TRADE HUNTER- CAL BARS THE TOUR
OF OVER FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY
INCLUDE TO OUR THIRTY FOUR
STATION TWELVE AIR ATTACK BASE.
CAN HELP TAX BASES CURRENTLY
ONE CONSERVE CARE. REQUIRE
CENTERS A HUNDRED TWELVE
COMMUTER FOR. SIXTEEN ADMIT
HEADQUARTERS TWENTY YEAR. STATE
FOREST AND- ONE REFORESTATION
CENTER AND ALSO THE INCLUDE
THREE TRAIN CENTERS THERE ARE
ALSO UNDER. HUNDRED OTHER THAT
SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT MISSION
OF THE SYSTEM 63% WORK PRIOR TO
NINE SIXTY WITH 80% CONSTRUCT
PRIOR NINETEEN SO. THE AVERAGE
AGE OF CAL FACILITY AS PART
NINE YEAR. OTHER PROJECTS PER
SE THIS IS OF A NUMBER OF SO
REALIZE. FREE I NEVER IMPROVING
ADDRESSING OUR FIRE STATION
PRESERVATION CARE TELL BASIS
THEIR ATTACK BASIS. IT HAD
COURT THAT INCLUDES EMERGENCY
CENTER. THESE PROJECTS REFLECT
TOPPER IS A CAL FIRE FIVE YEAR
INTEREST PLAN. OKAY WORK OUT
CLOSELY WITH THE- TO BUILD
SOLID FINANCIAL DOING THAT ABLE
TO. SEE THESE PER THROUGH TO
COMPLETION WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY AND
ARE VERY HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE- ANY OTHER
PRESENTATIONS- A BEFORE WE GET
TO- OF A QUESTIONS FROM MARK-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- AND THE-
ALEJO. REPORT. JEROBOAM THAT
CONCLUDES CAL BUYERS REPORT
ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU I THINK
IT'S A- VERY MEANINGFUL THAT
TO- YOU ARE A BUDGETING A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY TO-
UPGRADE AND REPLACE AGING AND
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE WE DID THAT
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO- WITH A
LOT OF THE- OF THE QUITMAN-
THAT- WAS OBSOLETE OR- AGING
AND IN NEED OF. OF REPLACEMENT
AND- GIVEN THAT WE KNOW THAT-
OF THE CHALLENGES YOU FACE OF
CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE ON INTO
THE FUTURE I THINK OF THESE-
UGH A VERY IMPORTANT.
ALLOCATIONS I WOULD JUST AT-
OF- ONE ADDITIONAL COMMENT- N.
M. AND THAT IS I'M GLAD THAT
YOU BEGAN. CHIEF PORTER WITH A
REPORT TO REMINDING US OF THE
DEVASTATION OF LAST YEAR'S
FIRES. IT'S BEEN QUIET FOR A
COUPLE OF MONTHS. AND IT'S VERY
VERY EASY FOR US TO FORGET TO-
THE CONFLAGRATION THAT- THAT WE
FACED ONLY A YEAR AGO AND- EACH
OF THE PAST YEARS SO. A
COLLECTIVELY THE DAMAGE THAT'S
BEEN DONE THE STATE HAS BEEN-
ENORMOUS. SO IT'S SICK IT'S
GOOD FOR US TO GET THAT-
REMINDER THAT WAKE UP CALL AND
TO HI THERE WILL MAKE SURE THAT
WE- CONTINUE TO- ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE AS A PRIORITY AS AS WE
MUST. ARE THERE ANY A MISTER
SMITH YES I WOULD LIKE A NOT
NECESSARY QUESTION BUT UPON.
BECAUSE I'M WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE FUNDING
REQUEST MY CONCERN IS BECAUSE
IN THE WHOLE TOTAL IS SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR MILLION.
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS AND I
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE
THAT FUNDING GOING TO THE
FUTURE SO YOU CAN FINISH THIS
PROJECT. I'D HATE TO SEE YOU
GET STARTED IN GOING INTO
GENERAL FUNDS TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU HAVE THE FUNDING SO AS LONG
AS TIME WENT ON THIS COMMITTEE.
I WILL MAKE SURE THAT WHEN YOU
GET TO REQUEST WE CAN CONTINUE
TO GET THESE PROJECTS
UNFINISHED. TO BRING INTO THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY. THAT'S A
WELL. PRETTY SINCE WE'RE ARE. A
TWENTY YEAR INTO THE TWENTY FOR
CENTURY. AND I THINK IN MANY
RESPECTS WERE- WERE BEHIND AND
NEED TO CATCH UP SO- I THINK
VERY APPROPRIATE. TO A COMMON
SET. IF THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS. HERE ON THE DYESS.
AND WHY DON'T WE- PROCEED WITH
THE L. A. X. REPORT. GOOD
MORNING MY MEMBERS BRIAN BROWN
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THE SPECIFIC
PROJECT. BY THE DEPARTMENT SO
WE FIND THAT MOST OF THE
FACILITIES ARE IN FACT AGING
IS. THE DIRECTOR DESCRIBED.
SAID I DO HAVE OPERATIONAL
CHALLENGES IN MANY CASES THERE
ALSO MODIFICATION REQUIRED TO
ADDRESS- NEED NEEDS SUCH AS THE
NEW HEALTH. THAT BY THE
LEGISLATURE. I THINK THE KEY
POINT JUST WONDERING WITH THE-
RAISED BY A MEMBER SMITH WHICH
IS THAT THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
OUT YEAR CONFIDENCE WITH THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE FROM. HE-
SIX FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS AND
COSTS AGAIN OF. IN IT IS
IMPORTANT RECOGNIZE IS ALWAYS
THE CASE WITH CAPITAL PROJECTS
BUT- PARTICULARLY BOTH ALL UP
FOR THIS AND THAT OF FINANCE
HAVE PROJECTED OUT YEAR
STRUCTURAL DEFICITS IN THE
GENERAL FUND. ANY PROJECT
ULTIMATELY WOULD BE PAID FOR
FROM THE GENERAL FUND TOOK IT
UPON TO- INSURE THAT. ARE FOR
LEGISLATIVE. AND GENERAL FUND
PRIORITY FOR THE- H. INTRUDERS.
THANK AND TELL THE OF FINANCE
HAVE COMMON THAT. YES GOOD
MORNING MICHAEL PART OF MY- IN
TO THE L. A. S. S. I. WOULD
LIKE TO ADD THAT HE HAD BEEN
HAS DEVELOPED A FIVE YEAR. PLAN
BASED AROUND THE OF THE CALL
REVENUES ALL THE WITH YOU TODAY.
REVIEWED FOR AFFORDABLE BAY ON
THAT IS. IT WOULD NOT THE
SEVENTY PER OF THE COSTS AT THE
IN THE YEAR FOR PLAN WILL BE
FUNDED USING WHICH FOR BOND
THIS WILL DIFFUSE THE IMPACT OF
GENERAL OVER TO FIVE YOUR-
THAT'S MAKING THE AFFORDABLE
THE PART NOT. GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- CAN WE GET TO KEEP.
BACK FOR- WANTED THIS. QUESTION.
AT LEAST- THAT CHIEF POOR- BACK
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN WHEN- I WAS-
GIVEN THE HONOR OF SHARING THE
SUB- IT DOES UP QUICKLY
APPARENT TO ME THAT ARE
HEALTHCARE FLEET WAS OUTDATED
AND BADLY IN NEED OF- OF
REPLACEMENT AND I'M GRATIFIED
THAT THE FUNDING IS NOW IN
PLACE TO- A COMPLETE THAT
REPLACEMENT PROJECT I WONDER IF
YOU COULD JUST- BRIEFLY- LEAD
AT- THE SENATE COMMITTEE AND
NOW IF WERE ON SCHEDULE AND ON
BUDGET AND THAT PROJECT. WE ARE
ON- THE ON BUT AND ON SCHEDULE
HAS BEEN- I JUST A LITTLE BIT
DUE TO IT- AND ACTUALLY THAT'S
NOT A IN UNITED STATES OF
COURSE OF THEIR OF THE STUFF
CHAIN PORTAL HELICOPTERS- IF-
YEAH DIRECTOR IS A BAY. CAN YOU
COME UP I'M WOULD LIKE TO GIVE
YOU THE SPECIFICS ARE BUT-
DEPLOYMENT ONE THE- HELLO WILL
BE- ON BASE AND READY. BUY THE-
IF AND EFFORT DEPUTY TO IS NOT
AVAIL- WHICH CERTAINLY THAT
RICH TO- WHEN- WE EXPECT TO SEE
AGAIN AFTER REVISE. CERTAINLY
NOT SEEING HIM COME- DIRECTLY-
WE'RE WE'RE A SLY DELAY ON.
LAST PORTION OF THE HELICOPTERS
BUT WE WILL BE RECEIVING. I
BELIEVE IT'S FOR THIS YEAR-
WHICH WILL BE DEPLOYED
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR INTO THE
BEGINNING OF NEXT- FALL SEASON.
BUT- WILL HAVE FOR WE HAVE TO
CURRENT AND TO A DISH- THAT-
COMING INTO THE FLEET. AS WE
MOVE IN. THE FIRES THAT WOULD
BE FOR. GOING IN TO PICK GRADE
MATH YOU AND WE CAN JUST- OKAY
A NEW FOR AN UPDATE- HAVE MAY
REVISED OF THE GRAY. THAT'S
THANK YOU. F. THERE'S NO OTHER
ARE THEN- WE WILL TAKE- ISSUE
SO- WERE HOLDING ALL OF OUR
ITEMS OPEN TODAY AND TAKING NO
ACTION- SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
REPORTER WILL MOVE ON TO- ISSUE
NUMBER TWO- RELATING TO
DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTIONS.
WELL OPEN AGAIN- THANK YOU
CHAIR BLOOM AND- THIS IS
ANOTHER PIECE OF THE HOLISTIC
APPROACH THAT CAL FIRE IS
TAKING TO REDUCING THE- DAMAGE
AND DESTRUCTION OF WILDFIRES
AND IT IS KEY TO PROTECTING.
HOMES FROM BURNING BUT ALSO-
INFRASTRUCTURE AND- I AM GOING
TO. INTRODUCE NOW- DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AND ASSISTANT STATE
FIRE MARSHAL. WENDY COLLINS.
RECEPTUS ON FORTUNE HER CAMERA
NOT WORK SO YOU'RE TO HAVE OVER.
FOR HER. THANK YOU TAKE THANK
IN THE MORNING THE CHAIR AND
MEMBER OF THE CAN. TO BE
RESPECTFUL OF YOUR TIME OPENING
WILL FREE FROM US TO GET TO ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
MY NAME IS WENDY COLLINS AND
I'M THE ASSISTANT STATE FIRE
MARSHAL WE'RE HERE TODAY TO
DISCUSS THE REQUEST OF EIGHT
POINT THREE MILLION GENERAL
FUND AND TWENTY SIX POSITION
STARTING IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. APPLE BE NECESSARY TO
CONDUCT WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB
THIRTY EIGHT. AND A SUBSEQUENT
TRAINING AND STAFFING OF TWENTY
ONE NEW FORESTRY TECH POSITION.
THERE WILL BE PASSED WITH THE
EVALUATION AND CERTIFICATION OF
STRUCTURE HARDENING MEASURES.
AND THE PROPERTY IS DISPENSABLE
FACE COMPLIANCE. TO THE BUYERS
OF HOMES IN HIGH OR VERY HIGH
FIRE SEVERITY. AS WE THROUGH
THIS PURPOSE. IT WAS IMPORTANT
HIM BUT THE THAT THIS PROGRAM
IS NEEDED FROM THE PALATABLE
FOR PROGRAM. FIFTH IS STAFFED
WITH POOREST AIDS THIS PROGRAM
IS WITH HERMAN FOR TECHNO. THIS
OF THE CIVIL CLASS- THE DEATH
LEVEL TRAINING. AND IS THE END
LEVEL LEADING TO PARK SHOPPERS
FOR AT THE ONE AND. TWO THE
DATE PROGRAM IT'S ON MEETING
THE FIRE GOAL COMPLETING
HUNDRED THOUSAND DEFENSE SPACE
INSPECTIONS AND LIKE ANNUALLY.
THIS PROGRAM IS THE TWENTY
POOREST TECHNIQUE WILL FOCUS ON
THE OF STRAW. AND ANY HOME
HARDENING. THAT HAVE BEEN
ACHIEVED OR THE ARE OF MAY AND
THEN. THAT AS PER OF A HOME
SALE IN HIGHER VERY HIGH FOR SO
THEY PROBLEMS IN THE SRX. AGAIN
THIS IS AN ENTRY BECAUSE WITH
UPPER. BUT SO IT'S NOT BE AND-
THAT THE AND STAFF WOULD CREATE
AND ONE. ONLY AN ADDITIONAL
ONE. BUT THAT. STAFF WILL BE
USING ENTRY LEVEL FOR THE AS A
STEPPING TO MEET THEIR- GOALS.
AND HOPEFULLY. SUPPORT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY
ASSISTANT. MAKING TURN OVER RE.
WE MUST BE. FOR WITH THAT SAID
TO BE ADDED STAFFING AND IT FOR
THE TRAINING CENTER AND DAVID
SMOKE QUITE. IS TO THE AND
HIGHER IN THE COMPLICATED IS
NOT THE. THANK YOUARE FIRST OF
ALL I WANT TO COMMEND THE
ADMINISTRATION AND CAL FIRE FOR
TAKING THE STEPS TO INCREASE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTORS-
BOTH FOR THIS BILL AND FOR THE
B. C. P. ON A. B. THIRTY
SEVENTY FOUR. WE NEED MORE
INSPECTORS WE NEED MORE-
INSPECTIONS BUT THIS IS A GOOD
DOWN PAYMENT AND I'M REALLY
HAPPY TO SEE- THIS MOVEMENT I
HAVE TWO QUESTIONS THE FIRST
QUESTION IS HOW THESE-
DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTORS FIT
TOGETHER. WITH THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR DISPATCH DEFENSIBLE
SPACE INSPECTORS IN THE
EXPENDITURE PLAN THAT'S MY
FIRST QUESTION ALL. YOU KNOW IF
YOU WANT TO ASK BOTH OF THEM
MISTER CHAIR OR JUST ASK ONE AT
A TIME. WELL I GUESS I'LL JUST
ASK BOTH. THAT THE QUESTION
SECOND. IS WHETHER THESE
INSPECTORS WILL ONLY
INSPECTORATES SAY TRANSACTIONS
BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE THEY HAVE A
DIFFERENT LEVEL OF TRAINING AND
THE OTHER INSPECTORS BUT I JUST
WANT TO BE CLEAR TO. MAXIMIZE
THEIR TIME THAT AS THEY'RE
TRAVELING TO. AND FROM THESE
REAL ESTATE TRANSACTIONS IS
THERE ANY THOUGHT TO USING THEM
ACROSS THE BOARD FOR OTHER
INSPECTIONS ALONG THE WAY SO
THEY DON'T HAVE TO TRAVEL A
LONG DISTANCE TO DO ONE
INSPECTION. AND TRAVEL BACK IF
THEY'RE SORT OF INSPECTIONS
THEY CAN DO AS THEY'RE MOVING
THROUGH THAT RELATE TO YOU KNOW
ACROSS THAT THAT LAND- SO I'M
JUST THINKING ABOUT EFFICIENCY
OF TIME AND WHETHER THEIR-
TRAINING IS UP TO THE POINT
WHERE THEY CAN DO. A DEBT THOSE
ADDITIONAL INSPECTIONS ARE NOT
SO THOSE ARE MY TWO QUESTIONS
AND AGAIN. WHEN I COMMEND CAL
FIGHTER IN THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR THE FOR THIS DIRECTION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
QUESTION. BUT I'D LIKE TO DO
IS- DEFERRED TO CHANGE. THE
POCKETS. IN THE ONLINE. HAS AS
HE WAS THE ONE- HE AND HIS
STAFF WERE. INSTRUMENTAL IN
CREATING THE METRICS. THAT
IDENTIFIED THE STAFFING NEEDS.
TO TALK. THANK YOU MEMBER
FRIEDMAN FOR THE QUESTION AND
HONESTY BOX- AND I OVERSEE THE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE PROGRAM FOR
THE DEPARTMENT. AND TO ANSWER
THE QUESTIONS- THE SECOND
QUESTION IS ABSOLUTELY WE- THE
NEW PORTREE TECHNICIAN
POSITIONS WILL BE TRAINED AS
OUR CURRENT DEFENSIBLE SPACE
INSPECTORS ARE TRAINED. AND SO
WHEN THEY'RE THEIR PRIMARY
FOCUS WILL BE ON MEETING THE
INTENT OF AB THIRTY EIGHT AND
CONDUCTING THE- DEFENSIBLE
SPACE INSPECTIONS ASSOCIATED
WITH. THE SALE OF PROPERTY-
HOWEVER- WHEN THEY'RE NOT BE
GAUGE AND THAT THEY WILL NOT
SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT'S
MISSION AND MEETING ITS GOAL OF
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
INSPECTIONS ANNUALLY. AND I'M
NOT QUITE CERTAIN ON THE FIRST
QUESTION- BUT THE PROPOSED
BUDGET HAS THE FUNDING IN IT
TOO- SUPPORT THE- HIRING OF
THESE POSITIONS AND THE PROGRAM
BUT GOING INTO THE FUTURE I'M
NOT SURE IF I ANSWERED. THAT
CORRECTLY OR NOT. I THINK I
WOULD HAVE A QUESTION BECAUSE
THESE AND SEEM TO BE DEDICATED
TO THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR
PRIMARILY I WAS WONDERING IF
THEY IMPACT ANY OTHER
DEFENSIBLE SPACE- EXPENDITURES
OR WORK THAT YOU'LL BE DOING
BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE THE
COMPLEMENTARY AND NOT
REPLACING. ANYTHING I'LL-
THAT'S CORRECT WE ARE PUMP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HOW IT HOW
MANY. OPPORT TRANSFERS AND-
HIGH FIRE ON A VERY HIGH FIRE
ZONE AREA DO YOU PROJECT OVER
THE COURSE OF A YEAR. THAT THE
BEGINNING AND I COULDN'T TAKE
THAT QUESTION BUT WE DID AN
ANALYSIS OF THE NUMBER OF SALE
THE PROPERTY WITHIN THE STATE
AND TRANSLATED THAT TO BE S. R.
A. AND WE'RE ANTICIPATING
ROUGHLY. BASED ON THOSE ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND-
TRANSACTIONS PER YEAR- HOWEVER
THAT IT'S BASED OFF OF- TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND THEN
AGAIN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
DATA- SO IT COULD BE HIGHER
COULD BE LOWER- AND- AND SO
WHAT AT THE OF THE PROGRAM
PROGRESSES WILL BE ABLE TO
DETERMINE. WHAT THE TRUE LEVEL
THE IMPACT. IS AND THEN ADJUST
ACCORDINGLY. SO YOU ANTICIPATE
THE TWENTY SIX- SESSIONS CAN DO
ROUGHLY. NINE HUNDRED TO A
THOUSAND. INSPECTIONS ANNUALLY.
IT SOUNDED LIKE WALL ORDERS
FROM THE COMMISSION POSITION.
I'M SORRY I CUT IT BUT- YES
THEY THEY CAN HANDLE THAT
WORKLOAD. OKAY. JUST ADD TO
THAT IT'S A CLUB SO OTHER
INSPECTORS WILL BE ABLE TO
ASSIST WITH SOME OF THAT
WORKLOAD- THERE WILL BE AN
EVENTFUL OF THE- THOSE. TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT EACH OTHER I
SEE AN ALLY IN- ALL OF THE A.
B. THIRTY EIGHT CASES AS OF
ANTICIPATED THAT THERE WOULD BE
AT LEAST ONE SITE VISIT. SOUTH
AMERICA PROBABLY HAVE TO BE AT
LEAST TO AN INITIAL AND THEN A
FINAL AT SOME POINT. J.
PROBLEMS THERE WILL BE- THIS
NIFTY BOX AGAIN THERE'D BE ONE
SITE VISIT- AND IF THEY ARE
COMPLIANT WITH THE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE INSPECTIONS THAT WOULD
ONLY REQUIRE ONE BIT THAT IF
THEY'RE NON COMPLIANT. A FOLLOW
UP AT THAT WOULD BE NECESSARY-
ONCE THE THAT A PROPERTY OWNER
HAS MITIGATED THE ISSUES- TO
BRING THEIR PROPERTY INTO
COMPLIANCE. OKAY I UNDERSTAND
THAT. LET SER PROCEED WITH A
REPORT FROM A ALEJO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR BRIAN BROWN WITH
THE L. A. AGAIN- FIRST IF I
COULD JUST TO RESPOND TO ONE OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN'S
QUESTIONED THE FOR THE FIRST
ONE ABOUT HOW THIS ALIGNS WITH
THE WILDFIRE RESILIENCE PACKAGE
THERE IS SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
THAT PACKAGE- IT IS PROPOSES
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND IN THE
BUDGET YEAR SIX MILLION
DOLLARS- UNDERSTANDING IS THAT.
THEY ARE COMPLEMENTARY OF. THAT
ONE AND AB THIRTY EIGHT-
PROGRAM THIS MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE WILD RESILIENCE PACK WOULD
BE TO- TO AUGMENT THE BASELINE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE PROGRAM.
PROBABLY UTILIZING A SEASONAL
INSPECTORS- FOR AN ADDITIONAL
YEAR CHIO- SO- WITHOUT THE IN
IN TERMS OF THIS PARTICULAR- WE
DO RECOMMEND APPROVAL OF MOST
OF THE PROPOSAL IT DOES ALIGN
AND IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE-
NEW STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS SEN
AB THIRTY EIGHT WE DID HAVE A
COUPLE OF- TECHNICAL AND OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS. ONE JUST
TECHNICAL SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS AS WE DO
SUGGEST- THAT D. OF FUNDING
THAT IS REQUESTED FOR TRAINING
OF VEHICLE PROCUREMENT THE
POSITION BE APPROVED JUST A ONE
TIME BASIS WE DON'T THINK THE
THERE'S BEEN A WORKLOAD-
JUSTIFICATION FOR PROVIDING
THOSE POSITION ON AN ONGOING
BASIS. AND THERE'S ALSO A
REQUEST IN HERE FOR A FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS ON A
ONE TIME BASIS. BY THE FIRE
ENGINE FOR THE SOUTHERN TRADING
ACADEMY- WE RECOMMEND REJECTING
NAPPIES BECAUSE NOT DIRECTLY
RELATED TO IMPLEMENTING AB
THIRTY EIGHT. A TWO OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS ONE IS- SOME
ADDING SOME REPORTING LANGUAGE
ON THE WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS PROGRAM THIS ISN'T BECAUSE
OF ANY PARTICULAR CONCERN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT APPROACH TO
ESTIMATING WORKLOAD BUT SIMPLY
AN ACKNOWLEDGEMENT. AS YOU
HEARD FROM THE DEPARTMENT THIS
IS A NEW RESPONSIBILITY AND
THERE IS SOME UNCERTAINTY ABOUT
THE NUMBER OF INSPECTIONS
THAT'LL BE REQUIRED OUR
RECORDS. AS WELL AS THE AMOUNT
OF TIME THAT'LL BE NECESSARY
AND IT SHOULD BE IN THIS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE- INDICATE
THAT FORGET WORKLOAD TO DO
THESE- INSPECTIONS IS HIGHER
THAN ANTICIPATED THAT COULD END
UP REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT TO
DIVERT RESOURCES FROM UP THE
PROGRAMS SUCH AS BASELINE.%
DEFENSIBLE SPACE PROGRAM CHECK
TO MEET THIS REQUIRED WORKLOAD
ITSELF WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO HAVE
THAT INFORMATION IN THE FUTURE
TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE-
PROPER AMOUNT OF RESOURCES.
PROVIDED TO THE DEPARTMENT. AND
ALLOW. DOESN'T POLICY GESTURE
IS FOR THE LEGISLATURE NEWMAN.
TO CONSIDER OPTIONS TO MAKE
DISCO RELAY AND- FEE BASED. FOR
ASSIST US INTO REASONABLE.
THING TO CONSIDER OF TWO
REASONS WHY EIGHT IT. BECAUSE
THIS. IS PROVIDING EITHER
SERVICE TO. OWNERS AND SO IT
SEEMS LIKE IT'S A REASONABLE
SHE BASED. AT BUT ALL BECAUSE
THE EXTENT WE COULD GENERATE
FEE REVENUES TO SUPPORT THIS
PROGRAM- THAT WOULD OFFSET
FUTURE. COSTS. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU QUESTIONS. ISRAEL THIS.
THANK YOU ARE SO OF THE L. A.
O. LIKE YOU JUST MENTIONED
PROPOSED THAT WE CONSIDER
CHARGING HOMEOWNERS A FEE FOR
THE A DEFENSIBLE SPACE
INSPECTIONS- WHO DO WE KNOW
WHERE THE ADMINISTRATION STANDS
ON THIS FEE PROPOSAL. WE HAVE
WITH ACID APARTMENT ON A BUT I
SHOULD PROBABLY LET FIFTY FOR
SELF. GOOD MORNING AT TWENTY
CALLING AGAIN I'M- WE HAVE.
CONTEMPLATED AND- OBVIOUSLY THE
L. A- SUGGESTION ON THE FEET
STUDY FOR A FEE- ONE OF THE BIG
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE IS THAT-
IT. WHILE AT IT MAY LOOK LIKE-
A SERVICE THE PARTICULAR
HOMEOWNER. REALLY ALLOW THE IT
IS TRULY PAR- DEFENDING THE
FAITH IN THE FRA FROM ANY
STRUCK FIRE THAT MADE. SO IS.
THAT'S ONE OF IT THE OTHER PART
IS- WE'VE TRIED FRA HI PLEASE
IN THE- I IT. LED TO SOME.
AUTHORITIES SOME AREAS AND WE
REALLY TO DO IS PICKING IN
THOSE AREAS AND BE PARTNERS-
ENABLING US TO REALLY PROVIDE
THE BAD THAT DEFENSE IN ALL OF
THOSE AREAS AND TO PROTECT THE
FRA- FROM ANY SORT OF STRUCTURE
FIRE THAT COMES THROUGH SO I
THINK THERE WOULD BE TO BE-
MORE DISCUSSION FOR SOME SORT
OF- RAILED MAY BE PUT INTO.
FIFTY ONE FACTOR- I DO DON'T
WANT TO AS- THE DAMAGE THE
MORNING. THAT BEEN BILL WITH
ALL OF OUR PARTNER IN. AND THE
FIRE CAN'T. IN THE CAN- IT'S A
FEE THE REALLY BENEFIT EVERY IN
THE STATE INCLUDING WILDLIFE
AND WATERSHED PROTECTION. HI
I'M- IN THE I'M SORRY. IN
ADDITION THE DIP DOESN'T HAVE
THE DOOR TO CALL A FEE AT THIS
POINT TIME- SO WE'RE THERE
WOULD NOT AT WITHOUT TO BE TAKE
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN. OKAY THANK
JUST ONE MORE PRESS POUND FOR
THE L. A- YOU KNOW- AGAIN ON
THE PROPOSAL HOW WOULD THIS FEE
PROPOSAL AFFECT CONTRACTS
CITIES ANY CONTRACT COUNTIES
SUCH AS LOS ANGELES. THAT
ALREADY HAVE MUCH HIGHER
DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTION
RATES THAN CAL FIRE. SO I
IMAGINE IF THE- IF THE
LEGISLATURE DID IT DECIDE TO
MAKE A POLICY CHANGE AND AS THE
DIRECTOR MENTIONED IT WOULD
REQUIRE- LEGISLATIVE CHANGE TO
GIVE THE AUTHORITY TO. CHARGE A
FEE TO HOMEOWNERS ON THESE
INSPECTIONS- I THINK HE WOULD
WANT TO DO THAT PROVIDE THAT
SAME AUTHORITY TO THE CONTRACT
COUNTY AS WELL AND THAT. THEY
COULD DO- DO THAT IN A WAY THAT
ALLOWED THEM TO OFFSET THEIR
COSTS THE PROPOSAL IN FRONT OF
YOU TODAY THE GENERAL FUND
PROPOSAL WOULD INCLUDE FINDING
THAT WOULD GO TO CONTRACT
COUNTIES TO DO THE SAME WORK ON
SRD. LANDS OKAY THANK YOU. YES
SOMEONE FREE BUT ASK A FOLLOW
UP IT'S MORE OF A COMMON WHICH
IS THE I ON THE RUSH FOR NOT
HOW A FEW GENERAL AND A SPACE
WORK WHERE YOU'RE TRYING TO
ENCOURAGE THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY TO ME OFTEN MAKE AN
INVESTMENT TO CLEAR THAT
PROPERTY- ONCE YOU BRING BACK
YOUR REPORT ON THE OTHER HAND I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
JUSTIFICATION FOR DURING REAL
ESTATE TRANSACTIONS- THERE ARE
MANY COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
SIMILAR KIND OF POINT OF SALE
INSPECTIONS- AND WHEN SOMEONE
SPENDING YOU KNOW LARGE AMOUNTS
OF MONEY PURCHASING A PROPERTY
I THINK IT DOES BEHOOVE THEM TO
HAVE. THAT REPORT NOT BECAUSE
THEY'RE KIND OF WALKING IN A
LITTLE BLOCK AND MAYBE DON'T
EVEN UNDERSTAND THE
REQUIREMENTS BUT I THINK IF
WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT A WAY OF
DOING THIS THAT IS A LITTLE BIT
MORE EQUITABLE THAT DOING IT
YOU KNOW AS PART OF A REAL
ESTATE TRANSACTION AT LEAST
WOULD HELP GENERATE SOME
REVENUE AND PROBABLY NOT GET
THE KIND OF PUSH THAT YOU WOULD
GET IF YOU JUST START. CHARGING
THIS TO GENERAL HOMEOWNERS IN
THESE AREAS SO I HOPE THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S THOUGHT
ABOUT. AFTER IF I COULD ADD. MY
VOICE TO THIS NOT REAL. WERE
NOT. WE'RE NOT READY FOR THIS
YET BUT I DIDN'T VENTURA COUNTY
WE VERY SUCCESSFUL AT-
REQUIRING DEFENSIBLE SPACE. AND
THEN IF WE WENT AND SOMEBODY
WAS NOT DOING IT WE WERE THEN
ABLE TO CHARGE THEM- TO DO IT
AND- THERE MAY BE SOME APPROACH
HERE. THAT IF IT'S NOT DONE
PROPERLY IT'S IN EVERYBODY'S
BEST INTEREST TO HAVE IT DONE-
THAT- THAT'S WHERE WE CHARGE A
FEE- AND REQUIRE THE- SOME SOME
CONTRIBUTION AS A RESULT OF NOT
DOING IT PROPERLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- DOES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAVE ANY COMMENTS. HI
THIS IS A MORE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YOU CHAIR AT IT JUST
WANTED TO THAT IT RIGHT NOW AS
CHIEF BORDER MISSION WE DO NOT
HAVE STASHED THOR TO TRY YOU SO
WITH TO HAVE FOR DISCUSS TO.
EXPLORE THIS. THANK YOU. THAT
WILL TAKE US NOW TO NOT THREE
COME EMERGENCE RESPONSE AND
PREPARE. THANK YOU SURE BELOW
AND MEMBERS- IS THE FRAME UP
WHAT WE KIND OF COVERING IN
STROKES HERE IS- THIS ALL OF
THE ABOVE APPROACH. WELL IT'S
NOT POSSIBLE TO ELIMINATE
WILDFIRE RISK IN CALIFORNIA-
FOCUSED AND DELIBERATE ACTION
TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES- AND
IMPROVED JULES CONDITIONS ALLOW
CALIFORNIA TO BETTER COEXIST
WITH WILDFIRE- THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- FOCUSES ON PREVENTION-
A PRESS THAT INFRASTRUCTURE AS
WE ALREADY TALKED AS WELL AS
THE CO BENEFITS OF INCREASING.
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS BOOTS ON THE
GROUND- INTERNET- ACTING ON
THAT THAT ALSO INCLUDES THOSE
THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTORS
WERE TALKING ABOUT AND ISSUE
NUMBER THREE THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE WITH NOW. I KNOW
INDIVIDUAL TASK OR PROGRAM IS A
SILVER BULLET. AND EACH OF
THESE BUDGET ITEMS WORKS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE WITH THE
CO EXIST WITH THE EXISTING
EFFORTS IN PREVENTION AND
PROTECTING AGAINST WILDFIRE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. SO BEFORE
ISSUE NUMBER THREE I AM GOING
TO SHARE WITH THE WITH DIRECTOR
SAIDO OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS ARE OPENING
AND THEN WILL KICK IT TO-
DEPUTY DIRECTOR- CHIEF TYLER.
COMPLEX REPRESENTED. EIGHTY
FOUR ARE PRECISE TOOK OUT
CONSERVE CORPS DIRECTOR- I'M
PLEASE TO BE HERE AND THANK YOU
CHAIR BLOOM AND CAN MEMBER FOR
IN THIS- PRESIDENT ON ISSUE
THREE C. CITY COMMITTEE TO AN
AND PREPARE TO ROLL OUT THIS I
THINK ARE VERY AMBITIOUS- FIRE
EXPANSION PLANNED AND- WE'RE
READY TO GO- I'VE STUDENTS-
THIS COMMITTEE AND- LODGE
SENATOR PER OF CRUISES DCP BUT-
KNOW THAT WE SPEND A LOT OF
TIME AND DUE DILIGENCE TO. OUR
OUR CREATE THE RIGHT MIX AND
ALSO IN IN THE SENSE THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY DO WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING STAFF OF ALL OF IT
TO- I TO PORTAGE TO- CHIEF
DEPUTY TYLER TO PRESENT EXACTLY
WHAT THE STARK FIRE EXPANSION.
PROGRAM WILL LOOK LIKE. THANK
YOU DIRECT AND GOOD MORNING
BILLION GOOD MORNING TO THE
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS JOE NOT THE DEPUTY FOR
PROTECTION FOR CAL- IN THIS.
CAP AND CAL COME CORPS SILVA OF
ONE FORTY THREE. TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR MILLION. FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY THREE THOUSAND
IN GENERAL FUND PHASED IN OVER
FIVE YEARS WITH SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN POSITIONS AREN'T
GOING TO ACT THIRTY ADDITIONAL
HAND CREWS TO PROVIDE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
HAZARDOUS FUELS REDUCTION
PROJECTS AND WHAT ABOUT
WILDFIRE- SUPPRESSION ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
PROPOSAL STAFF. BARBARA
HANNIFIN OF SEVEN OF THE D.
POPULAR. ACONTECE CAMPS- THAT
WERE DEPOPULATED AS PART OF THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY. IT'LL STAFF EIGHT YEAR
ROUND CCC HAND CREWS AT FOR CCC.
AND STAFF SIX SEASONAL CCC
ANCHORS ADICIONAL. PARA
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
FACILITIES DURING FIRE SEASON.
IT'S IMPORTANT NOTE AS OF-
JANUARY I'M SORRY AS OF MARCH
ONE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT WILDFIRES BURNING
ONE THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
FIFTY ACRES COMPARED TO THE
SAME TIME FRAME IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY CALIFORNIA SOUTH FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE WILDLAND
FIRES TRACER. FIFTY SIX ACRES
IN THE FIVE YEAR AVERAGE RIGHT
AFTER THIS SAME TIME FRAME IS
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE FIRES
FOR TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
ACRES WHAT WE'RE HEARING TODAY
REPEAT THE TIME FRAME PLACE.
BLUM HAS MARCH ONE. TWO
THOUSAND ONE- BROWN SAID SO
FROM JANUARY FIRST TO FEBRUARY
TWENTY EIGHT FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
EIGHT WILDLAND FIRES FOR
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED FIFTY ACRES.
THAT SAME TIME FRAME IN. TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. WILDFIRES. FOR
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY SIX ACRES
AND I YOU LOOK AT A FIVE YEAR
TIME SPAN TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
ONE ACRES FOR TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE I'M SORRY TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE FIRES
FOR TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
ACRES. IS THE FIVE YEAR AVERAGE.
SO THE PROPOSAL TODAY- IS.
PRETTY BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S.
RECENT AND OF FIRE AVAIL TO
RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES. THE
DECREASE HAS RESULTED IN FEWER
NUMBER CREWS AVAILABLE.
AVAILABLE TO PERFORM. A
CRITICAL REDUCTION WORKING
COMMUNITIES IN VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT PROJECTS BEFORE
STYLE. TO GIVE A LITTLE HAS
CALVET HIS.THIS HAD A DESIGN OF
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY TYPE ONE
HAND CREWS INCLUDING A ONE
HUNDRED NINETY TWO FIRE CREWS
TO COOPERATIVE AGREEMENTS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE AND TWELVE ADDITIONAL
HAND CREWS OR OR CLOSE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS. AND THEN AN
ADDITIONAL FOUR CREWS THAT ARE
PART OF A TRAINING PROGRAM-
MULTI AGENCY TRAINING TRAINING
PROGRAM AT THE VENTURA TRAINING
CENTER. OVER THE LAST DECADE.
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CAMP PROGRAM HAS EXPERIENCED A
DECLINE OF INMATE FIREFIGHTERS
AVAILABLE TO FULLY STAFF ITS
FIRE CREWS. WHICH IS RESULTED
IN THE OPERATION IF YOU WERE
HAND CREWS TO SUPPORT CALPERS
OPERATIONS IN THE FLEET- WELL
WHAT I WOULD HAVE FIRE
SUPPRESSION AND HAZARDOUS FUEL
REDUCTION PROJECTS. AND THAT
RECOGNITION OF THIS TREND AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER THE- BUDGET
OF FIFTY THOUSAND TWENTY
REFLECTED A CONSOLIDATION OF
INMATE FIREFIGHTERS AND THE
POPULATION OF EIGHT CAMPUS OF
THESE BY CDC ARE. TODAY COOPER
CURRENTLY HAS AN APPROVED
DESIGN CAPACITY OF ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY EIGHT HAND CREWS. WITH
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY TWO CDCR CRUZ
TWELVE CCC CREWS ENFORCEMENT
TRAINING CENTER CREWS OUT OF
THIRTY CONSERVATION CAMPS. FOR
FIRE CENTERS. IN ONE TRAINING
CENTER. BUT UNFORTUNATELY DUE
TO A OF AND CO FIRE WE'RE ONLY
ABLE TO STAY UP TO OF SIX FIVE
SIXTY FIVE. OF THE ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY EIGHT FULLY TRAINED AND
QUALIFIED FIREFIGHTING HAND
CREWS AS A CHOI AS OF FEBRUARY
TWENTY FOURTH OF THISYEAR.
ANOTHER SIXTEEN HAND CREWS ARE
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE TO THEIR
LOCAL AREAS BUT THEY HAVE TO
FEW CREWMEMBERS TO BE A TYPED
IN FULLY QUALIFIED HAND CREW BY
STATE NATIONAL STANDARDS. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THE FIRE
CREWS ARE ONE OF THE MOST
VERSATILE AND SPECIALIZED
RESOURCES COPPER UTILIZES FOR
FIRE SUPPRESSION. BY CLEARING
VEGETATION AWAY FROM AN
ONCOMING WILDFIRE OFTENTIMES
ALONE WITHOUT HOSE LINES AND
ALWAYS SUPPORTED BY
FIREFIGHTING AIRCRAFT IN THE
TOOLS THAT THEY HAVE IN THEIR
HANDS. THEY ACCESS AND SUPPRESS
FIRES BURNING IN MORE REMOTE
AND INACCESSIBLE TERRAIN WERE
BULLDOZERS AND OTHER HEAVY.
HEAVY MECHANIZED EQUIPMENT. I
CANNOT TRAVERSE WITHOUT AN
ADEQUATE NUMBER HANDY FOR USE
FIRES WILL GROW LARGER IN THE
STATE RESULTING IN INCREASED
DAMAGE TO WILDLIFE AND
WATERSHEDS. I WILDLIFE
FISHERIES AND AIR QUALITY. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE. THAT NGUYEN
NOT NOT RESPONDING TO
EMERGENCIES THE FIRE CREWS
ENGAGE IN FUEL REDUCTION
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
PRESCRIBED FIRE AND FOREST
HEALTH PROJECTS A RECENT REVIEW
OF CALAVERAS CREE UTILIZATION
SHOWN AT THE SEVEN OF THE EIGHT
CONSOLIDATED CONSERVATION CAMPS
IN A PERIOD THAT OF A THREE
YEAR AVERAGE FROM TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN TO NINETEEN THE
CALIFORNIA CREE SPENT 25% MORE
TIME ON CONSERVATION RELATED
PROJECT WORK THE MOST SPENT ON
FIRE SIGNS. NOT TO THOUSAND
TWENTY WAS DEVASTATING AND
THAT'S REASON WE DID THE PRIOR
THREE YEAR AVERAGE. CALVET HAS
YOU CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD
CREWS ARE GONNA FIRE CREWS. AND
IF THOUSAND TWENTY FIRE SEASON
THE ADMINISTRATION ARE GOING TO
THE EMERGENCY FUND TO ADD BOTH
ADDITIONAL SEASONAL CCC CREW
MEMBERS FIRE CREWS IN EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX HARPER THE
ACT. IS NOT FIRE CREW MEMBERS
AS PART OF A FLEXIBLE
FIREFIGHTERS SEARCH CAPACITY.
IN THIS PROPOSAL CAUGHT FIRES
REQUESTING THE STAFF- FOR THE
SIXTEEN FIREFIGHTER CREWS THAT
WE OPERATED OUT OF SEVEN OF THE
CONSERVATION CAMPS THAT HAVE
BEEN DEPOPULATED. IS PART OF
THE CAMP CONSOLIDATION
INCLUDING DEVIL'S GARDEN
CHAMBERLAIN CREEK IROC VALLEY
VIEW. BASELINE PILOT ROCK AND
RAINBOW CAMPS. THESE CREWS WILL
BE STAFFED TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK NINE
MONTHS A YEAR FROM MARCH
FIFTEENTH TO DECEMBER
FIFTEENTH- STAFF WITH A FIRE
CAPTAIN FIRE APPARATUS ENGINEER
AND A MINIMUM OF THIRTEEN
SEASONAL FIREFIGHTER ONES. ARE
THAT WILL PERFORM FUEL
REDUCTION AND FIRE PREVENTION
PROJECT WORK WERE NOT ASSIGNED
TO EMERGENCY INCIDENTS. THIS
MODEL WILL PROVIDE THIRTY ONE
ADDITIONAL CREW DAYS OR TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS A YEAR
WITHIN THAT NINE MONTH
FIREFIGHTER CREW THAT ARE
TRADITIONAL HAND CREAM MODEL.
UTILIZING IT MAY FIRE CREWS AT.
TWO HUNDRED FORTY NINE DAYS-
PARTLY. DUE TO- HOLIDAYS AND
VISITS. THAT WE NEED TO. OUR
AND MAKE. FIREFIGHTERS WORK AT
SEVENTY TWO HOUR SHOW IN WITH
THE DAY WEEK COVER CAN YOU OUR
DUTY THE BACKFIELD CREE ONCE
IT'S CA. AT EMERGE ANSWERED.
THIS CAN BE YOU FOR COVERAGE
BEHIND THE FIRE COULD COME
EMERGE INCIDENT OF THE MERGER
RESPONSE THE NEW. STAFFING
SIXTEEN FIREFIGHTERS STATEWIDE
WILL PROVIDE A CALIFORNIA TO
SEARCH THE THIRTY TWO
FIREFIGHTING CREWS AT TIMES A
CRITICAL NEED IN ADDITION THE
FIREFIGHTING CREWS WILL BE
STAFFED AGAIN. TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
AS IT RELATES TO OUR RELAY.
WITH CAL COMES CORPS AS I SAID
WE'VE HAD TWELVE YEAR ROUND
PARKER'S STAFF STATEWIDE
DIVERSE RELATIONSHIP. COOPER
AND THE CCC REQUEST AFTER SIX
IT TO STAFF- TO TRANSITION SIX
EXISTING REIMBURSEMENT CCC
CREWS OF THE TYPE ONE FIRE
CREWS. WHICH CRUISE AND LAKE
TAHOE. TO A DOCTOR'S STYLE HAS.
STOCKTON DELTA SORRY ABOUT THAT
AND I'VE BEEN IN THE U. PRIOR
WILL ITS AREA. IN ADDITION THE
PROPOSAL ADDS ANOTHER TWO
EXPANSION CRUISED TO THE LOS
PINOS CENTER. THE REQUESTED
CLUES AN OFFSET OF ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION IN YEAR ONE AND
TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION
STARTING YAR TWO FROM THE
FOLLANDO CAN. REIMBURSEMENT
ACCOUNT TO REFLECT THAT THE SIX
EXISTING REIMBURSEMENT CREWS
WILL TRANSITION. TO BE FULLY
FUNDED BY THE GENERAL FUND.
POSO ALSO FOR TO STAY SIX CCC.
THE WAY TO. EMERGE HERE
CAPABILITIES. DURING THE PEAK
FIRE. ACTIVITY PERFORM.
MANAGEMENT HAZARDOUS WE WHEN
THEY NOT THIS I OVER TO
INCIDENT. FINALLY IT'S
IMPORTANT TO. THAT THE AND
EQUIPMENT CAN WITHIN PROPOSED
ARE CALM OF. BECAUSE IN A QUICK
FROM THE DEEP POP CAMPS ARE
FROM THOSE EIGHT CONSERVE CAMP
AS WELL AS NEW BECAUSE THEY
THAT THE OP NEEDS OF CAREERS.
THE STRONG WORKING THAT WE HAVE
FOR BETWEEN CALPERS. AND CDCR
PROVIDE HAND CREWS. TO CONDUCT
FIRE SUPPRESSION FUEL REDUCTION
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WORK
RELATED TO- RELATED WORK THAT'S
BEEN OUTSTANDING AND CONTINUES
TO GROW IN THAT RELATIONSHIP.
NOW YOU'RE GONNA HEAR FROM THE
L. A. O. I REPORT THAT THEY
RECOMMEND. AND SUGGEST A
VARIETY OF OPTIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER BEFORE
ACTING ON THIS PROPOSAL AND AS
SUCH I'D LIKE TO OFFER THE
COMMITTEE SOME ADDITIONAL ITEMS
TO CONSIDER. WHEN CONSIDERING
THE USE OF AUGMENTED OR MUTUAL
AID LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAND CREWS
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THERE ARE ONLY FOURTEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TYPE ONE HAND CREWS
AVAILABLE ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THOSE HAND CREWS
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO THEIR
LOCAL JURISDICTION FIRST AND
FOREMOST. AND REGIONALLY OR
STATEWIDE ONLY IF AVAILABLE TO
RESPOND ACROSS THE STATE. THE
STATE DOES NOT CONTROL THESE
RESOURCES. LOCAL GOVERNMENT
DAILY RATES ARE HIGHER THAN THE
PROPOSAL HERE. WHERE CAL FIRE
ESTIMATES ARE DAILY COST OF THE
CREW TO BE ELEVEN THOUSAND.
EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY SIX
DOLLARS A DAY. OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COOPERATORS AND
ASSESS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FOR REIMBURSEMENT OF THEIR
RESOURCES AND TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY. TWELVE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED NINETY THREE DOLLARS A
DAY TO SEVENTEEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT DOLLARS A
DAY. AND THAT WAS VERIFIED
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
SYSTEMS AGREEMENT REIMBURSEMENT
INVOICES RECEIVED IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. WHEN LOOKING
AT OTHER CREE TYPES IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW CALPERS BEEN
WORKING THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
TO BUILD FIRE CREWS BY ADDING
ADDITIONAL CCC FIRE CREWS ARE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL. A GUARD
THE POOL OF AVAILABLE NON STATE
FIRE RESOURCE IS EXTREMELY
LIMITED AND CONSISTS OF THE
UNITED STATES FOR SERVICE CREWS
THAT ARE CONTROL RESPONSE FROM
BOISE IDAHO FOR NATIONAL
RESPONSE OUR PRIVATE CONTRACTOR
USED CONTRACT COUNTY AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FIRE CREWS THAT ARE
DESCRIBED. IN RELATION TO OUR
LESS COSTLY ALTERNATIVES IT'S
IMPORTANT. TO VALUE OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH A SIXTY SEVEN
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THROUGH THAT THAT SOME C. C. C.
APPLICANTS ARE NOT INTERESTED
IN BECOMING FIREFIGHTERS
POTENTIAL CORE MEMBERS JOIN THE
CCC TO CONDUCT WORK OTHER THAN
FIREFIGHTING. FOR MANY OTHER
CONSERVATION RELATED
OPPORTUNITIES THE CCC REPORTS
BOTH EMERGENCY RESPONSE AND
PUBLIC SERVICE CONSERVATION
WORK AS AN EXAMPLE. THE CCC
CREWS ARE CURRENTLY SUPPORTING
MASS VACCINATION SITES FOOD
BANKS THE STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER. A REVISION CONTROL AND
BERNARD- RESTORATION DEMANDS
AND ASSISTING TREE MORTALITY
ISSUES IN THE SIERRAS
ENDANGERED SPECIES HABITAT AND
PROJECTS SUCH. AS THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PRIOR- GRAHAM
THANK BE A CALL BY TIME CREWS.
THIS HAS I'M MORE THAN YEARS A
CARRYING OUT VALUABLE CRITICAL
ENVIRONMENT PROJECTS-
CALIFORNIA MISSION AND
COMMITMENT TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA IS TO CONTINUE TO
SUSTAIN THEIR WORK AND SERVICE
TO THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES.
FINALLY NOT RELATED TO COST. UP
A SEASONAL FIREFIGHTER ONE'S
BASE SALARY IS 400-010-0404
DOLLARS 250-003-0012 DOLLARS
PER MONTH. WORKING EIGHT TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY OUR TWENTY EIGHT
DAY- WORK PERIOD ENSURING THE
STATE IN THE CITIZENS AND
VISITORS THAT THEY HAVE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE COVERAGE
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THE SEASONAL
FIREFIGHTERS THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING HERE IS PART OF THIS
PROPOSAL ENTER THEIR CAREER AT
APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN DOLLARS
THIRTY CENTS AN HOUR UP TO
EIGHTEEN DOLLARS FORTY CENTS AN
HOUR. FINALLY IF- CHAIR BLAME
WILL ALLOW ME- A MOMENT ALL
ANSWERED A QUESTION FROM A FROM
AN EARLIER ASK IF SHE ORDER AND
THAT WAS- THE S. SEVENTY I.
HELICOPTER FLEET. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE THREE HELICOPTERS- IN
CALIFORNIA ONE OF MCCLELLAN ONE
AND FINING YOU'RE CHICO ONE YET
COLOMBIAN YOUR SONORA. AT TODAY
ARE STAFFERS LEAVING IT PICK UP
TO ADDITIONAL HELICOPTERS IN
COLORADO. THAT WILL BE FLOWN
OUT BY THE END OF THE WEEK
AFTER THIRTY DAYS OF NEAR SEA
LEVEL TESTING. BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T DO THAT IN COLORADO- IN
THOSE TWO HELICOPTERS WILL GO
TO HEMET RYAN IN THE RIVERSIDE
AREA AND BOGGS. IN THE NAPA
AREA. WE WOULD EXPECT TO MORE
HELICOPTERS COMING IN IN THE
MIDDLE OF FIRE SEASON IF. OUR
FIRE SEASON IS IT A AT A SLOW
PACE AT THAT MOMENT TIME WE
WILL TRAIN CREWS INTO THOSE NEW
HELICOPTERS AS WELL- AND
CURRENTLY WELL WE DID HAVE SOME
INITIAL CO THAT DELAY IS I
APPEARS THAT WE ARE ON
SCHEDULE. ETCHER BLOOM AND
FELLOW MEMBERS WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND PERCENT THAT THIS
PROPOSAL TO YOU AND WE'RE HAPPY.
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU FELT A LOT OF.
AND- A- I'M GONNA SOME TIME TO
DIED IT I AND HAVE MORE FOR YOU-
AT AT- FUTURE HEARING- BUT OF
THE MASK OF MY COLLEAGUES TO
FURTHER ANY. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT WELL- YOU
REFERENCED- THAT THE L. A. O.
HAS A LOT TO SAY ABOUT THIS
TOO- AND- WHEN IT WILL ALLOW
THE L. A. O. TO MAKE ITS
PRESENTATION NOW. THANK YOU
PRIME BROWN WITH L. A. AGAIN-
SO WITH REGARD TO THIS PROPOSAL
WE DO THINK THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT VALUE IN
CONSIDERING THIS PROPOSAL-
PARTICULARLY FOR THE ADDITIONAL
FIRE RESPONSE CAPACITY. THAT IT
WOULD PROVIDE GIVEN THE
DECLINING INMATE CONSERVATION
CAMP POPULATION WHICH HAS GONE
DOWN BY. ROUGHLY A THOUSAND
OVER THE LAST DECADE AND SO
THAT REALLYDOES DIMINISH
IMPORTANT. RESOURCE FOR- FIRE
FIRE PROTECTION AS WELL AS-
FUEL PRODUCTION. I'M WE DO
THINK THOUGH THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT ONGOING GENERAL
FUND COMMITMENT. AND THEREFORE
IMPORTANT THINK ABOUT IT AGAIN
AND IN THE CONTEXT OF THE-
BROADER GENERAL FUND
CONDITIONAL OFFICE AND FINANCE
HAS. PROJECTED TO BE- IN A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT IN FUTURE
YEARS. HI IN ADDITION PROBABLY
ALSO WORTH CONSIDERING HOW THIS
ALIGNS WITH WHAT YOU ULTIMATELY
CHOOSE TO DO ON THE WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE PACKAGE. AS IS THE
PRESENTERS NOTED EARLIER THE
FIRE CREW PROVIDE BOTH RESPONSE
CAPACITY AS WELL AS PREVENTION
MITIGATION- TYPE BENEFITS IN-
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT THAT IS A
PARTICULAR. FOCUS OR INTEREST
OF THE COMMITTEE YOU MAY WANT
TO THINK ABOUT WHETHER THESE-
FIRE CREWS ARE THE BEST WAY TO
PROVIDE THOSE ADDITIONAL-
PREVENTION MITIGATION ACTIVITY-
BENEFITS. OF VERSUS- INVESTING
SOME OF THESE DOLLARS IN OTHER
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE PART OF
YOUR BURKE RESILIENT PACKAGE
THAT YOU ALTERNATELY ADOPT- YOU
OTHER POINTS NAY ONE EIGHT
EIGHT. AS CHIEF NOTED WE DO
THINK THAT YOU THE SPRING ALSO
TO WORK WITH THE MINISTRY TO.
WHY THERE ARE OFF. TO EXPAND HE
CREW THE- IN ADDITION TO OR OR-
IN PART REPLACE OF THIS
PROPOSAL A PARTLY BECAUSE OF IT
IS AN EXPENSIVE PROPOSAL AND-
WE KNOW THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS DONE A LOT IN RECENT YEARS
TO LOOK AT OTHER OPTIONS TO
EXPAND HAND CREWS. AS SHE
TALENTED THE USE OF
CONSERVATION CORPS NATIONAL
GUARD PAROLEES AND SO WE DO
THINK THERE IS VALUE IN USING
THE SPRING PROCESS TO LOOK
WHETHER. FOR OUR OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES WHETHER THAT'S
WORKING WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE FINDING OTHER WAYS TO
EXPAND THE PRO THE- PROGRAM- OR
OTHER YOU UTILIZE OTHER. OF
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS JUST EXAMPLES WE
DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC PROPOSAL
BUT AGAIN WE THINK YOU CAN JUST
BRING PROCESS TO EXPLORE THE-
AND AN UNDERSTANDING WITH THE
RELATIVE COST TRADE OFFS AND-
IN PROGRAMMATIC BENEFITS WOULD.
BE IS THAT COULD BE IMPORTANT.
AND LASTLY REALLY JUST WROTE A
PRETTY MINOR TECHNICAL ISSUE IS
THAT A VERY SMALL SHARE OF THE
PROPOSAL HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS. IS FOR- CAL FIRE TO
WORK WITH CAL HR TO EXPLORE A
NEW CLASSIFICATION- THAT WOULD
IDEA WOULD BE POTENTIALLY. IF
THEY DIDN'T IF THEY DETERMINE
THAT WAS WARRANTED CREATE A NEW
CLASSIFICATION FOR THESE CAL
FIGHTER FIRE CREWS IN INSTEAD
OF USING FIREFIGHTER ONES IN
THE FUTURE. WE THINK
UNDERTAKING THAT IF THE
ANALYSIS IS INVALUABLE WE DON'T
DISPUTE THAT IT COULD FOR
EXAMPLE- IN THE LONG RUN REDUCE
COST IF YOU COULD UTILIZE A-
LOWER PAY CLASSIFICATION
POTENTIALLY AND ALSO
POTENTIALLY EXPAND. THE
ELIGIBLE POOL OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT COULD FILL THAT THE
TRADITION WE JUST HAVE A LITTLE
BIT OF A CONCERN ABOUT WHETHER
THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING REQUEST
IT IS THE RIGHT AMOUNT IT WOULD
FIND. ESSENTIALLY THREE
POSITIONS ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
FOR SEVERAL YEARS AND SO ON
THAT ISSUE JUST LIKE THAT COULD
YOU HAVE AN OPTION IT WORK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT TO. IDENTIFY
WITH THE RIGHT LEVEL OF
RESOURCES. WOULD BE SHOULD THE
AND A LOT OF WANNA MOVE FORWARD
THIS FOR. THANK YOU- THAT OF
FINANCE COMMENTS. NOTHING THANK
YOU THANK YOU CHIEF TYLER AND I
HAVE YOUR BACK FOR A MOMENT- ON
THIS ISSUE OF- A FIRE CREWS AND
THEIR- PREVENTION FUNCTION- AS
YOU. ARE A WELL AWARE THE SUB
COMMITTEE HAD A- A EARLY
HEARING ON FIRE PREVENTION AND-
THE GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED EARLY
ACTION. ON. PROVIDING FUNDING
FOR FIRE. VENTION MEASURES AND
ALL HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY ABOUT
IT WHEN WE GET TO- ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE OUT OF WHY NOT- WHY IS
THIS THE BEST MIX OF- A NEW
RESOURCES WHEN IT COMES TO THE
ISSUE OF PREVENTION. I BELIEVE-
IS CHEAP ORDER- MENTION IN HIS
OPENING THAT- THAT. IT IS NOT A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL OUR VARIOUS
CREW TYPES. WILL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE- THAT FUNCTION AND AS I
MENTIONED- THE- THE FIRE CREWS
THAT ARE REFERRED TO IN THIS
PROPOSAL WHEN NOT ASSIGNED TO
EMERGENCY RESPONSE I WILL BE
CONTINUING THAT WORK- RIGHT
ALONGSIDE THE PRESCRIBED FIRE
CREWS OF THE FUEL REDUCTION
CREWS THAT ARE. PROPOSED AND-
IN EARLY ACTION AND WELFARE
RESILIENCE TO BE ABLE TO MEET
THE TARGET GOALS OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- TO BE ABLE TO-
IMPROVE FOREST HEALTH- AND
PROVIDE A FUEL REDUCTION
PROJECTS ACROSS THE STATE. I
THINK A COMBINATION OF THESE
RESOURCES- IS. IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE STATE
CALIFORNIA'S ITS CITIZENS TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE. THAT GREAT
WORK. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
RESPONSE AND- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. BECAUSE
OF THE NEXT ITEM. ONE NEXT THE.
NO WE'RE WE'RE A FORCE
RESILIENCE IS GOING TO BE-
ISSUE FIVE. YOU'RE WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
PROCEED NOW TO- ISSUE NUMBER.
FOUR THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
WILL DISCUSS CONTINUING
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE AIR
PROTECTION PROGRAM. ONE SHERMAN
WAY ALONG PARTS OF THE DAY MY
NAME IS CHIANG I'M AT THAT
EXACT OFFICE WITHOUT UNIVERSAL
FOR AND I'M HERE TO MAKE TALK
ABOUT OUR FOR FUNDING FOR TWO
FORTY FISH AND- EMPLOYMENT
NEEDS. FOR SO AB SIX OR SEVEN
ACT BY THE WEAPONS IN. SEVEN A
NEW PARADIGM FOR HOW FAR YOU
CAN. AT THE. CALIFORNIA WHAT
FLIPS TWO CONVENTION IN THE
YOUR. WHAT EIGHTY SIX. FIFTY
BROWN'S CABLE FUND AND BECAUSE
THIS WASN'T FIRM WORK FOR THE
**** DOES. TWENTY TWO NUMBER. I
REQUEST OF ON ON FOR THE.
TWENTY FIFTY MINUTES THIS IS.
THANK ABOUT RECOMMENDATIONS
WAITING EIGHTY EIGHT AND DAILY
CONVERSATIONS WITH MINISTRY
MORE THAN ONE GROUP I WORK WITH
LOCAL EXPECTS A RESPONSE MANY
CONCERNS ITSELF. THE ALL HM.
THESE KIND PENSIONS ARE ONE TO
EIGHTY SIX POINT SEVEN INCOME
WE ARE RIGHT ACROSS THE. ARM
MARKETS IT'S- IN THE FISCAL
NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE AND THE
OTHER GOODNESS BECAUSE
LEGISLATURE DR SUPPLEMENTS OVER
LANGUAGE WITH ARE REPORTER OFF.
EIGHTY SIX SEVEN. WE TRANSIT
THAT SUPPLEMENTS OR REPORT WHAT
THE BALL AND I KNOW THE- YEAH.
I'M I WON TO BE AN OVER OF THE
PART POSITION THANK OUR HAPPY
THAT'S THE REPORT WITH THE L.
A. THE FACT DETAIL. AT AFTER
REVIEW OF THE- SRL REPORT WHICH-
WE JUST RECEIVED YESTERDAY SO
I'M HOPING THIS IS NOT TO
BECOMING A TREND LINE- WERE
RECEIVING REPORTS SAID ON THE
ON THE EVE OF HEARINGS BECAUSE
IT MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR
US TO- FULFILL OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES OF OVERSIGHT.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS.
THREE OF US JUST ASK ONE AT
YOUR NEXT OKAY I'M- HERE TO GET
TOO SLOW ON THE DRAW. FOR A-
THANK YOU CHAIR- I IN ADDITION
TO NEEDING MORE INFORMATION
FROM THE R. B. ABOUT THE NEED
FOR- ITS POSITIONS OF WE NEED
MORE INFORMATION FROM THE AIR
DISTRICTS OF COURSE HE GAINED
SIGNIFICANT APPROPRIATIONS FOR
THEIR COST OF ADMINISTERING AB
SIX ONE SEVEN- I'D LIKE TO ASK
EACH- DISTRICT- IN PARTICULAR
SOUTH COAST SAN JOAQUIN IN THE
BAY AREA FOR A CLEAR SCHEDULE
THAT INCLUDES THE DATES. OF
WHICH LARGE INDUSTRIAL SOURCES
ARE EXPECTED TO INSTALL OF THE
BEST AVAILABLE RETROFIT CONTROL
TECHNOLOGY- IN KEEPING WITH AB
SIX ONE SEVEN SKI REQUIREMENT
THAT THE SOURCES IMPLEMENT-
BARK BY THE END OF. TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. SO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU FOR THAT- AND
THAT THERE IS INFORMATION ON
OUR WEBSITE THAT RELATES TO
SCHEDULE THAT THE DISTRICTS
HAVE LAID OUT HOW THEY WE HAD
TO ADDRESS THOSE PARKS
DEPARTMENT. AS YOU KNOW THE
YOUR DISTRICTS ARE AGE THERE IN.
HARPER AND WILL DEFINITELY WORK
WITH I. AND THEIR DISTRICTS
RESPONSIBLE. OKAY THANK YOU.
THAT'S A BETTER FIT WITH THE
REQUEST FOR A NEW POSITION I'VE-
JUST YOU KNOW THAT I WILL
CONTINUE TO- ABOUT- WILLING TO-
REVISIT THE CAP AND TRADE
ARRANGEMENTS THAT WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW- I THINK MOST PEOPLE WOULD
WOULD- AGREE THAT. WE ARE NOT
GOING TO READ OUR MONEY- THIRTY
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS GOALS-
WITHOUT MODIFICATIONS AND- I
WOULD LIKE TO- SUGGESTED A
REQUEST FOR MORE RESOURCES-
PART OF THAT REQUEST FOR MORE
RESOURCE SHOULD BE- TO ADDRESS
WHAT IS IT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO DIFFERENT WITH CAP AND TRADE
TO TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
REACH- OF THOSE. THOSE
IMPORTANT GOALS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU- L.
A. L. AND- DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WERE FOUND WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
AT MISS CHANG MENTIONS OF THE
LEGISLATURE DID REQUIRING US
ARE- REPORT- THAT WAS INTENDED
TO KIND OF HELP INFORM- AND
OPERATIONAL WORKLOAD AND THE
NEED FOR ONGOING FUNDING FOR
THESE POSITIONS AND THAT WAS
JUST- TRANSMITTED LAST NIGHT SO
WE HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO
REVIEW THAT. WE WILL REVIEW THE
REPORT AND PROVIDE OUR UPDATED
COMMENTS RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE ONCE WE'VE HAD A
CHANCE TO GET OUT. THANK YOU
FINANCE. ZERO EIGHT APART IT'S
NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU. LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE I KNOW THIS
IS- GOING TO CONTAIN SOME LEVEL
OF DETAIL. IN THE REPORT SO
LET'S GET RIGHT INTO IT. THANKS
SO MUCH. YOUR BLOOMING MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'M I'M WAY
CROWFOOT ARE NATURAL RESOURCES
SECRETARY- FIRST OF ALL THANKS
FOR YOUR STEWARDSHIP. OF OUR
ENTIRE AGENCIES BUDGET- WHAT
YOU'RE ABLE TO DO YEAR IN AND
YEAR OUT ALLOWS US TO MEET THE
MISSION OUR NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY. SPECIAL THANKS TO YOU
CHERRY BLOOM FOR YOUR
STEADFASTNESS OVER SO MANY
YEARS- WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH IS TRULY POSSIBLE
BECAUSE OF THE PARTNERSHIP- IN
YOUR LEADERSHIP. I HELPING
STEWART IN SHAPE OUR OUR BUDGET
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE- BIG
BANKS AS WE DISCUSSED THIS
ISSUE A WILDFIRE RESILIENCE ON
EVERYTHING THAT YOU AND YOUR
LEGISLATIVE COLLEAGUES HAVE
DONE. TO COMBAT THE WILDFIRE
CRISIS IN THE STATE. ARE
CLEARLY HAS REPORTER
ARTICULATED BUILDING OUR
RESPONSE CAPACITY. IS ESSENTIAL.
VERY PROUD OF THE WORK OF. AND
I KNOW WE'RE ALL SO THANKFUL
FOR THE COURT COURAGE OF THE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO ARE FIGHTING
WILDFIRES IN OUR STATE. I YEAR
IN AND YEAR OUT. I SAY OFTEN
THAT WE'RE BLESSED IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE THE WORLD'S
MOST SOPHISTICATED WILDLAND
FIREFIGHTING FORCE AND THAT'S
TRUE. SO CONTINUING TO
STRENGTHEN OUR RESPONSE
CAPACITY IS ESSENTIAL. BUT
FRANKLY IT'S NOT ENOUGH. HOW WE
ARE LIVING THROUGH A REMARKABLE
PHENOMENON OF CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES IN OUR STATE. THERE
ARE A COUPLE OF KEY DATA POINTS.
SEVENTEEN OF THE LARGEST TWENTY
WILDFIRES IN OUR STATE A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY YEAR
HISTORY HAVE OCCURRED IN THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS. LAST SUMMER
FIVE OF THE SIX LARGEST
WILDFIRES IN OUR STATE OR
BURNING AT THE SAME TIME. NOW
SCIENCE IS CLEAR AYE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES ARE
RISKS ARE WORSENING AS A RESULT
OF WARMING WINTER AND SUMMER
TEMPERATURES. SO WE ALL KNOW
ABOUT THAT DECADES OF A POLICY
OF FIRE SUPPRESSION- THAT THAT
CREATED THESE CONDITIONS THAT
ARE NOW BECOMING WORSE AS AS A
RESULT. OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
AS WE SAID BEFORE AND WE'RE
THANKFUL TO THE LEGISLATURE'S
LEADERSHIP WE'RE NOT GOING TO
STICK OUR HEAD IN THE SAND-
ABOUT THE SCIENCE WE HAVE TO
FOLLOW THE SCIENCE WHICH TELLS
US WE NEED TO DO MORE. TO
COMBAT THE CRISIS SO IT'S BOTH
RESPONSE AND RESILIENCE AND
WHAT WE'LL TALK ABOUT TODAY IS
OUR WHAT WE PROPOSE AND WHAT
GOVERNOR NEWSOM PROPOSES TO BE
A QUANTUM LEAP OF INVESTMENT.
IN BUILDING A WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE AND BY WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE WE ESSENTIALLY MEAN
PROACTIVE UP FRONT ACTIONS THAT
WE CAN TAKE BEFORE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES EXIST I TO REDUCE THE
BOTH THE REST OF THOSE
WILDFIRES FROM GETTING SO LARGE
AND DANGEROUS BUT ALSO THE
THREATS. TO OUR PEOPLE ON OUR
PROPERTY AND OUR ENVIRONMENT
FROM- THOSE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES. AND IF WE THESE.
OUTWARDS OUR ACTIONS THEY WE
MAKE IS RESILIENCE INVESTMENTS
CORRECTLY WE WILL. BETTER
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
FIREFIGHTERS. RESTORE AND
MAINTAIN OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
PROVIDE ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES
ACROSS OUR STATE TO GET MORE
PEOPLE I ENGAGED IN THE
SOLUTION- TO BUILD OUR WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE. SO IN A MOENT ONE
OF MY COLLEAGUES IS GOING TO
SHARE DETAILS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL UPWARDS OF ONE BILLION
DOLLARS I TO IN BASS.
COMPREHENSIVELY ACROSS THE
SECTOR I TO BUILD OUR WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE. THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE BASED IN
PART ON AN ACTION PLAN. THAT
HAS BEEN DEVELOPED OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS WITH MY-
PARTNERS INCLUDING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
ALL MANNER OF STAKEHOLDERS-
THAT ACTION PLAN WHICH WAS
RELEASED IN JANUARY IS CALLED
THE WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCE ACTION PLAN. AND IT
COMES OUT OUT OF THE WORK OF
THE FOREST MANAGEMENT TASK
FORCE BEGAN. OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS SO THE BUDGET YOU'LL HEAR
ABOUT AND CONSIDER I IS BASED
ON THE INPUT. OVER THAT PERIOD
OF TIME AND BOTH THE ACTION
PLAN AND THE BUDGET REFLECTS
pDO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT AS WE TAKE
THE TIME. AND I'LL MENTION THAT
THESE PRINCIPLES. I HAVE
DEVELOPED AN ELEVATED- IN PART
THROUGH THE LEADERSHIP AND
ADVOCACY OF LEGISLATORS I
HELPING EDUCATE US WHAT'S
NEEDED ACROSS THE STATE SO A
FEW KEY PRINCIPLES. FIRST A
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION. NEEDS
TO ADDRESS BOTH. BETTER
MANAGEMENT OF OUR LANDSCAPES.
WHETHER THAT'S OUR PINE FOREST
THE SIERRA THE NORTH. FOR THE-
OAKWOOD LANE. I IN THE FOOT OF
THE VALLEY OR THIS. ENVIRONMENT
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THERE'S
MORE WE CAN DO ACROSS THE
LANDSCAPE. AT THE SAME TIME WE
HAVE TO INVEST MORE WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND AROUND OUR
COMMUNITIES TO REDUCE WILDFIRE
RISK. WHETHER THAT'S- FUEL
BREAKS THAT FLOWED ON FIRE
COMING IN THE COMMUNITIES. OR
HELPING DRIVE ACTIONS INCLUDING
EVACUATION PLANNING DEFENSIBLE
SPACE HOME HARDENING. SO FAR
PERSPECTIVE IT'S NOT A WAR
BETWEEN LANDSCAPER FOREST
MANAGEMENT AND COMMUNITY
INVESTMENT IF THEN AND- QUITE
NUMBER TWO- YOU'LL SEE IN THIS
PROPOSAL A PRIORITY ON DRIVING
RESOURCES TO REGIONALLY
TAILORED SOLUTIONS- WHAT WORKS
IN URBAN I SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
MAY NOT WORK IN THE RURAL
SIERRA NEVADA. WHAT WORKS IN-
THIS THE BAY AREA UP MAY NOT
WORK OUR AND IN JUST DIFFERENT-
THEN WHAT WORKS ON THE NORTH
COAST. WE CANNOT INVEST IN A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL SOLUTION FROM
SACRAMENTO SO WHAT YOU'LL HEAR
ABOUT IS INVESTING MORE IN A
REGIONAL PIPELINE A PROJECT
THAT ARE DEVELOPED. IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL AND
REGIONAL LEADERS THAT REALLY
ADDRESS THE UNIQUE WILDFIRE
RISKS THAN ANY PART OF THE
STATE. WE'RE ALSO INVESTING IN
DEEPENING PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND LOCAL
LOCAL- LAND MANAGEMENT
AGENCIES. SOMETIMES
PARTNERSHIPS CAN SOUND A LITTLE
BIT LIKE A TALKING POINT BUT
WHEN IT COMES TO BUILDING
WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
PARTNERSHIPS ARE ESSENTIAL.
CERTAINLY WITH THE FEDERAL
MANAGEMENT FEDERAL AGENCIES
THAT MANAGE 57% OF OUR STATE
FORESTS BUT ALSO WITH NUMEROUS
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT- WE NEED
TO. MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
SPENDING MONEY I'M IN IN CLOSE
ALIGNMENT WITH THOSE OTHER LAND
MANAGEMENT AGENCIES AND LEADERS.
ONE POINT I WANT TO MAKE IS THE
IMPORTANCE OF INVESTING IN OUR
REGIONAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AS WELL AS SMALL BUSINESS
INVESTMENT. I SIMPLY PUT WE
NEED MORE WORKERS TO DO THIS
WORK I'M WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
AND WE NEED MORE CALIFORNIA
BASED COMPANIES HOW TO ACTUALLY
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO GET THIS
WORK DONE. AS A RESULT OF A LOT
OF OUR INVESTMENT PARTICULARLY
RELATED TO UTILITY RELATED
WILDFIRES- THERE IS A WE HAVE A
DEARTH OF WORK FORCE TO
ACTUALLY MAKE THIS WORK HAPPEN.
SO PART OF OUR OUR PROPOSAL IS
INVESTING IN WORKFORCE ACROSS
THE STATE AND SUPPORTING SMALL
BUSINESS SO WE CAN PUT MORE
PEOPLE TO WORK ACTUALLY ON ON
THIS CRITICAL PRIORITY NOT ONLY
BUILDING A RESILIENT BUT HOPING
OUR OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY. AND
THEN LASTLY SOMETHING I'M
PASSIONATE ABOUT IT'S WE NEED
TO MORE EFFICIENTLY AND COST
EFFECTIVELY DELIVER PROJECTS-
WHETHER IT'S EMERGENCY FUEL
BREAKS OR LANDSCAPE LEVEL
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT ARE WE
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WAYS TO CUT
RED TAPE THAT EXISTS TO GET
MORE OF THIS WORK HAPPENING
MORE QUICKLY. SO WHEN I BROAD
OVERVIEW I WANT TO INTRODUCE MY
COLLEAGUE JESSICA MORRIS OUR
DEPUTIES. FORCED MANAGEMENT TO
OUTLINE OUR PROPOSAL HERE TODAY
AND BOTH JESSICA AND I ARE ARE
FORCED AYE GLAD TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS AFTER HER
PRESENTATION. THAT'S GOT. I'M
GOING TO SHARE PRESENTATION
WITH YOU HERE. AND AND I'M
EXCITED TO TALK THROUGH THE
STRATEGY HERE FOR WELFARE
RECIPIENTS IN CALIFORNIA. I'M
OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS
GROUND BREAKING IT PROPOSES A
BILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS AN
INCREASE FROM THE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR- BUDGET LAST
YEAR. TO REALLY INCREASE AND
SEARCH OUR CAPACITY TO HIT ALL
THREE FRONTS OF WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE WHILE STILL
ADDRESSING UNDERLYING- I UNDER
LYING ISSUES AND STRUCTURAL
CHALLENGES THAT HAVE BEEN
SLOWING DOWN OUR PACE AND SCALE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES WITH IN THAT BILLION
IS THREE HUNDRED TWENTY THREE
MILLION. OR FOR EARLY ACTION
FUNDING THIS IS ESSENTIALLY
THIRTY DOLLARS TO ENABLE US TO
GET TO WORK NOW BECAUSE THE
WILDFIRE DOESN'T FIT NEATLY
INTO THE BUDGET CYCLE THE WIND
IT'S TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
WEATHER OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE TO
DO THE PREVENTATIVE WORK IS
RIGHT NOW AND THIS WINDOW
COMES- ONLY YOU KNOW IN IN THE
SPRING AND- IN THE WINTER AND
SO WE NEED TO BE HAVE HAVE WORK
ON THE GROUND NOW. AND CAN'T
WAIT UNTIL THE SUMMER SO
THERE'S THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE MILLION FOR SEARCH
DOLLARS. GAS ACTING ACTIVITY
STARTED WHILE WE HAVE THE
WEATHER OPPORTUNITY TO DO IT
I'M SO I WANT TO TALK TALKING
THROUGH THE OVERALL STRATEGY
THAT SECRETARY CROWFOOT TOUCHED
ON AND REALLY DIVE INTO SOME OF
THE DETAILS OF WHAT'S PROPOSED.
IN THIS BUDGET SO WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD. CALIFORNIA'S WHILE
RESILIENCE WE- IS CHEAP THREE.
THAT TO BE SIGNED. THIS IS.
HARDENING BUILDINGS THAT COULD
MEAN. CAN STATE WITH STAN IN
THE WORK CASE SOMEONE. COMES
THROUGH. ESTABLISHING WINTER
INTERFACE FOR T. NO. AND
PRESCRIBED. WERE FIRE CAN TAKE
A STATE. AND A STATE DURING.
FIRE AND WHOLE LANDSCAPE
STRATEGY TO REDUCE THE SEVERITY.
AND RETURNING. IN AND THE NOT.
ECOLO ROLE OF. I'M CAL PLANT.
SO WE ARE TRYING ALL OF THESE
OUT IN THIS PART AS WELL AS
SOME UNDERLYING STRUCTURAL
CHALLENGES- THAT WILL ALLOW US
TO INCREASE THE PACE. ON THE
RESILIENT LANDSCAPES RAIMES OUR
GOAL IS TO REALLY UTILIZE
PRESCRIBED FIRE AND RETURN THE
NATURAL ROLE OF FIRE TO THE
RIGHT TECHNOLOGY- A MOST OF
CALIFORNIA'S ECOLOGY INTO FIRE
ADAPTED ECOSYSTEM. SOME AREAS
ONE OF FIRE RETURN INTERVAL OF
THIRTY TO SIXTY YEAR. SOME OF
THE STATE ONE OF FIRE RETURN
INTERVALS OF TEN TO FIFTEEN BUT
MANY AREAS IN THE STATE HAVEN'T
SEEN FIRE FOR HUNDRED YEARS.
WHICH IS WHAT'S GIVING US THESE
CATASTROPHIC FIRES. SO WE'RE
TRYING TO GET- FIRED BACK ON
THE LANDSCAPE A LOT OF THAT
MEANS REDUCING THE FUEL LOOK
FIRST TO BE ABLE TO RESTORE THE
NATURAL ECOLOGICAL ROLE
ACQUIRE. WITH CHALLENGING
CALIFORNIA IS THAT WE HAVE
MULTIPLE TYPES OF. A LAND
OWNERSHIP ACROSS THE STATE 57%
IS OWNED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT 40% IS PRIVATELY
OWNED AND 3% IS OWNED BY THE
STATE. BUT THE WILDFIRE DOESN'T
STOP AND JURISDICTIONAL
BOUNDARIES STORE STRATEGIES
HERE ALLOW TO HAVE A PATCHWORK
OF RESILIENCE ON THE LANDSCAPE
WE ACTUALLY HAVE TO ADDRESS THE
WHOLE ECOSYSTEM. SO WE WORK.
AND WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
DIFFERENT TARGETED PROGRAMS YOU
TARGET DIFFERENT TYPES OF
LANDSCAPE THAT CAN COME
TOGETHER AND GIVE US THAT WHOLE
WATERSHED. AND POOL AYE.
ECOSYSTEM APPROACH YOU. THERE
WERE SOME SO EXAM OF THESE PRO
IN REALLY RIGHT UP ARE AT ON
EIGHT LAND THIS IS SOME OF MOST
BY DIVERSE AND UNIQUE HABITAT
IN THE STATE WHICH IS IT IS
PROTECT BY PARK AND DEPARTMENT
FISHER WILDLIFE WORK CAPACITY
OUR STATE ENTITY TO MANAGE OUR
LAND FACT. WE'RE ALSO INCREASED
FUNDING FOR SMALL FAVORITE 20%
OF THE FORCE LAND IN. AND IT
MALL OF COURSE LANDOWNER
CREATED ON THE COAST AND THE
THINK IT'S GIVING THEM A GREAT
DOLLARS- AND FUN TO ACTUALLY DO
THE WORK THEIR ON SMALL FAMILY
FORCED OF IT'S REALLY TO WHICH
SIX HERE WE ALSO HAVE FUNDING-
CHIU SUPPORT REFORESTATION
PARTNERS- AND WE ALSO FUNDING
TO REALLY SUPPORT TRIBAL
ENGAGEMENT SO TRY FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY. FOR CRIMES TO BE
ABLE AYE WHAT THEY WANT DO ON
THE LAND IT'S VERY OPEN FOR
TRYING TO BE A TO HOW LOT OF
FLEX AND- AND EASIER TO GETTING
DAHLE- TO THAT CRITICAL AND
ALSO PRESS TO BE INFORM
TRADITIONAL EAGLE KNOWLEDGE IN
OUR PRESS. IT'S ALSO INCLUDES
OUR EGGS FOR HEALTH GRANT PARK
WHICH KEEPS OUR DAHLE OUT TO
GRANT IN THE AND IT'S REALLY OF
THE FOUNDING OF OUR APPROACH TO
POOREST. REALLY LOOKING AT THE
ONE- INTERFACE. MANY OF THE
OVERALL CALLED GOVERNOR.
DECLARED IN A- BEFORE THE
EMERGENCE IN TWENTY NINETEEN
AND DEPLOYED CALIFORNIA AND THE-
GUARD. AND THE CONSERVE CORPS
DO THAT WAS THIRTY FIVE
EMERGING FUEL FOR ACROSS
LANDSCAPE. YES BREAKS PICTURE I
AGREE EXAMPLE OF ONE OF HERE
WHERE IT'S A SHE AREA- YOU
REDUCE THE ON. THERE ARE ALONG
ROAD. TO THE DOUBLE A SKI.
AWARD TO APPROACH A FIRE. THESE
ARE QUITE AND- TOOLS DURING A
CATASTROPHIC FIRE TO BE ABLE
HELP NOT ONLY POTENTIAL HOLD.
LINE OR RIGHT OF FIRE BUT TO
ALLOW P. TO STATE I'M HERE THE
COP OF THE- OF. FUEL BREAKS ARE
DOWN- A DOWN AND DIEGO AND THE
IN THEM AND EMPIRE. AND- THE
BOTTOM. IS A FEW YOU'LL BREAK
IMPAIRED- IN HE CAN'T. WE AS
YOU CAN SEE THE TREES RISK BUT
THERE STAND THAT WILL BREAK
WASN'T EVEN MANNED BY FIRE. AT
OR- THE CAN'T ON THE PLANE IN.
PROTECT THE TOWN OF STERLING.
SO THE STRATEGIC FEEL BREAKS
ARE CLOSE AND FUNDING WILL
ALLOW CALTRAIN HERE TO BE ABLE
TO INCREASE THE FUEL THEY PUT
THE GROUND AS WELL AS GETTING
MORE. DAHLE OUT COMMUNITY. TO
PUT ST YOU FUEL RIGHT AROUND
THERE IN. THE NIGHT AREA IS
GOING TO BE V. IS ANYTHING
HERE'S ANOTHER PHOTO. THE SPACE
AND OUR HOME THIS NEW AREA
REALLY LOW AT. COMMUNITY AND
HOW HARDENING HOW WE HELP.
SERVED BY IF A WILDFIRE THROUGH.
YOU CAN SEE IN THE BOTTOM RIGHT.
THAT THERE IS- SPACE. THESE
HOME. AND AND THESE REALLY. AND
ALLOWS A HIGHER PRICE TO BE
ABLE TO PROTECT. BETTER AND
TWO. A WILD. MORE IMPORTANT OUR
IMPORTANT ALSO WHO HARD THIS IS.
IN SMALL. FRACTURE FITS ON A TO
BE ABLE TO AND- ITS- ARE.
DURING WHAT. THE FIRE MARSHAL
CHANGED FIRE CODE CORPS. HOME
HARDING'S. IN YOUR STREETS YOU
FUEL FOR. AND YOUR LAST
BUILDING BACK INTO. EIGHT AND
SO WE STARTED HOMES IN THE CAMP
PERKS. BILL BEFORE. BUILT AFTER-TWO. EIGHT HOW A FIFTY TO. PER
SURVIVE RATE WERE THESE PUMP.
STANDARDS WHEREAS HOMES BUILT
BEFORE HAD A PERCENT SURVIVAL.
SO THERE'S A LOT COMMUNITY CAN
DO. IN THE WAY TARGET HOME KERR.
IS TO ENSURE THAT- THAT WE ARE.
AND AN OPPORTUNITY FAMILIES FOR
THOSE WHO CAN AFFORD TO MAKE
THESE RECORDS LIKE PUTTING BACK
ON THE ADDRESS. CLEANING OUT
THE GUTTERS- IN DEFENSE OF
SPACE THE- YOUR STAVING AROUND
HOME. I'M LOT OF EDUCATE
OUTREACH CAN BE DONE SO WE'RE
INVESTING IN THE UC
FIREFIGHTERS FIRST INCREASING
THE OF REACH CAPACITY OF OUR
DEFENSIBLE SPACE. PROGRAMS AND
DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTORS
WERE ALSO RECOGNIZING THAT MANY
HOMEOWNER CAN'T AFFORD TO MAKE
THESE RECORDS THAT. AND SO WE
ARE LAUNCHING A PILOT- IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH FEMA.
MITIGATION FUNDING TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE THE STATE INVEST TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THE
FEDERAL MATCHING WOULD BE
POTENTIALLY. SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS EVEN THAT'S NOT
I'M MILLION DOLLARS. TO BE ABLE
TO DO YOU KNOW SLOW THOSE
RECTOR FOR LOW IN FAMILIES THAT
CAN AFFORD IT. AND WITH THESE
TOOLS I DO. AND DIRECTOR
SUPPORT YOUR FAMILY THAT CAN'T
IT WE'RE HOPING TO BE ABLE TO
REACH HIGHER SO. THAT CENTURY
LEVEL- WHAT WE BEEN ARE HARD.
COMMUNITY I. THREE FOUR THAT
YOU CURRENTLY NEED COMMUNITY
HOW. WHILE URBAN. AND WE'RE THE
SEVERITY OF FIRE ACTUALLY
THEY'RE MORE EQUAL WORLD ON THE
REVERSE FOR SO YOU. BUT I DON'T
THAT WE'VE BEEN. SEVERAL APPS
THAT HAVE BEEN SLOWING THAT.
ONE OF THE MAJOR ONE IS GETTING
WORK FOR CREW AND BUSINESS
NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO. UP TO BE
ABLE TO HIRE THEM TO BE ABLE TO
ACT DO THE WORK. ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WE HAVE WHEN WE'RE
DOING THIS. AND IS AS CAN SEE
THESE THE INSIDE SLASH PILES
THIS IS A- OF A- I WAS STYLE OF
ANTI IF YOU LOOK IN THE LOWER
RIGHT HAND CORNER THAT IS. AND
THE FOR SERVICE SEVERAL YEARS
AGO GET ASK ME THAT THEY WERE
ABOUT FORTY OF SLASHED BY. IN
THE TOP WILL BE ALONE TO. WAYS
TO JUST OF THIS WOULD BE BY A
IS COOL. INCREASE BUSINESS ARE
THAT EVEN SENSE. SO ONE OF THE
A- WE PROPOSE IS CLIMATE. FUNDS
WHICH HELP CREATE- AND- WERE AT
LOWING LENDING FOR STARTING UP.
IN IS BOTH IN. AND NOT
TRADITIONAL SECTORS SO
BUSINESSES ARE. SAWMILLS TO. I
THINK HE SHOULD BE ABLE TO BE
TO THIS AND WORK IN. I DON'T
FEEL THAT YESTERDAY BE ABLE TO
A FLAT STYLE LIKE THE ONE USED.
AND TURN IT INTO. A BY DIESEL
RATHER THAN OPEN I OVER AT AND
HAVING THAT CARD GET REALLY
YEAH. THERE'S ALSO A IN HERE
THE WERE PUT. THAT WE ALLOW US
TO BE TO TRY A LARGE BUSINESS.
SO LIKE CROSS MEANING TIMBER
WHICH SHE A SMALLER. ONE LIKE
YOU THANK YOU OFTEN ENDING UP
CLASS I. AND TURNING IT A STEEL
AND CONCRETE EQUIVALENT I'M
BUILDINGS AND CALIFORNIA
BUILDING CODE JUST. TO A UP TO
EIGHTEEN. WHICH MAKES VERY. IN
BYRON- BEFORE HE'S- NEW. WHICH
IS THAT- IT WHICH IS THAT
PROGRAMMATIC CALAVERAS COUNTY
AND NOW THE ENTIRE SIERRA THAT
PARTNERS WITH TRYING. TO
TREATING TRIBAL MEMBERS IN A
PRESCRIBED FIRE YOUR ACTION HE
AND CREWS SO THAT THEY CAN
MANAGE THEIR OWN LAND
THEMSELVES WE SAW THIS PROGRAM
ACTUALLY REDUCE THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE ON THAT HELLO
T. TRIBE UP IN ALBANY COUNTY BY
30% WITH THIS ONE PROGRAM
ALONE. ANOTHER EIGHT TRIBES
PARTICIPATING THROUGHOUT THE
SIERRA AND THEY ARE GETTING
EMPLOYED BY MANY OF THESE-
GRANT PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE
PUTTING OUT ON THE GROUND. AND
THE FUEL REDUCTION WORK THAT WE
ARE DOING. IN ADDITION TO THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND THE
NEED FOR A BUSINESS INVESTMENT
IN THIS SECTOR THERE'S- SEVERAL
OTHER UNDERLYING ISSUES ONE IS
WE'RE REALLY WORKING ON-
STREAMLINING PERMITTING WE HAVE
CREATED. A FAST TRACK FOR- BY
DOING A PRE ENVIRONMENTAL
ANALYSIS ON TWENTY MILLION
ACRES THROUGHOUT THE LANDSCAPE
AND THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL IS-
TOOLS THAT WILL ALLOW WATER
BOARDS. TO BE ABLE TO. THINK
THEIR PERMITS WITH OUR FASTER
SEQUEL PROCESS AND BRING THE
SEQUEL PROCESS DOWN TO ABOUT
TWO MONTHS. AND WHEN GRANT YOU
SUPPLY FOR THE PERMIT- THEY
GET. THIRSTY QUIET GET THEIR-
CDFW ADD THEIR FISH AND
WILDLIFE IS COVERED UNDER WATER
BOARDS ARE COVERED. SO WE'RE
CREATING FASTER TRACKS ON
PERMITTING AND FINALLY ONE OF
THE MOST CRITICAL AREAS IS THAT
WE ARE GROUNDING BASED IN
SCIENCE. SO REALLY INVESTING IN
SCIENCE- AND DATA TECHNOLOGY WE
ARE ENSURING THAT WE ARE
IMPROVING OUR MODELS. AND OUR
MODELING WERE. DOING PREDICTIVE
ANALYSIS AND SAPPHIRE MODELING
SO THAT WE ARE DESIGNING ALL OF
THESE WATERSHED SCALE
APPROACHES. AT THE HIGHEST
LEVEL. BLUSTERY I WANT TO
MENTION AND THEN WE'LL TAKE
QUESTIONS IS HOW THIS ALL FITS
INTO THE REGIONAL STRATEGY ONE
OF THE AREAS IN THIS BUDGET IS
AN EIGHTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN THE REGIONAL
FOREST AND FIRE CAPACITY
PROGRAM. THIS THIS BILL THREE
COLLABORATIVES ALL THE STATE TO
TABLE. FROM FEDERAL PARTNERS TO
TRY TO PARTNER Q. A LOCAL AND-
TO LOOK SMALL WHEN OWNERS- AND
IT DOES LANDOWNER. BRING THEM
ALL TO THE TO DESIGN IT THAT
WAY FOR ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
HAVE BEEN HOW. MANY OF THE-
COLLABORATIVELY RECEIVED GRANT.
FROM OUR TO BUY A TO PASS
PROGRAM. HOWEVER THEY OFTEN
LACK THE DOLLARS TO DO NEED TO
REACH SCALE WATER SCALE. TO BE
ABLE TO USE THE SCIENCE THAT
WE'RE GETTING TO DESIGN THEIR
TIRE STRATEGIES ANOTHER ED
STOCK IN GETTING PROJECTS COURT
SHOVEL READY GETTING PROJECTS-
REVIEW FOR THEIR ENVIRONMENTAL
ANALYSIS IN GETTING THAT DONE
FASTER. SO WE HAVE INVESTIGATED
IT AT EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING
FOR THE REGIONAL PORTION FIRE
CAPACITY PROGRAM TO EXPAND
THESE COLLABORATIVE. ROUTE THE
STATE TO BE ABLE TO GET THEM
PLANNING DOLLARS PROJECT
PREPARATION DOLLARS TO
DEPARTMENT. PLANS CAN BE. DEAR
THEN THE GRANT DOLLARS THAT YOU
SEE THE ENTIRE BUDGET PROPOSED.
GOING FORWARD THAT THEY THEN
FINE THE- GREAT- THESE ENTIRE
REGIONAL. COMPLETELY SO WE ARE
THREE TO WITH YOU ON THE STATE
SO MUCH FOR. THIS BUDGET PER
AND WORKS TO BE YOUR- IN HOW
CALIFORNIA BECOME. AND
RESILIENCE THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THE. AT THE- REPORT I'M
GOING TO ASK THAT WE HAVE AFTER
QUESTIONS THAT ARE ALLOWED WE
HEAR FROM THE- L. OF THE L. A.
PRISON. ON ITEM IS. TO HELP
ANSWER SOME OF THE- THAT- ARE
ANTICIPATED SO- I WOULD BE-
MISTER BROWN. YES THANK YOU
UPRIGHT CONTRACT WITH THE L. A.
AGAIN THANK YOU- OUR OFFICE
LAST MONTH IT OUT TO REPORT IS-
SUMMARIZING DIFFERENT ELEMENTS
OF THE RESILIENCE PACKAGE OF
PRESENTED THE FIRST REPORT OF
THE ONE THAT'LL BE SPEAKING
FROM TODAY WHICH PROVIDES KIND
OF OUR OVERARCHING COMMENT BUT
WE DO HAVE A SECOND REPORTERS
WELL THAT. SHOULD BE A HELPFUL
REFERENCE WE THINK FOR THE
COMMITTEE WHICH HAD MORE
DETAILED INFORMATION ON EACH OF
THE TWO DOZEN OR SO DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS THAT MAKE UP THE
PACKAGE. ON SO A FEW HIGH LEVEL
ISSUES FOR YOU TO CONSIDER I
THINK FIRST OF ALL IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO KNOWLEDGE THAT
THIS- THERE'S A LOT IN THIS
PACKAGE IT IS WORTH YOUR
CONSIDERATION AS SECRETARY
CROWFOOT DISCUSSED HE LAST YEAR
LAST COUPLE YEARS LAST COUPLE
DECADES HAVE BEEN AMONG THE
WORST IN TERMS OF FIRE DAMAGE
AND FIRE SEVERITY- IN THE
STATE'S RECORDED HISTORY AND SO
WE THINK THAT PACKAGE DOES
BUILD ON ACTIONS THE
LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION
TAKEN IN PRIOR YEARS SUCH AS-
THE ADOPTION OF SB NINE A ONE
TO. EXPAND PREVENTION AND
MITIGATION ACTIVITIES THAT VERY
MERITED AND I THINK AS WELL
THAT HAVE A PACKAGE WITH A MIX
OF DIFFERENT STRATEGIES MAKE
SENSE OF THE RANGE OF
CONTRIBUTORS TO THE FIRE-
WILDFIRE PROBLEM AND DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES. HAVE DIFFERENT
CHALLENGES SPECIFIC. TO THEM
AND SO HAVING A- THE PACKAGE
THE A- PARTICULAR TIME FOR THEM
TO. FOR EXAMPLE ALL OUR EGGS
ONE- AND SO WE THINK
ADMINISTRATION PACKAGE PROVIDE
YOU A REASONABLE TO. IN LOOKING
FORWARD TO A BROADER WILDFIRE
REDUCTION STRATEGY- THAT SAID
THIS ISN'T THE ONLY WAY YOU
COULD STRUCTURE A PACKAGE AND
SO HAVE A FEW COMMENTS FOR
YOUR- FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THE FIRST IT IS LOOKING AT THE
ONE TIME NATURE OF THE GENERAL
FUND PROPOSED SO IN TOTAL SIX
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION OF
THE BILLION DOLLARS A PROPOSED
TO BE FROM THE GENERAL FUND. IN
A ONE TIME NATURE NOW IN MANY
CASES THOSE ONE TIME DOLLARS
WILL BE SPENT OVER MULTIPLE
YEARS OF THE PROJECT TAKE.
MULTIPLE YEARS TO IMPLEMENT AND
DEVELOP- THAT SAID EVEN WITH
THE SCALE OF. THIS PACKAGE-
THAT THE SCALE O THE PROBLEM
IN CALIFORNIA IS OF COURSE MUCH
LARGER WHETHER YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT THE- TENS OF MILLIONS OF
ACRES OF FOREST LAND THAT WOULD
BENEFIT FROM TREATMENT FOR THE-
MILLIONS OF HOMES IN THE MOVIE
THAT WOULD BENEFIT FROM
HARDENING. THIS FUNDING PACKAGE
WILL ONLY ADDRESS A RELATIVELY
SMALL SHARE OF THE IDENTIFIED
PROBLEM. AND SO WE THINK ONE
IMPORTANT. WHAT IT WOULD WE
THINK WE ARE AT THE MINISTRY.
READ THE PROPOSING ONE GENERAL
FUND IT BECAUSE OF THE ONGOING
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT THAT WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER IN THE
CONTEXT OF CALIFORNIA. BUDGET
PROPOSAL DO WE THINK THAT
UNDERSTANDABLE BUT WE DO THINK
THAT DOES IMPLY THAT THERE'S
VALUE IN THE SPRING AND IN
FUTURE MONTHS THE- H.
INTIMIDATION WORKING TOGETHER
TO. THINK ABOUT WHAT A LONGER
TERM STRATEGY IS BEYOND THIS
BILLION DOLLARS OR WHATEVER
ACTUALLY SUCH A FAMILIAR DOCKS.
THE NEXT ISSUE I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT WAS THE- EARLY ACTION
PROPOSAL THAT WAS DISCUSSED AT
THE THREE HUNDRED TWENTY THREE
MILLION OF THE BILLION DOLLARS
THAT PROPOSED FOR. FUNDING IN
THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR- JUST
AS A BIT OF CONTACT OUR OFFICE
IS A LITTLE BIT WARY ABOUT
EARLY ACTION WITHOUT A VERY
STRONG RATIONALE. IN THAT EARLY
JUST BECAUSE IN PARTICULARLY.
WITH RESPECT TO THE GENERAL
FUND- APPROVING THOSE DOLLARS
NOW TAKE THEM OFF THE TABLE IF
YOU'RE CONSIDERING YOUR BROADER
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET-
PRIORITIES- THAT THERE. WILL BE
DO YOU THINK THERE ARE SOME
REAL NATIONAL FOR ADOPTING SOME
EARLY ACTION PROPOSALS ONE IS
WITH RESPECT TO THE G. JAR
AFTER. FINDING THAT PROPOSED
THE UNDER THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSAL THE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION IS INTENDED TO
BRING TOTAL GDR FUNDING BACK TO
THE LEVEL. IDENTIFIED AT THE
PRIORITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
AND SB NINE OH ONE- THE FUNNY
WITHOUT FULLY PROVIDED THE
CURRENT BUDGET ACT BECAUSE OF
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT CAP AND TRADE
REVENUES. I KNOW YOU'LL TALK
ABOUT THAT A LITTLE BIT MORE
DETAIL LATER IN THIS CARE ACT
THANK. ON THE OTHER CASES THAT
WHICH WE THINK THE MESSAGING
COULD MAKE THAT IT. WOULD MAKE
IT. CONCEPTUALLY THAT IF WE CAN
PROVIDE EARLY ACTION IF WE CAN
PROVIDE A FEW EXTRA MONTHS OF
TIME. THAT MAY BE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN. I CERTAIN
PROJECTS BEING IN. IN ADVANCE
OF THE NEXT WILD SHE'D OR EVEN
THE TWO TWENTY. FIRE SEASON AND
WE THINK THE ADDITIONAL SAFETY
BENEFITS THAT COULD PROVIDE.
COULD MERIT CONSIDERATION OF
EARLY ACTION ADOPTION. ONE
CONCERN WE HAVE THERE IS THAT
WE HAVE NOT YET RECEIVED
TIMELINE IMPLEMENTATION PLANS.
TO TO DEMONSTRATE THAT IN FACT
THE- INITIATION EXPECTS A
CERTAIN NUMBER PROJECT NUMBER
OF ACRES TO BE TREATED ON THOSE
TIMELINES IN ADVANCE OF US. THE
FIRE SCENE SO WE REQUESTED
THAT- EXERTION. WILL PROVIDE
THAT SOON AND WHEN THEY DO WILL
CERTAINLY SHARE THAT WITH THEM.
WITH THE COMMITTEE. BUT THE
NEXT ISSUE WE SUGGEST THAT YOU
THINK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT USING
THIS BRAND EVEN BEYOND THE
EARLY ACTION PROPOSALS ARE
USING THE REMAIN OF THE SPRING
PROCESS. TO EXPLORE WHETHER
THERE MIGHT BE ADDITIONAL
PROGRAMMATIC OR FUNDING OPTIONS
TO. COMPLEMENT THE PROPOSED
PACKAGE WE DON'T HAVE SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL BUT WE NOTE THAT.
THERE HAVE BEEN- THE CURRENT
PACKAGE RELIES. VERY MUCH ON
EXISTING STATE PREVENTED
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT OTHER
PROGRAMS- IDEAS THAT MAYBE
LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS- DIFFERENT
ADVOCACY GROUPS AND OTHER
GROUPS WE HAVE ALL THE WAY TO
SUPPLEMENT THIS. THIS PACKAGE
AND THEN SIMILARLY IT
PARTICULARLY THINKING ABOUT THE
LONGER TERM STRATEGY THAT OU
MAY WANT. TO EMPLOY- IF TRYING
TO IDENTIFY ADDITIONAL FUNDING
OPTIONS THAT COULD A SUPPORT
SOME OF THE ONGOING. ONGOING
NEEDS OR DEMANDS. D. NATURALLY
SHE LEFT PROVIDE THE THEN ONE
IS A KNOW THAT THEIR ARE CASES
WHEN WE WENT THROUGH EACH OF
THE- TWO DOZEN OR SO PROGRAMS
IN THE PAC ACHETER SEVERAL
CASES WHERE. WE WERE LOOKING
FOR MORE INFORMATION ON
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS TO CHOOSE
FROM THE EARLY ACTION ISSUES
IDENTIFIED OR PROJECTED
OUTCOMES THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION EXECUTIVE
EXPECTS TO ACHIEVE WITH
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS. AND SO
THAT'S SOMETHING WE- COULD
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO HAVE I WAS SO THAT
YOU CAN EVALUATE WHETHER THIS
PARTICULAR PACKAGE IS DESIGNED
TO MEET YOUR YOUR HIGHEST
PRIORITY NEED AND SO WE DO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO USE THE
MADE OF THE SPRING PROCESS. TO
TRY DIRECTED INDUSTRY AND
PROVIDE. ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
IN DETAIL. LASTLY ONE OF
PACKAGE DO IT. WE SUGGEST THAT
BE IMPORTANT TO BUILD IN
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THIS IS
PARTLY TO HOLD ADMINISTRATION
ACCOUNTABLE FOR DELIVERING ON
THIS VERY LARGE FUNDING PACKAGE
WHATEVER PACKAGE YOU ADOPT. A
BOOK PERHAPS EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY THAN THAT- WEEK WE
THINK HAVING SOME. ABOUT FORTY
REQUIREMENTS WILL HELP INFORM
YOU IN THE ADMINISTRATION AS
WELL IN FUTURE YEARS. I AND
HELP GUIDE HOW WE SHOULD AND IN
THE FUTURE. FOR FUNDING AT TO
TARGET THE MOST AFFECTED
PROGRAMS INTERMITTENTLY IN SOME
OF THOSE- ROBUST REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS WOULD WOULD BE
VALUABLE IN THE FUTURE- WITHOUT
HAVING TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU- LET ME. OPEN UP BUT-
THE TO- IF I MIGHT WITH A- A
COMMENT- WELL FIRST A-
GRATITUDE TO- THIS IS INDEED
THE FIRST TIME WE HAVE SEEN
SIGNIFICANT- AMOUNTS OF MONEY
PROPOSED TO- A BY ANY GOVERNOR-
BUT CERTAINLY BY A GOVERNOR
NEWSOM- FOR WILDFIRE PREVENTION.
COMES IN THE WAKE OF THE WORST
YEAR WE'VE SEEN IF I COULD
FRANKLY WAVE A MAGIC WAND THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY I WOULD WANT TO
TRY AND ALLOCATE WOULD BE FAR
MORE THAN A BILLION DOLLARS BUT
THIS IS CERTAINLY- A
SIGNIFICANT AND WELCOME
INCREASE IN THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING. FOR PREVENTION AND ON
THE SUBJECT OF PREVENTION
PREVENTION IS SOMETHING THAT WE
DO A TERRIBLE JOB OF ON A WHOLE
RANGE OF ISSUES AND- THE
DEVASTATION THAT WE'VE SEEN IN
WILDFIRE OVER THE LAST DECADE.
OF IS PREVENTABLE- HAD WE HAD A
LONG TERM STRATEGY LONG AGO IN
PLACE WE WOULD HAVE SEEN MUCH
REDUCED. DEVASTATION AROUND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA OVER THE
LAST DECADE- BUT IT'S NOT JUST
WILDFIRE ON HEALTHCARE AND
DISEASE- ON HOMELESSNESS. HAVE
WE HAVE THE FORESIGHT TO OF I
SPEND SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF
MONEY ON PREVENTION WE WOULD
HAVE TODAY LESS ST HOMELESSNESS
WE WOULD HAVE IN THE HEALTHCARE
ARENA FOR EXAMPLE FAR LESS
RAMPANT. TYPE TWO DIABETES.
TOTALLY PREVENTABLE DISEASE-
AND WE DO VERY LITTLE TOO- TO
INTERCEDE AND OF COURSE ON
WILDFIRE SO THIS IS THE
EXTREMELY- OF WELCOME- VIDAK A
TOPIC OF- EARLY ACTION IS NOW-
BEEN RAISED AND- I KNOW THAT-
MANY OF YOU. MAY HAVE TUNED IN
TO OUR COUNTERPART TED THE
SENATE SAID- SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER TWO HEARING YESTERDAY
AND SAW AND HEARD ABOUT THEIR
EARLY ACTION WILDFIRE PLAN-
AGAIN THE NOTION OF EARLY
ACTION ORIGINATED WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE PAYING
CLOSE ATTENTION TO AND TO
GRATEFUL FOR. HIS UP A PROPOSAL
BUT I'VE BEEN IN DISCUSSIONS
WITH SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI
THE CHAIR OF US SENATE SUB TO
ON WHAT SHOULD BE INCLUDED IN
EARLY ACTION FOR WILDFIRE
FUNDING AND IN GENERAL WERE. IN
AGREEMENT THAT- THIS IS A
PRESSING ISSUE THAT MERITS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING HOWEVER- AT
THIS POINT I DO NOT AGREE WITH
THE SENATE'S APPROACH AND
EXCLUSIVELY USING GENERAL FUND
MONEY- COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
OTHERS WILL NOTE THAT. THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN- CONTAINS A LOT
OF GIGI R. F. MONEY AND SOME
GENERAL FUND- I ALSO. WANT TO
COMMENT THAT WE HAVE MADE A
COMMITMENT- IN SB NINE OH ONE
TO EXPAND TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN GIGI R. F.
FUNDING FOR WILDFIRE PREVENTION
PURPOSES AND I THINK IT'S
PRUDENT FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
STAY VERY FOCUSED ON ENSURING
THAT EVERY DOLLAR OF THE EARLY
ACTION PACKAGE HELPED US TO GET
STARTED ON FIRE PREVENTION WORK
AS MUCH IN ADVANCE OF THE
UPCOMING FIRE SEASON AS
POSSIBLE AND SO I'M APPROACHING
THE CONVERSATION- THAT WERE
HAVING BETWEEN THE TWO HOUSES
WITH TWO PRINCIPLES IN MIND.
THE FIRST IS THAT THE FUNDING
HAS TO GO TOWARDS FIRE
PREVENTION AND SECOND THE
ENTITY RECEIVING THE FONT OF
FUNDING MUST BE ABLE TO USE THE
FUNDING IMMEDIATELY IN THE VERY
VERY NEAR. I THINK THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S EARLY ACTION PROVIDE
PROPOSAL PROVIDES US WITH A
GREAT STARTING POINT MANY OF
THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE PROPOSED
FOR FUNDING IN THAT PLAN THAT
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT- OF THIS
MORNING OUR PROGRAMS THAT WE
FUNDED IN THE PAST THEY ARE-
IN- A FOR ALL INTENTS AND
PURPOSES SHOVEL READY READY TO
GO THEY MEET THE DEFINITION OF
EARLY ACTION THESE ARE PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE ESTABLISHED
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE TO
RAPIDLY USE AND DEPLOY FUNDING
IN THE CURRENT YEAR THAT'S WHAT
EARLY ACTION IS ALL ABOUT. IN
ORDER TO GET AHEAD OF THE
UPCOMING WILDFIRE SEASON WILL
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
SENATE ON THIS AND- TO ENSURE
THOUGHTFUL EARLY ACTION
WILDFIRE PACKAGE AND I INVITE
YOU OVER- COMMENTS NOT
NECESSARILY HERE- ON THE DICE
BUT HAD- HAPPY TO RECEIVE FOR A
BI OF YOUR THOUGHTS AND
INCORPORATE THE MINUTES MUCH AS
POSSIBLE NOW. HAVING SAID THAT-
I'M NOT- IT WOULD BE- MR
CROWFOOT OR SOMEONE ELSE BUT-
THE ISSUE OF WHETHER- THIS OF
FUNDING IS ONGOING OR NOT I
THINK IS AN IMPORTANT ONE WE
ARE CLEARLY NOT GOING TO- I DO
THE PREVENTION WORK THAT WE
NEED TO DO SIMPLY BY DOING WORK
THIS YEAR TESTS HAVE TO BE AN
ONGOING. EFFORT PROBABLY OVER A
DECADE THERE'S NOT THAT MANY
YEARS AND THE- SO WHAT CAN YOU
UP PLEASE RESPOND TO. THE ISSUE
OF WHAT THE INTENTIONS ARE HERE
AND HOW MUCH OF THE CURRENT
PACKAGE IS INTENDED TO BE
ONGOING. YEAH OUT IN JUST A
MOMENT I'LL THANK YOU CHAIR
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE JESSICA BUT I THINK
BROADLY SPEAKING WE RECOGNIZE
THAT. WE CAN'T. FIND ON AGAIN
OFF AGAIN WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
PROJECTS OR AS JESSICA LIKES TO
TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW RANDOM ACTS
OF. OF A WILDFIRE RESILIENCE WE
HAVE TO ENABLE REGIONS TO
DEVELOP PIPELINE OF PROJECTS
AND THEN FUND THOSE PIPELINE
PROJECTS. THE GOOD NEWS IS- WE
PROPOSE A STRUCTURE WITHIN
THIS- BILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS
LARGELY QUOTE UNQUOTE ONE TIME
FUNDING TO BE SPENT OVER A
SERIES OF YEARS ACTUALLY ENABLE
THOSE ARE PROJECTS TO BEGIN IN
THE PIPELINE OR CONTINUE IN THE
PIPELINE AND GET FUNDED OVER
SEVERAL YEARS. SO CATHOLIC I
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT- MORE
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT HOW WE DO
THAT. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU SO-
SO WHAT INNOVATIVE ABOUT THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL IS THAT MANY OF
THE PROJECTS THAT ARE PROPOSED
BUDGET YEAR- ARE DESIGNED TO
HAVE EIGHTY FIVE TO SEVEN YEAR
EXPENDITURE WINDOW. SO THE
PROGRAMS WITHIN STATE PARKS AND
FISH AND WILDLIFE AND YOU'RE
ABOUT TO CONSERVANCY SOME OF
THESE PROGRAMS ARE DESIGNED TO
BE ABLE TO PUT A SURGE- DOLLARS
ON- ON THE LANDSCAPE AND THEN
TO BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY TAKE
THOSE PROGRAMS. START TO FINISH
OFTEN WHAT HAPPENS WE NEED MORE
TIME FUNDING IS THAT IT GETS
SPENT ON- INFRASTRUCTURE OR A
ONE TIME ACQUISITION WHEREAS
WHAT WE ARE DOING BY HAVING A
LONGER SPENDING FOR RICIN WITH
ONE TIME DOLLARS. WE ARE
ESSENTIALLY ENABLING US TO
CREATE A PROGRAM THAT WILL
ACTUALLY DELIVER NOT JUST PHASE
ONE- AID FIRE SCIENCE PROJECT
BUT ACTUALLY NEEDS HIGHER- BE
ENTIRE PIPELINE TO GET FUNDED
START TO FINISH. WHAT THAT DOES
IS ALSO ENABLES US TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE- PREDICTABILITY- SO THE
WORKERS THAT WE HIRED THE
CONTRACTORS THAT WE HIRE IN
THESE LOCAL COMMUNITIES. THERE
BECOMES A PREDICTABILITY THAT
THIS PRODUCT BUT PROGRAMMING IS
GOING TO BE ON THE GROUND IN
THEIR COMMUNITY. FOR THE
ENTIRETY OF THE BEING ENTIRE
WATERSHED PROJECT AND THEY CAN
THEN DELIVER WITH THAT SO WELL
THIS IS A ONE TIME FUNDING-
WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
INNOVATIVE WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. TO COME
UP WITH AN APPROACH THAT ALLOWS
US TO BE ABLE TO CREATE MORE
ROBUST AND ADORING- THE
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE A DISCREET
START TO FINISH- WE AT ONE TIME
FUNDING. THANK YOU A APPRECIATE
THAT ANSWER- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
YOU KNOW I AGREE WITH YOU THAT
WE NEED AN ONGOING COMMITMENT
TO FIRE PREVENTION AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR QUESTIONS ON
THE ONE TIME FUNDING VERSES ON
GOING FUNDING WHICH I THINK IS
IMPORTANT- I HAVE A QUESTION
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION- CAN YOU
EXPLAIN THE RATIONALE FOR WHICH
EXPENDITURES OR EARLY ACTIONS I
KNOW THAT WE HEARD. A LITTLE
BIT FROM THE L. A. O. ON SOME
OF THE RATIONALE- FOR EARLY
ACTION PROGRAMS- BUT WHAT WILL
WE LOSE OUT ON BY WAITING TO
APPROPRIATE. THESE FUNDS UNTIL
JUNE. THANK YOU SO MUCH OF THAT
QUESTION THE REACTION DOLLARS
ARE REALLY FOCUSED ON- ON THREE
CORE CRITERIA THE NUMBER ONE IN
THE MAJORITY OF THEM ARE REALLY
ACTIVITIES THAT WE NEED TO GET
STARTED NOW TO BE ABLE TO GAIN
A FIRE SEASON. AND AND I WANT
TO BE ABLE TO MANAGE
EXPECTATIONS SOME OF THESE WILL
BE ABLE TO GO TO SEARCH
EXISTING ACTIVITIES ON THE
GROUND THAT WE CAN COMPLETE
BEFORE FIRE SEASON TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. MOST PROJECTS
AROUND FIRE RESILIENCE- GO
START TO FINISH THEY TAKE EIGHT
TO TEN MONTHS SOMETIMES LONGER
BUT THERE ARE ONLY CERTAIN
WINDOWS WITHIN. A LONG EIGHT
SPEND MUCH TIME TIMELINE THAT
THEY CAN ACTUALLY GET THIS WORK
DONE JUST STARTING IN MARCH
RATHER THAN JUNE ALLOWS THOSE
PROJECTS TO FINISH IN THE
SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
RATHER IN THE SPRING OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. SO IT ALLOWS US
TO BE ABLE TO GAIN- AND A TIRE
FIRE SEASON OUT OF THESE-
FUNDING OUT OF THESE DOLLARS
AND CREATE THAT BUYERS MIGHT
SOON ARE YOU'RE ALSO ACTIVITIES
THAT WE ARE PROPOSED IN THERE
SUCH AS THE HOME HARDENING. I'M
PROGRAM WITH PROPOSED FOR EARLY
ACTION THAT IS PROPOSED SO THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY GET THAT
PROGRAM STARTED GETTING THE
FEMA MATCH WHILE THE FEMA MAPS
WINDOW. IS AVAILABLE- TO GET
THREE TO ONE FUNDING OUT OF
THAT EVEN THOUGH THAT PROP
PROGRAM WILL HAVE EVEN LONGER A
LARGE AND THEN HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION OF THE EARLY
ACTION. IS DESIGNS- TO
BACKFILL- WHAT WAS THE
APPROPRIATION FROM. EUROPE WERE
AND I FIND WE ONLY RECEIVED
TWENTY SEVENTY FIVE MILLION OF
OUR- TYPICAL TWO HUNDRED
MILLION APPROPRIATION IN THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
THIS YEAR. WE WANT TO COMPLETE
THAT SO THOSE. ACTIVITIES CAN
GET ON THE GROUND AND MOVING.
K. YOU I HAVE ONE QUESTION. YOU
KNOW I NOTICE THAT CAN. GRAY
PRO- HAVE NOT PER. MUCH FUNDING
TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I'M
REFERRING TO THE FIRE
PREVENTION GRANTS IN THE
HEALTHY FOREST GRANTS- WHAT IS
BEING DONE TO ADDRESS THIS.
WE'RE WE'RE HAPPY TO GIVE YOU
THOSE NUMBERS- AND AS A
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED OUR- THAT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RECEIVED
ABOUT- 3235% OF THE GRANTS
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA 35240% OF
THE GRANT- JUST SO YOU HAVE A
SENSE THEY- THEY GET. OUT THEY
ALSO PROVIDE ABOUT 30% OF THE
GRANT APPLICATIONS TO REALLY
THE LIMITATION AND WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IN TERMS OF FUNDING IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IT'S REALLY
BASED ON B. SCALE APPLICATIONS
THAT THEY'RE PROVIDING- RATHER
THAN. RATHER THAN A LACK OF
DOLLARS- AND WE CAN GET YOU THE
SPECIFIC DOLLARS- YOU GOT TO
TALK THAT THROUGH. I WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT YEAH PLEASE
SEND. THOSE TO MY OFFICE. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY I JUST MIGHT
MENTION THAT HAVE JUST. I PART
OF IT PART OF OUR DOES TO
REALLY INVEST IN THESE REGIONAL
PLANS- AND ITS REGIONAL
PRIORITIES IS TO ENSURE THAT
EVERY REGION IS ACTUALLY BEING
AS PROACTIVE THAT WANTS TO BE
OR CAN BE. GOING AFTER THAT
FUNDING SO WE'RE VERY MUCH
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THERE'S-
THERE'S A REPRESENTATIVE AMOUNT
OF FUNDING TO GET THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT
FOLLOWED BY MISS FRIEDMAN.
SECRETARY CROWFOOT CROWFOOT- I
APPRECIATED YOUR EARLY
COMMENTS- THAT IDENTIFIED SOME
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT IN FIRE
PREVENTION- IS. SORT OF A NEW
AREA FOR EVERYBODY TO BE
FOCUSED ON- SO WITH THAT I WISH
I APPRECIATED THAT YOU WERE
SENSITIVE TO ISSUES LIKE A WE
NEED TO DEVELOP NEW INDUSTRIES
AND NEW NEW COMPANIES TO DO
THIS WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT-
BECAUSE IT'S NOT LIKE THERE'S A
SIMPLE EASY ANSWER FOR THIS- SO
WITH YOUR- SENSITIVITY ON ON
AND ALSO TRYING TO GET MORE
BANG FOR THE BUCK- TO TRY TO
HAVE THESE PROJECTS NOT BE SO
EXPENSIVE- I APPRECIATE THAT
KIND OF LEADERSHIP. WHAT I HOPE
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO DEVELOP FOR
US ARE TWO THINGS THAT WILL BE
HELPFUL IN THE LONG RUN TO
CONTINUE TO FUND AND THAT IS
IDENTIFY SPECIFICALLY THE
BENEFITS OF THESE VARIOUS
PROJECTS SO YOU CAN COME BACK
AND IDENTIFY- HOW THAT
PARTICULAR. EFFORT DECREASE
FIRE RISK WHAT THE PROFESSIONAL
SAY OR IF A FIRE BROKE OUT WHAT
THE IMPACTS WORK BUT THE OTHER
THING IS IF THERE IS A REQUEST
TO USE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUNDS YOU ALSO IDENTIFY WHAT
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
GAINS ARE FROM THIS PROGRAM.
DOESN'T IN MY MIND B. TWO
ESSENTIAL THINGS AND IF YOU AS
YOU'RE STARTING UP IF YOU'RE
FOCUSED AND PAY ATTENTION ON
THOSE IT MAY BE EASIER FOR YOU
TO QUALIFY THOSE FOR US AND SO
THAT'S MY REQUEST AND I HOPE IT
SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO THAT. FOR
SO LONG RUN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU I DON'T REALLY THE
VERY. I'M SORRY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGREEMENT REVIEW. THERE
THERE'S NO WAY TO DO THIS IN A
WAY THAT'S NOT AWKWARD. YOU
HAVE ONE OF THOSE IMAGES
QUICKLY SORRY I WAS ABLE TO
SECRETARY GO AHEAD AND FINISH
HIS GO AHEAD MAKE YOUR COMMENT.
GO AHEAD WITH YEAH I JUST
WANTED TO. THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR THE POINT AND IT'S
VERY WELL TAKEN- THERE IS OPS
REALLY GOOD WORK UNDERWAY
ENSURING THAT OUR FOREST
RESILIENCE INVESTMENT ACTUALLY
GET MEASURED ACCORDING TO OUR
CLIMATE GOALS. YOU KNOW WE NEED
OUR FORESTS TO BE AND WE NEED
OUR LANDSCAPES I SHOULD SAY TO
BE I THINK- AND THAT ABSORBER
OF CARBON POLLUTION. AND
UNFORTUNATELY DURING THESE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES THEY'VE
BEEN A SOURCE. OF MORE CARBON
POLLUTION SO VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR REQUEST AND WE
WILL WORK TO RESPOND TO THAT TO
MAKE SURE WE COME BACK- WITH
MEASURABLE. I INFORMATION ON
THE BENEFITS. THANK YOU FIRST I
WANT TO. JUST TELL YOU HOW.
GRATIFIED IN AND OUT YOU KNOW
EXCITED I AM TO SEE THIS LAN
GOING FORWARD AND TO START TO
BE FUNDED. I WANT TO COMMEND
SECRETARY CRAWFORD AND HIS TEAM
FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP IN
ABSOLUTELY TO CALL OUT GOVERNOR
NEWSOM. AND HIS VISION FOR
SHIFTING RESOURCES WHERE THEY
NEED TO BE SHIFTED INTO
PREVENTION- TO MEET THIS NEW
NORMAL. OF OUR OUR NEW CLIMATE
AND CHANGING CLIMATE AND I FEEL
LIKE THIS. PACKAGE REALLY-
ENCOMPASSES UGH FIRE IN A VERY
HOLISTIC WAY TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT WATERSHEDS AND IMPACTS
ON WILDLIFE AND BIODIVERSITY IN
AND EVERYTHING THAT REALLY- IS
IMPACTED BY BY THE WILDFIRES-
SO IT'S NICE TO SEE IT LOOKED
AT HOLISTICALLY SO THAT ALL OF
THOSE DIFFERENT COMPONENTS
AREN'T TRAMPLED ON AS WE
SOMETIMES SEEN IN THE PAST YOU
KNOW- SO THAT THEY'RE ALL
RESPECTED AND GIVEN THEIR
PROPER PLACE SO I I'M- REALLY
HAPPY TO SEE THAT I DO HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS THAT ARE. THAT
ARE A LITTLE BIT. ABOUT THE
MECHANIC SO I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT BUT I WANT TO JUST
UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT SOME OF THIS SO.
THE PRESCRIBED FIRE WE KNOW
WE'RE SEEING A LOT OF DATA AND
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF PRESCRIBED FIRE AND- YOU
KNOW THE CHALLENGES AND
DIFFICULTIES AS WELL OF
UTILIZING IT. SO THE FIRST
MINUTE TREAT A MANAGEMENT TASK
FORCE REPORT RECOMMENDED
ESTABLISHING A NATIONAL
PRESCRIBED FIRE TRAINING
CENTER. AND DEVELOPMENT SO THAT
WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ACTUALLY YOU KNOW QUALIFIED TO
DO THIS WORK AND MORE OF THEM.
BECAUSE PRESCRIBED FIRES BEEN
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE BEEN
USING BUT THERE'S A LOT OF.
KIND OF HURDLES OF FULLY
IMPLEMENTING IT SO. YOU KNOW I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT HOW WE RAMPED UP
INTO AREAS WHERE WE THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE. SO THEY ALSO
RECOMMENDED DEVELOPING AN
AUTOMATED PRESCRIBE BOB COULD
PRESCRIBE BURN PERMIT. AND I'M
WONDERING IF THE EXPENDITURE
PLAN COVERS THE COST OF
BEGINNING ALL OF THAT WORK. AND
TANGENTIALLY A LOT OF THE FIRE
EXPERTS ALSO TALK ABOUT HAVING
BERMAN BOSSES THAT ARE
EXPERIENCED- AND SO I'M
WONDERING ABOUT KIND OF HOW WE
DEVELOP HOW WE GET ALL THIS
GOING BECAUSE- WE CAN TALK
ABOUT THE NEED FOR IT BUT WE
ALSO HAVE TO HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT IT
SO. IN THE BUDGET IS ALL IS
BLUE OR THOSE KINDS OF ISSUES
CONSIDERED AN FUNDED. THE NEXT
ONE QUESTION I'M GONNA TURN IT
JUST AGAIN JUST A MOMENT I
WANTED TO FIRST ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT YOU KNOW PRESCRIBED FIRE
IS A- IS A PRACTICE THAT OUR
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN USING FOR.
SINCE TIME IMMEMORIAL. AND
OSTALIH AND IRONICALLY IT WAS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IN YOU
KNOW DECADES SOUTH ACTUALLY
RESTRICTED THOSE PRESCRIBED
BURNING PRACTICES SO. AMONG ALL
OVER DOING ON PRESCRIBED
BURNING A LOT OF IT IS LEARNING
FROM. OUR TRIBAL PARTNERS. BUT
JESSICA CAN YOU TALK WE WE'VE
WE'VE IDENTIFIED NUMEROUS
BARRIERS THAT WE NEED TO REMOVE
TO ACTUALLY GET MORE PRESCRIBED
FIRE ON THE LAND. CAN YOU TALK
WITH DIRECTLY ABOUT WHERE OUR
INVESTMENTS ARE FOCUSED- IN IN
THIS PROPOSAL ON REMOVING THOSE
BARRIERS. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION- SO WHAT WE'VE
WE'RE BUILDING OUT SOME
INVESTMENTS WE MADE IN THE
PREVIOUS YEAR SOME CAL FIRE HAS
INCREASED ITS PRESCRIBED FIRE
PROGRAM. IT'S PAST TRAINING
PROGRAM AND ITS PRESCRIBED FIRE
CREWS SO OUR OWN IN HOUSE
WORKFORCE. IS EXPANDING
DRAMATICALLY- I'M MORE ALSO
PUTTING THESE OF COURSE
RESILIENCE DOLLARS WHICH ARE
AND- WHICH ARE ARE REALLY CAN'T
BE FOCUSED ON PRESCRIBED FIRE.
THERE'S FUNDING HERE FOR THE
AIRPORTS I'M TO BE ABLE TO WORK
AND PARTNER- WE IN ATTEMPT OUR
LOCAL AIRPORTS TO WORK. WITH
CALIFORNIA AND- TO INCREASE
THOSE BURNT WINDOWS ONE OF THE
LARGEST HURDLES WE STILL HAVE
THOUGH. IS THE PRESCRIBED FIRE
LIABILITY AND THAT'S ADDRESSED-
BROUGHT UP IN THAT TASK FORCE
REPORT. IT'S AN ISSUE THAT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE OUR PARTNER YANG-
AND WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
TO TRY TO WORK THROUGH BUT
UNTIL WE SOLVE. THE LIABILITY
CHALLENGE- THAT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BE. A LARGE HURDLE
TO PRESCRIBED FIRE BUT NOW WE
ARE GETTING A LOT OF PROGRESS
IN EDUCATING COMMUNITY.
OUTREACH ADDRESSING PERMITTING
HURDLES AND GETTING THE. WORK
FORCE IN PLACE TO DO THE WORK.
AND LAST POINT IN IS SOMEONE
YOU RAISE THE MAKE NATIONAL
PRESCRIBED TRAINING. WHERE
REALLY. EXCITED THE- OF THAT
COME TO CAL. AND WITH FIRE ON
MAKING THE CASE WORKING
DELEGATION AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES- TO REALLY MAKE THAT
INVESTMENT. GREAT AND THEN I
JUST HAVE TO OTHER QUESTIONS AT
ALL LINKED TOGETHER IN THE
FIRST IS HOW WE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT. ADDITIONAL DEDICATED FUEL
CREWS DON'T END UP GETTING
DIVERTED TO FIRE SUPPRESSION
AND JUST SORT OF PULLED AWAY
FROM. THE FOCUS ON PREVENTION
AND ALSO WHETHER CAL FIRE HAS A
PLAN TO ENCOURAGE RETENTION OF
THE CRUISE THEMSELVES SO- A
LITTLE BIT OF WORK FORCE
QUESTION A LITTLE BIT OF YOU
KNOW HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT
WE KEEP THE RESOURCES WERE
SAYING WE NEED TO KEEP THEM.
EXCELLENT QUESTION AND I WANT
TO JUST CHECK IN AND SEE IF TO
PORTER. IS STILL OUR PRESIDENT
OF PS I WOULD YEAH HE'S GONNA
SPEAKING JUST A MOMENT. I MEAN
JUST ACKNOWLEDGE CHEAP THE
WATER AND HIS TEAM. OKAY ARE
YOU KNOW ABSOLUTE PARTNERS WITH
OUR AGENCY AND EVERYONE ELSE
AND ALL THINGS WILD-
RESILIENCE- A LOT OF ATTENTION
AND RIGHTLY SO IT'S PROVIDED
TO. THEIR ABILITY TO RESPOND TO
FIRES. BUT THEY REALLY BAD- THE
EFFORT IN SO MANY RESPECTS
BUILDING RESILIENCE. THIRTY
PORTER- RESPONDING TO THE
FAMILY MEMBERS QUESTIONS AROUND
YOUR CRUISE AND HOW TO AVOID
THEM GETTING SORT OF
CANNIBALIZE. AND ALSO RETAIN.
ABSOLUTELY- THANK YOU SO. AND
THANK YOU. I REMEMBER. FOR THE
QUESTION. TRUE LAST YEAR WAS A
DIFFICULT YEAR AND THE
STATISTICS WILL SHOW. THAT THE
FUEL SCREWS SPOTFIRE- BECAUSE
OF THE SEASON THAT WE ALREADY
TALKED ABOUT- WE ARE COMMITTED
TO KEEPING THOSE CREWS WORKING
ON FUELS PROJECTS- ALEX THEIR
PRIMARY AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO
SO- SO THAT IS A- COMMITMENT.
FROM ME FOR FUEL SPRUCE- YOU-
AND THE AND CALIFORNIA TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN. AS FAR AS
RETENTION OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
YES WE'VE HAD SOME RETENTION
ISSUES- IN THOSE POSITIONS
BECAUSE THEY ARE TRAINED TO A
LEVEL OF. A FIREFIGHTER. AND
THEY ARE ELIGIBLE FOR-
TRANSFERRED INTO THAT TYPE OF
THE JOB. SO THERE'S A TERM
THAT'S BEEN. THAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING. PART OF- WHAT YOU
HEARD THE L. A. O. PER. RELATE
TO. DEVELOPING CREWMEN- A
CLASSIFICATION- BAD IS KEY IN
ORDER TO STOP THAT CHURN AND
GET GET POSITIONS SETTLED INTO
JOBS THAT THEY'LL BE AND FOR A
COUPLE OF YEARS AT A MINIMUM OR
MAYBE FOR A CAREER SO. THAT IS
IMPORTANT- IN THE PREVIOUS
DISCUSSION I THINK THAT WAS
ITEM OF THREE. AND THEN- CHIU
JUST A TOUCH ON A QUESTION THAT
YOU ASKED RELATED TO BURN
PERMITS. I AM FIRST AND
PRESCRIBED BURN PERMIT
SPECIFICALLY- WE HAVE AUTOMATED
OUR- BURN PERMIT PROGRAM
STATEWIDE SO NOW FOR REGULAR
BURN PERMITS THOSE ARE
AUTOMATED AND THERE. IT'S A WEB
BASED PROGRAM WE'RE IN THE
WE'RE IN THE PILOT PHASE SO
IT'S BEEN TESTED AND NOW IT'S
GOING TO RULE OUT- THIS SPRING
TO ALL OF THE STATE. THAT WILL
INCLUDE- AS WE GET INTO MORE OF
THE PRIVATE BURNING OR
PRESCRIBED BURNS- THAT WILL BE.
THE PLATFORM THAT'S USED THERE
AS WELL. THANK YOU OVER MUCH.
THANK YOU SOME MEMBER SMITH.
THANK YOU CHAIR BLOOM A COUPLE
OF KIRK OF CLARIFICATION I'M
NOT SURE WHO WOULD LIKE ANSWER
BUT THE NUMBERS IS IT 40%
FEDERAL LAND 37% PRIVATE LAND
AND THEN 23% STATE OWNED
PROPERTY I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
THOSE NUMBERS THAT ARE ABOUT.
NEAR 57% FEDERAL LANDS 40%
PRIVATE LAND AND 3% STATE OWNED
IN CALIFORNIA THE FOOD. I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE I HAD THE
RIGHT NUMBERS THERE. BECAUSE I
ADDED THAT THEY'RE PERFECT
THANK YOU AND THEN- A COUPLE
OTHER CONCERNS THAT THE
STEWARDSHIP. OF THE STATE OWNED
LAND. IT WAS TWELVE MILLION
APPROVED OF AND TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY THE BUDGET ONE
POSITION. AND FOR THE MONEY BUT
THE TO DATE THAT WOULD POSITION
HAS NOT BEEN FILLED- AND OF
WHAT IS A PROGRESS WITH THAT
EFFORT. AND HOW WAS THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
APPROPRIATIONS SPENT IF THAT
POSITION WASN'T FILLED. IN
DIFFERENT PARTS ON THAT IF
THEY'RE HERE. YOUR. HOW DID HER
COMMENTS. IT PARSES ONLINE WEEK
DIFFERENT OF THEM OKAY BUT IF
THEY ARE NOT ONLINE I'M HAPPY
TO TALK THROUGH WHAT ARE
PROPOSAL WHAT OUR DELIVERABLES
ARE WOULD BE PROPOSED AB
FINDING FOR STATE OWNED LANDS
IN THIS BUDGET THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO GIVE YOU SOME
TARGETS WELL IF IT IF IT WASN'T
FIELD AND YOU'RE JUST ASKING
FOR IT AGAIN THIS YEAR AND IT
WASN'T SPENT THAT'S WHAT THE
CLARIFICATION I JUST WANTED
PRETTY MUCH- WE CAN FOR. STATE
TAX ON THAT BUT THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING IS THAT IT'S A
NEW. INVESTMENT IT'S A IT'S A
NEW PROPOSAL OF CREATING AN
ACTUAL PROGRAM TO REALLY START
DOING FIRE RESILIENT AND FUEL
REDUCTION. ON STATE OWNED
LANDS- MOST OF OUR STATE.
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN RUN OFF THE
RECEIVING GRANT DOLLARS FROM-
THE FROM OUR FOREST HEALTH
ENTIRE CAPACITY PROGRAMS AND
OTHERS. AND SO THIS CREATES
TOUGH STUDY FUNDING STREAM FOR
STATE PARKS AND FISH AND
WILDLIFE. TO ACTUALLY START
DOING YOUR PRODUCTION WORK ON A
REGULAR BASIS AND TO REALLY
START RAMPING UP- THOSE
ACTIVITIES THAT TAKE STATE
PARKS FROM ABOUT A THOUSAND
ACRES HERE TREATED. TO TWENTY
FIVE. THOUSAND ACRES YOU'RE
TREATED ANSWERED. FROM ABOUT A
THOUSAND ACRES YOU'RE TREATED
TO- TO CLOSER TO FIFTEEN
THOUSAND ACRES HERE TO READ IT.
WOULD PRESERVE THE MIND IT
MIGHT IT SAYS THE L. A. O.'S
OFFICES CALLING FOR THIS A
REJECTION OF THIS PARTICULAR
PROGRAM SO I. DON'T KNOW IF L.
L. A- WOULD LIKE TO. COMMENT ON
THAT- NOT. WELL ASSEMBLY MEMBER
I MIGHT THE ARE STEVE FROM OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BE MAY
HAVE THAT SPECIFIC INFORMATION
THAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR. THANK
YOU YES- STEVEN MANAGEMENT
DEPARTMENT FINANCE I PERSONALLY
DON'T HAVE THE SPECIFIC ANSWER
QUESTION WHERE I WAS GOING TO
DO IS SAY WE'RE HAPPY TO FOLLOW
UP WITH PARKS AND MAKE SURE YOU
GET THAT INFORMATION- I IT.
APPEARS THAT THE PARKS ARE
PARKS COLLEAGUES THERE ARE NONE
THIS PROJECT. I ACTUALLY I NOW
UNDERSTAND YOUR QUESTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I BUT MY
APOLOGIES FOR THE CONFUSION-
WHAT WHAT YOU'RE SPECIFICALLY
ASKING ABOUT IS THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION. AND THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION ON- WILL HAVE TO
GIVE YOU AN EXACT NUMBER BUT
IT'S- YOU KNOW IN IN THAT. KIND
OF HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE-
FRAMED AND- SO THIS AT PROPOSAL
WE HAD PUT FORWARD WAS TO HELP
THEM. WE GET THEIR PROGRAMS
START TO FINISH THEY DON'T HAVE
pAT ALL. FOR THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION WHICH IS ONE OF
SEVERAL STATE ENTITIES. THAT
WE'RE PROPOSING FUNDING IN HERE
I'M WHO ARE STATE LANDOWNERS-
IN ADDITION TO STATE LANDS
COMMISSION OR PROPOSING
FUNDING. FOR OUT OF STATE PARKS
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE
AND CHAU CONSERVANCY- TO BE
ABLE TO TREAT. AND TO PROVIDE
FIRE RESILIENCE ON THE LAND
THAT WE ARE DOING AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO YOU- YEAH I'M BACK TO
YOU WITH YOUR STAFF ON THE
SPECIFICS OF THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION- PATHFINDING. OKAY
THEN ONE MORE IN REGARDS TO THE
CONSERVANCY'S. AND OF COURSE
THE OF PREVENTION PROJECTS AND
THE GRANTS. SIXTY MILLION FOR
EARLY ACTION ITEMS HOW LONG
WILL IT TAKE YOU TO GET THAT ON
THE GROUND. IN IN INTO THE-
WORK THAT YOU WANT TO GET DONE
THAT QUICK. FIX APPROVED AT THE
END OF MARCH IN THE BUDGET. WE
CAN STARTED APRIL FIRST APRIL
FIFTEENTH MAY. HOW QUICK CAN
YOU GET THAT MONEY OUT. THAT'S
A GREAT SIR IF MISTER AMERICANS.
ONLINE MAY BE WELL AS TO AN IT
BUT I CAN ANSWER. ALBUM YOU
THINK UP- SO. HE THE EARLY.
DOLLARS ARE REALLY DESIGNED TO
GET AN ADDITIONAL FIRE SEASONS
ARE STARTING NOW IN THE SPRING
ALLOWS US TO BE ABLE TO. TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF WORK WINDOWS GET
PROJECTS ARE READY TO GO MOST
OF THESE PROJECTS ARE QUOTE
UNQUOTE SHOVEL READY. THERE
WILL STILL BE A REALITY. ANY
BUILD UP AND IT WANTS TIME-
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T. COMMIT
CONTRACTORS AND- LOCAL
WORKFORCES UNTIL YOU ACTUALLY
HAVE THE DOLLARS IN HAND- AND
SO TO BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY GET
THIS DONE THERE'S A COUPLE
MONTHS- LEAD UP BUT WE NEED TO
GET IT STARTED NOW. SO THAT WE
CAN TRY TO FINISH THESE
PROJECTS BEFORE FIRE SEASON
TWENTY TWENTY THREE- SO THAT
THE EARTH REPORT FIRE SEASON
TWENTY TWENTY TWO IF WE WAIT A
FEW MONTHS. IT BUMPS INTO FIRE
SEASON TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND
GET THEM DONE. YOU KNOW CLOSER
TO THE FALL OF. TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. I DO BELIEVE MYSELF MY
COLLEAGUES WE WANT THAT MONEY
TO GET EARLY ACTION THEN PUT IT
TO WORK RIGHT AWAY AS. THE
CHAIR SPOKEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JUST NOW WE KNOW IF WERE.
FUNDING EARLY. WE WILL WE WILL
WORK. VERY HARD TO GET THAT
WELL FUNDING- WORKING
IMMEDIATELY. AS JESSICA
MENTIONS AND THEN OBVIOUSLY BE
ABLE TO COME BACK AND REPORT ON
HOW THAT GOT BANNED. I COMING
MONTHS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND MEDICARE THIS IS BRIAN
BROWN FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AGAIN JUST TO.
RESPOND TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH'S QUESTION SIMPLY
REFERENCED OUR RECOMMENDATION.
DO YOU WANT TO CONFIRM WE
DIDN'T. RAISE AN OBJECTION TO
THE FUNDING FOR PARKS- WE DE AS
MISS MORRIS NOTED. OUR CONCERNS
WITH THE SPECIFICALLY THAT
TWELVE MILLION FOR STATE LANDS
COMMISSION. AND THAT WAS
BECAUSE THERE HAD BEEN PREVIOUS
FUNDING PROVIDED. AS YOU NOTED
FOR- TO DEVELOP AN INVENTORY
MANAGEMENT PLAN. WHICH HAD NOT
YET BEEN COMPLETED SO. THAT WE
CAN WE CAN WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO. FOLLOW UP ON
A QUESTION ABOUT THE STATUS OF
THE ON THAT. THANK FOR THE
CLARIFICATION ON THAT THANK YOU
AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PLEASE TELL ME YOU HAVE NOTHING
TO ADD. MORE TO OF FINANCE I
JUST HAD ONE NO ACTUALLY FROM
QUESTION- ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
HAD ASKED ABOUT ONGOING FUNDING
AND I WANTED TO NOTE THAT. THE
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN CHIEF EUROPE
FUNDING IS ACTUALLY I SOMEBODY
MENTIONED BEFORE TO BACK FILL
THAT SB NINE ONE COMMITMENT. AT
THAT ALSO IS MEANT TO BE
ONGOING AND WE ARE ACTUALLY. WE
ARE ALSO PROPOSING TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO EXTEND THAT
INVESTMENT THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY NINE WHICH
IS AN ADDITIONAL. FIVE YEARS ON
TOP OF THE ORIGINAL
AUTHORIZATION. GRADES THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WELL THAT THERE
BRINGS US TO THE END OF THIS
ITEM- LET'S SEE A FOR
OURSELVES- HEADLONG INTO ISSUE
SIX THE- CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE CLIMATE CATALYST
FUND ITEM AND HOPEFULLY WE'LL
GET THROUGH THIS ONE AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE IF PAST IS PROLOGUE
WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
LIKELY WAITING TO GIVE US THEIR
AND PUT ON THE A CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN ISSUE. SEVEN
THANK YOU SURE BLOOM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS TAYLOR
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. SENIOR ADVISOR FOR
CLIMATE FINANCE- VERY HAPPY
HAVE THE CHANCE TO TALK WITH
YOU ABOUT THE CLIMATE CHANNELS
ONE PROGRAM. A SPECIFICALLY THE
APPLICATION IN CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE AND I WILL BE BRIEF
IN MY REVIEW HERE. BOB THE
CALIFORNIA DO YOU YOU MAY
RECALL FROM LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
IS SOMETHING OF A NEW. APPROACH
A NEW TOOL TO LIKE IN THE
STATE'S APPROACH TO CLIMATE
FINANCE AND- DANCING ARE THE
ENERGY CLIMATE INFRASTRUCTURE
AGENDA. IT IS REALLY IN THE
MODEM DEVELOPMENT FINANCE- IN
THE WAY THAT HAS DRIVEN
ECONOMIC GROWTH THROUGHOUT THIS
COUNTRY AND AROUND THE WORLD
FOR A LONG TIME. UTILIZING A
DEVELOPMENT BANK MINDSET TO SIT
ALONGSIDE OUR GRANT PROGRAMS IN
OUR REGULATIONS DEMOBILIZED
PUBLIC MONEY BUT WITH
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF PRIVATE
MONEY ALONGSIDE. JERRY TIME
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ENGAGING
THE PRIVATE SECTOR ENGAGING
LOCAL PROJECTS. LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND ECONOMIC GROWTH.
THE IS A TOOL FOR THIS TO
LEVERAGE FROM PUBLIC MONEY TO
THAT OF. THIS IS A MY- ROUGHLY.
CHARACTERIZED AS GREEN BANKS
THAT IS NOT A POOR ANYMORE
TWELVE STAY ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THAT'S A BIT OF ACROSS THE
GROUND WORLD THE MOBILE I
COMMITTEE STRUCTURE. NOW BEING
DISCUSSED THE FEDERAL AS A
MAJOR TOOL. TWO REALLY DRIVE
SIGNIFICANT ANDERSON IN CAPITAL
FOR CLIMATE RESEARCHER GOALS IN
MULTIPLE SECTORS. IT BEYOND THE
MODEL HERE WOULD LEVERAGE THE
SIGNIFICANT CAPACITIES OF THE
STATE INFRASTRUCTURE BANK WHICH
IS TWENTY FIVE PLUS YEARS OLD.
HAS MOBILIZED MORE THAN FORTY
BILLION DOLLARS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS USING A
RANGE OF. FAIRLY STANDARD
PUBLIC BANKING TOOLS. BUT NOW
WITH THE ADDITION OF AB SEVENTY
EIGHT FROM LAST SESSION.
CREATING A CATALYST FUND
ENABLING YOU HAVING TO USE
THOSE TOOLS AND THE HUMAN
RESOURCES. TO DRIVE MONEY. AND
PARTNER WITH PRIVATE CAPITAL
FOR SIGNIFICANT INFRASTRUCTURE
EXPANSION. REALLY TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE FACT THAT
THERE AND IS A SIGNIFICANT
PRIVATE INTERESTS AND
SUPPORTING STATE INFRASTRUCTURE
GOALS FOR CLIMATE AND CLEAN
ENERGY. INCLUDING. THE SPACE
APARTMENTS MART AT. WE'RE SORRY
ROUGHLY THREE TO DOLLARS OR MO.
OF PRIVATE FOR EVERY DOLLAR
DEPLOYED. SO THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTION TO THE
STATE'S OFFICIAL APPROACH TO
OUR COMING CLEAN EERGY AGENDA-
BUT IN A COMPARISON DOWNEY
APPROACH THIS LAST YEAR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL LAST
YEAR OF A LARGE SCALE TOP DOWN
CAPITAL ONE. WE'RE LOOKING
SECTOR BY SECTOR AND NEAR TERM
OPPORTUNITIES TO PROVE THAT HE
SAID. IT IS LEVERAGED REVOLVING
LOAN FUND PROGRAMS THAT DEPLOYS
CAPITAL UNLOCKS MARKETS AND
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS. IF THE
MONEY BACK AND REINVEST IT. CAN
BE A KEY NEW TOOL THAT WE CAN
SCALE OVER TIME THIS IS
RESPONSIVE TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S RECOMMENDATIONS OF. A
PILOT APPROACH. FROM LAST
YEAR'S OFFER. THE RECORDING
SECTOR. WE ARE WE OF THE CASH
NEED ACROSS THE RANGE OF
CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURAL.
INDUSTRIES GENERALLY.
PARTICULARLY IN METHANE
MANAGEMENT AND UTILIZATION OF
ORGANIC WASTE AND LARGELY UP IN
PARTICULAR IN THE FOOD
PROCESSING SECTOR WORK WE'VE
ALREADY HAD A NUMBER OF
DISCUSSIONS WITH. PRIVATE FIRMS
PRIVATE INVESTORS THAT WANT TO
IMPROVE ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND
CLEAN ENERGY UTILIZATION. AND
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS IN
THE FOOD PROCESSING SECTOR AND
THIS IS A BIG CONTRIBUTOR TO
OUR GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS WE
NOW KNOW THAT. ADAM ROUGHLY 8%
EMISSIONS THE AG SECTOR
CONTRIBUTES MORE THAN IMPORTED
POWER DOES AND IS COAST GUARD
CLOSELY BEHIND IN STATE
ELECTRICITY GENERATION SO THIS
IS A SIGNIFICANT. SOURCE OF
GREENHOUSE GASES BUT IT IS ALSO
A SIGNIFICANT POTENTIAL GREEN
TRIBUTE HERE TO THE SENATE
SOLUTIONS. BE AFFECTED THE
PRODUCTION OF CLEAN RENEWABLE
WELL A FIFTY EIGHT THE
PRODUCTION OF EVENTS POPULOUS
OF HYDROGEN DRIVING DOWN ENERGY
CONSUMPTION. THROUGH ENERGY
EFFICIENCY ALTERNATIVE
OBSTACLES PRACTICES THAT ARE
SIMILAR TO OKAY- THE TOOLS AND
TECHNIQUES THAT ARE BEING
DEPLOYED. THEY ARE ON THE EDGE
OF COMMERCIAL. ACCELERATION AND
THIS AMOUNT OF PUBLIC CAPITAL
CAN REALLY LEVERAGE. THE
MAINSTREAM OF. ADOPTION SO WE
ARE OFFERING THE THEY ARE REAL
OPPORTUNITIES- AND IT'S A
UNDER. UNDERGRAD ASPECT OF OUR
CLIMBING COMMUNITY AGENDA AND
ACCOUNTS FOR. I WAS FORCED TO
MAKE US. CONTRIBUTION THE LAST
THING I WANT POINT OUT THERE
ARE ALSO. FROM THE L. A. R.
ASSESSMENT OF THE HERE- THE
KIND FONG WORKS CLOSE WITH. GO
BUT ALSO WITH- JOHNSON PLANNING.
AND ENTER GROWTH COUNCIL- AND
WE ABOUT PROGRAM GREAT OF AB
SEVENTY EIGHT TO ARTICULATE
WHERE THE CAPITAL'S FUND IS
LOOKING TO MAKE INVESTMENTS TO
BE AMERICA THE FORWARD LOOKING
YEAR. THIS CATEGORY WAS NOT
INCLUDED IN THAT BOB REALLY
BECAUSE IT WAS A LATE BREAKING
OPPORTUNITY THAT WAS BROUGHT
FORWARD. BY OUR COLLEAGUES AT
CDFA INTERESTED IN USING THE
IRAQ AND OUR LOAN PROGRAM
BROACHED TO REALLY DRIVE
PROGRESS IN THE COMMUNITIES
THAT THEY'RE AWARE OF ANSWER.
SO THIS I THINK IS INDICATIVE
OF A KEY PARTNERSHIP AND HOW WE
HOPE THIS PROGRAM GROWS OVER
TIME. THE I THINK IN THE
COMMENTS FUND AS A DEVELOPMENT
FINANCE FUNCTION FOR THE
STATE'S CLEAN ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE GOALS PRODUCT
AND WITH PARTNERSHIPS AT THE
AGENCY LEVEL SETTING POLICY
SETTING REGULATION. WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THEIR
CONSTITUENCIES AND OBERNOLTE
LIKE. THIS DEVELOPMENT FINANCE
METHODOLOGY I THINK IS THE
MODEL FOR DRIVING SIGNIFICANT
PRIVATE CAPITAL LONG STOCK WHAT
IS EFFECTIVELY A MODEST- PUBLIC
CONTRIBUTION AGAIN TO THE PILOT
AGAIN AT THE L. A. O. SUGGESTED
WE START WITH SOME. OF THAT IN
A IN A NUTSHELL IS THE
APPROACH- FOR THE COMING
CATALYSTS THAN PLANETS MURDER
ACT AS PROPOSED IN HIS BUDGET
AND I WELCOME ANY ANY COMMENTS
EITHER NOW OR SUBSEQUENTLY.
GIVEN YOUR TIGHT CALENDAR
TODAY. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THE- PRESENTATION. ARE THERE.
ANY QUESTIONS. THINK OF A THIS.
THANK YOU. THREE I HAVE A
QUESTIONS THE K. AND TRADE
EXPAND FOR- THE CURRENT TIME
DOES NOT INCLUDE FUND FOR THE
CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE PROGRAM-
DOES THE ADMINISTRATION INTEND
THAT THE CLEAN FUEL REWARDS
PROGRAM- ADMINISTERED BY THE
UTILITIES WILL BECOME THE
PRIMARY STATE REBATE PROGRAM. I
THINK THAT MAYBE FOR THE NEXT
ITEM YEAH ALL THE DOCUMENTS CAN
BE FOR ITEM- SEVEN. THANKS HOLD
ON TO THAT QUESTION. OKAY I
HAVE IT. OKAY I'LL ALWAYS STAND
FOR OUR GREAT THANK YOU- LEARN
NOW WHY DON'T WE HEAR FROM THE
L. A. L. FAVORING WITH THE
BOARD WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- OUR COMMENTS
WERE REPRODUCED IN THE AGENDA
SO I'M NOT GOING TO RUN THROUGH
ALL OF THEM IN THE INTEREST. OF
TIME I JUST WANTED TO NOTE THAT
WE DID- AS MISTER ADLER NOTED-
SUGGEST A PUBLIC PROGRAM IN OUR
COMMENTS ON THE ECONOMIC
CATALYST. FARM THE LAST YEAR.
AND THIS OTHER INDEED TO BE
CONSIDERED SUCH A PILOT
PROJECT- WE ALSO NOTETHAT
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES I THINK
GENERALLY REPORT INFORMATION
ABOUT THE CLIMATE CATALYST
LOANS ITS PORTFOLIO- AND SHOULD
YOU PROVIDE FUNDING FOR CLIMATE
CATALYST WE RECOMMEND-
INCREASING THE RE EXTENDING THE
REPORTING PART SO MUCH REQUIRE
I THINK TO ALSO REPORT A LITTLE
BIT MORE DETAILED FINANCIAL
INFORMATION ABOUT EACH PROJECT.
SO THAT THE STATEMENT SAYS THE
FINANCIAL RISKS ARE AND THE
EXTENT TO WHICH PRIVATE CAPITAL
IS PARTICIPATING IN FINANCING
THESE PROJECTS. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
ABOUT OUR COMMENTS ON THE
AGENDA. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THIRTY FIVE OUR
DEPARTMENT FINANCE AT NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENT AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WELL THIS IS A- INTERESTING
PROPOSAL AS IT WAS LAST YEAR-
THERE SO- I THINK WE UNDERSTAND
IT A LITTLE BIT BETTER BUT- I
KNOW- OUR STAFF- AS CONTINUING
QUESTIONS ABOUT- JUST HOW
EFFECTIVE THE- THE- OF THE
PROGRAM WILL BE AND THAT MIGHT
BE DIFFICULT TO- TO DETERMINE
GIVEN THAT IT'S A NEW PROGRAM
AND- EXPERIMENT OF SORTS. BUT
TO- WILL CONTINUE TO LOOK AT IT
AND TO COME BACK TO IT TO- AND
FUTURE HEARING. MISTER CHAIR
YES QUICK COMMENT AND THAT IS
THE EFFECTIVENESS I WILL I WILL
BE INTERESTED AFFECTING THIS
POST IN THE SHORT RUN BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY IN THE LONG RUN IN
TERMS OF OTHER CAPTURE THANK
YOU. POINT TAKEN- ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN IS THE CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN AND WE'VE GOT
A PRETTY LONG LIST OF POTENTIAL
PRESENTERS HERE AS A SECRETARY.-BLUMENFELD WITH US. I AM JEFF.
MHM THERE YOU ARE. EXCELLENT
I'M THANK YOU CHAD- MEMBERS- I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE TODAY
MY NAME'S JERRY BLUMENFELD AND
I'M THE SECRETARY OF
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY AND TOGETHER
WITH LAUREN SANCHEZ THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR CLIMATE POLICY
AND INTERGOVERNMENTAL RELATIONS
THAT CALIBRATE WILL BE
PRESENTING ON THE OVERALL
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS FUND
BUDGET AFFECTIONATELY KNOWN AS
TH G. G. R. AFTER I HATE
ACRONYMS BUT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO USE THAT ONE- JUST BEFORE WE
GET INTO THE NUMBERS CHAD I
JUST WANTED TO PROVIDE SOME
BRIEF CONTEXT- ESPECIALLY BRIEF
NOTING. HOW BUSY- CALENDAR IS
TODAY THE CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
LEADERSHIP HAS BEEN A ROLE
MODEL OF AMBITIOUS ACTION IN A
POSITIVE CLOSE TO DRIVING AND
HANS EFFORTS BY GOVERNMENTS AND
ACT AS IN THE US AND AROUND THE
GLOBE AND IS PART OF THE
LEADERSHIP WE'VE INTEGRATED A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN TO ACHIEVE
OUR BOLD CLIMATE TARGETS I
CLIMATE PROGRAMS BUILD ON A
LONG HISTORY OF ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION
ACROSS THE STATE. AND IF YOU
HAD FOR ME BEFORE THIS
ADMINISTRATION WILL CONTINUE TO
ADVANCE EQUITY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IN THAT
CONTEXT I'LL BIPARTISAN EFFORTS
BANDED MINISTRATIONS AND HAVE
BENEFITTED FROM STRONG
LEADERSHIP THREE GOVERNORS OUR
PARTNERS YOU IN THE LEGISLATURE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THE NONPROFIT AND PRIVATE
SECTORS AND I REGULATORY
AGENCIES CALIFORNIA HAS GROWN
OUR ECONOMY BY REDUCING
EMISSIONS THE HOBBIT INTENSITY
OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY IS
DECLINING AND WE HAVE AMONG THE
MOST AMBITIOUS TARGETS IN THE
WILD AND EMPLOYED MORE
CALIFORNIANS IN THE CLEAN
ECONOMY. THAN ANY OTHER STATE
IN THE NATION WITH ALSO HE
COUPLED OUR EMISSION REDUCTIONS
AFFECTS GROWING OUR ECONOMY BY
26% WHILE REDUCING CARBON
EMISSIONS BY 13% APPLE FELT IT
APPROACH TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE NCLUDES POLICIES TO
INCREASE BUILDING EFFICIENCY
RENEWABLE POWER RENEWABLE FUELS
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES CLEAN
AFRAID OPTIONS IN AN ECONOMY
WIDE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM AND
PROTECTION. OF OUR NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS COPS GO BEING
PLANNED UPDATE WILL CHIP. BLOCK
DRUG OF COP NEUTRALITY BY TWO
FORTY FIVE. WILL BEGIN THIS
SPRING WITH THE PLAY TO THE- OF
AND LATE TWENTY TWO TWO
CONSIDER. WITH ON ALL OF OUR
EXIST CLIMATE. TO DO. IN THE
NEXT ECADE. FOR EXAMPLE THE
CAP ON A CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
WILL DROP 4% ANNUALLY FROM
TODAY TO TWENTY THIRTY. THAT'S
TWICE THE RATE THEN IT DROPPED
IN THE LAST DECADE AND THAT'S A
SIGNIFICANT DEAL IN TERMS OF.
EMISSION REDUCTIONS IS THE
EQUIVALENT TO RETIRING TWELVE
CEMENT BLOCKS AND A STATE. TAX
YEAH IN THE NEXT DECADE. WE
HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO
ACCELERATE. OF PETITIONS
REDUCTIONS DRAMATICALLY AND
GOVERNOR NEWS AND RECOGNIZE THE
NEED TO ACCELERATE OUR ACTIONS
ON CLIMATE. LAST YEAR ISSUED
EXECUTIVE ORDERS ON ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AND NATURAL
WETLANDS. TO MOVE US TOWARDS AN
EQUITABLE LOW CARBON AND
RESILIENT FUTURE FOLLOWING
HAPPEN TRADE PROGRAMS PRIMARY
PATH IS REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS ACROSS EIGHTY
PERCENT. OF THE STATE'S ALSO
FUEL SECTOR PEOPLE CAN REVENUE
BENEFIT IS IMPORTANT TO
HIGHLIGHT AND DEPUTIES WE
LEARNED SANCHEZ WILL GO INTO
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET NUMBERS IN
GREAT DETAIL. I ALSO WANT TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
CONGRATULATE LEARN ON A
REQUIREMENT TO BE SENIOR
ADVISER TO JOHN KERRY.
PRESIDENT BY INTERNATIONAL
CLIMATE ENVOY WE'RE EXCITED TO
HAD TO TAKE CALIFORNIA'S
MESSAGE TO THE GLOBAL STAGE.
THE BRIDGE SHORTLY BEFORE SHE
DOES THAT SHE'S GONNA EXPLAIN
CALIFORNIA'S GRF EXPENDITURE
PLAN. THIS IS CERTAINLY THE
MOST IMPORTANT- PRESENTATION.
SO MAKE PRIOR TO THAT
ASSIGNMENT. BUT WE CAN SCHEDULE
HER AS WE- THANK YOU TO THANK
YOU SECRETARY BLUMENFELD- AND
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS THAT
REALLY IS A PLEASURE TO BE
PRESENTING TO YOU ALL THIS
MORNING. AS YOU'VE HEARD THE
LAST FEW HOURS TWENTY TWENTY
WAS REALLY AN UNPRECEDENTED
YEAR OF ACCELERATED CLIMATE
IMPACTS IN EVERY CORNER OF OUR
STATE FROM RECORD BREAKING HEAT
TO HISTORIC DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES. TO GATHER CALIFORNIA
CALL CONTINUE TO DEVELOP AND
ENFORCE OUR PROGRAMS AIMED AT
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE ENVIRONMENT AND SURE TO
FOCUS ON EQUITY IN ALL OF OUR
WORK AND ADVANCED ARE VICIOUS
CLIMATE GOALS AS SECRETARY
BLUMENFELD JUST SHARED.
GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAS CONTINUED
TO PRIORITIZE OURCLIMATE
ACTION WITH THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL A KEY PILLAR OF THE
PROPOSED CLIMATE AND
ENVIRONMENT BUDGET IS THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
EXPENDITURE PLAN I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT THE JDRF PROPOSAL
TODAY. TO DATE THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM HAS GENERATED
ALMOST THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
IN AUCTION PROCEEDS TO FIND
CRITICAL CLIMB INVESTMENT
PROGRAMS. INCLUDING AN OPTION
THAT POSTED A PROJECTED OVER
SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
PROCEEDS JUST LAST MONTH.
THANKS TO YOUR LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP AND DIRECTION TO
PRIORITIZE INVESTMENTS AND
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AS ENVISIONED IN SB
FIVE THIRTY FIVE IN AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY. DIRECTING PROJECTS
TOWARDS THESE COMMUNITIES IS A
KEY OBJECTIVE OF THE FIVE. WE
CONTINUE TO SET EXAMPLE FOR
OTHER NATIONAL AND SUB NATIONAL
CLIMATE PROGRAMS BY EMPHASIZING
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND EQUITY
AND PROGRAM DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENTATION. NOTABLY OF THE
SIX POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
THAT IS ALREADY BEEN
LEGISLATIVELY APPROPRIATED AND
SPENT ABOUT 55% OF THOSE
PROCEEDS HAVE DIRECTLY
BENEFITED ARE DISADVANTAGED IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. HERE
TWENTY NINETEEN SO ARE THE
SINGLE LARGEST ANNUAL
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA'S
PRIORITY POPULATIONS TO DATE.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROVIDE PROPOSED
EXPENDITURE PLAN INCLUDES ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
INCLUDING SEVERAL KEY EARLY
ACTIONS FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TO TWENTY ONE. FOR WE
PRIORITIZED EXISTING PROGRAMS
THAT ADVANCE THE STATE PARTIES
OUT OF NUMBER FOR ONE EQUITY
AND ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
NUMBER TWO PROTECTING PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THREE DRIVING A
GREEN ECONOMIC RECOVERY WHILE
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS EXPENDITURE PLAN ALSO
ADVANCES THE GOVERNOR'S RECENT
CLIMATE EXECUTIVE ORDERS ON
THEIR MACHINE VEHICLES AND
NATURAL BURKE AND LANCE. THE
PLAN PROPOSES THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR THE
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION
PROGRAM CREATED THROUGH SB SIX
SEVENTEEN IN WHICH DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE OFFICER CHIANG FROM
CARBON HIGHLIGHTED EARLIER.
BUDGET ALSO PROPOSES FUNDING
FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF F. B. TWO
HUNDRED THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER PROGRAM DESIGNED
TO ACHIEVE SUSTAINABLE
OPERATIONS FOR OUR DRINKING
WATER SYSTEMS AND ENSURE THAT
THE ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
THAT CURRENTLY LACK ACCESS. TO
SAFE DRINKING WATER RECEIVE
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
TOGETHER THESE INVESTMENTS
REFLECT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PRIORITIZING OF PROTECTING
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE STATE'S
MOST VULNERABLE AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. THE
PLAN ALSO PROPOSES SIX HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
DEDICATED TO THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR THE LARGEST SOURCE OF
CALIFORNIA'S GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND THE MAIN DRIVER
OF HARMFUL AIR POLLUTION IN OUR
STATE. THE PROGRAMS INCLUDED IN
THE TRANSPORTATION PACKAGE
INCLUDES A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION FOR EQUITY FOCUSED
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS WHICH
TOGETHER FIND FOR EXAMPLE LOW
INCOME CAR SHARING PROGRAMS
VANPOOL IS FOR AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS AND SCHOOL BUSES IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES. THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN MILLION FOR
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE PROGRAMS
INCLUDING INCENTIVES FOR CLEAN
TRUCKS BUSES AND OFF ROAD
FREIGHT EQUIPMENT THE SO CALLED
EIGHT STAR PROGRAM RUN OUT OF
FUNDING IN JUST TWO WEEKS. AS
AN ILLUSTRATION OF HIGH DEMAND
FOR THESE INCENTIVES ACROSS THE
STATE. AND THE HUNDRED SEVENTY
MILLION FOR THE FARMER PROGRAM
WHICH FUNDS CLAMOR CLEANER
AGRICULTURAL VEHICLES AND
ENGINES. THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
WHICH RECEIVES THE BULK OF
FARMER FUNDING HAS OVER TWO
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS. IN
PENDING APPLICATIONS. TURNING
OVER OLDER AND HIGHER POLLUTING
VEHICLES AND EQUIPMENT AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE IS
ESSENTIAL TO PROTECTING PUBLIC
HEALTH. AS MANY CALIFORNIANS
CONTENT CONTINUE TO SUFFER FROM
POOR AIR QUALITY AND ARE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES HAVE
BORNE THE CLERK BURDEN OF
POLLUTION FOR TOO LONG. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FURTHER
PROPOSES THE RE AUTHORIZATION
OF THE LEGISLATURE IS ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT WHICH I UNDERSTAND
IS BEING DISCUSSED ELSEWHERE
BUT WOULD ALSO PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND TO CLEAN UP
CONSTRUCTION AND AGRICULTURAL
EQUIPMENT AND LIGHT AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES. TOGETHER WITH A
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED
PROGRAMS WHICH ACCOUNT 465% OF
GRF SPENDING AND INCLUDE HIGH
SPEED RAIL TRANSIT PROJECTS AND
TRANSIT ORIENTED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. OR TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENTS ARE A KEY PILLAR OF
THE TRANSITION TO AN EQUITABLE
SUSTAINABLE CALIFORNIA FOR ALL.
THE GOVERNOR IS DID YOU ARE OF
PROPOSAL ALSO REFLECTS OUR
COMMITMENT TO BUILDING CLIMATE
RESILIENCE THERE ARE NATURAL
BREAKING PLANS. AS ALREADY
HIGHLIGHTED BY SECRETARY
CROWFOOT AND DISCUSSED IN ITEM
FIVE INCLUDED WITHIN THIS PLAN
IS THREE HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
AND INVESTMENT STARTS SB NINE A
ONE TO SUPPORT WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE AND SUSTAINABLE
FORESTRY. ANOTHER KEY PILLAR OF
OUR NATURAL WORKING LANDS
EFFORT IS OUR CLIMATE SMART I
GRAMS THE BUDGET INCLUDES
THIRTY MILLION IN FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND I.
HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE GRANTS FOR ARM ON FARM
SOIL MANAGEMENT PRACTICES I
WANT TO THANK SECRETARY ROSS
AND HER UNDER SECRETARY JENNY
LESTER MOFFETT. WHO IS WITH US
THIS MORNING FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS CRITICAL
PROGRAM. IN CLOSING WE ARE
EAGER TO WORK WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS ON OUR COLLECTIVE
CLIMATE AND EQUITY AGENDA IF I
DIDN'T HARRIS ADMINISTRATION
HAS ALSO PROPOSED JUSTICE
FORTY. AN INITIATIVE TO SPEND
40% OF INVESTMENTS AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES TO
ADVANCE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
THIS INITIATIVE BUILT ON YOUR
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP AND
DIRECTION TO PRIORITIZE
INVESTMENTS IN DISADVANTAGED
AND LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES.
YOUR ONGOING SUPPORT AND OUR
TIRELESS EFFORTS ON
ADMINISTRATION WIDE CLIMATE
INVESTMENT PROGRAMS WE HAVE
LESSONS AND STRATEGIES TO SHARE
WITH OUR NEW PARTNERS. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP WITH ALL OF YOU AND
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE TO
ADVANCE PARTIES OF CLIMATE
EQUITY PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH
AND DRIVING AGREED ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY SECRETARY BLUMENFELD
AND I ARE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU LET ME
LEAD OFF THEIR QUESTIONS- BY-
ASKING BECAUSE ESSENTIALLY
QUESTION THAT IS. POSED IN THE
STAFF REPORT JOHN CAN YOU SHED
SOME LIGHT ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S THINKING AND
NOT FUNDING. TRANSFORMATIVE
CLIMATE COMMUNITIES URBAN
GREENING LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION. CLEAN VEHICLE
REBATE PROGRAM AND TO- WASTE
DIVERSION AND RECYCLING. I KNOW
IT'S A LOT. THERE IS THERE IS A
LOT- CHAD THIS IS JARED AND
LEARN CAN CHIME IN ON ON THE
SPECIFICS- I GUESS. THE FRAMING
THAT LARA AND- GAVE TO THE
BUDGET- IT IS THE IS THE ONE I
THINK INSTRUCTED HOW WE
PRIORITIZED FUNDING- AND- IT'S
REALLY LOOKING AT ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE HEALTH AND THEN GREEN
ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND AS- AS WE
KNOW. EVEN WITH THE HELP THE
AUCTION RETURNS FROM LAST WEEK
ASSEMBLY ISN'T I'M NOT MONEY
AND WITH SIXTY FIVE PERCENT. OF
THE FUNDING GOING TO CONTINUES
APPROPRIATIONS- THERE'S LESS.
DISCRETIONARY FUND AND GO
AROUND AND SO ON ON ALL THESE
PROGRAMS BUT I'M PICKING UP ON
ON ONE OF THE LED QUESTIONS- A
MINUTE AGO ABOUT CVR PETE FOR
INSTANCE- THERE'S A COMMITMENT
TO MAKE SURE THAT. THAT WE'VE
WATCHED I PROJECT LINE CAMPOLI
WE CURRENTLY FOR INSTANCE HAVE
FORTY NINE BILLION DOLLARS IN
CV HAPPY- WAIT WAIT COMMITTED
TO LOOKING AT THIS AS THE YEAR
GOES ON- AND- IT SAYS. YOU KNOW
THESE ARE VERY HARD TRADE OFFS
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND WE TOOK A
LOT OF- DILIGENCE AND SCRUTINY
LOOKING OUT WALK WHAT MADE THE
MOST SENSE GIVEN THOSE THREE.
CRITERIA IT SO I'M WE CAN TALK
ABOUT ANY ONE OF THOSE AND MORE
SPECIFIC DETAIL- BUT THE BIG
THRUST WAS TO MAKE SURE ALL
THAT WE WILL FUNDING THINGS
THAT WE'RE TRULY TRANSFORMATIVE
AND THE AGENDA THAT WOULDN'T BE
FUNDED- OTHERWISE. AND THAT
THOSE THREE GOALS. I DON'T KNOW
LARGE WANTED TO ADD ANYTHING.
ARE YOU COVERED IT SECRETARY
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT- THANK
YOU- I. I THANK ALLAH- WITHHOLD
ASKING MORE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
BECAUSE I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE WANT TO WEIGH IN ON ON
THE- THESE PRIORITIES AND THAT
WE CAN HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
SEPARATELY AND OFFLINE- MISERY
THIS I KNOW YOU HAD QUESTIONS
EARLIER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I WANT TO FOCUS MY QUESTIONS
ON. OF THE LACK OF FUNDING- FOR
C. V. R. P. AND URBAN GREENING-
SO I HAD PREVIOUSLY ASKED THIS.
OF ITO'S ART THE CURRENT PLAN
DOESN'T INCLUDE FUNDING FOR THE
CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE PROGRAM
AND SO I WAS WONDERING IF THE
ADMINISTRATION INTENDS THAT THE
CLEAN FUEL REWARDS PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY UTILITIES- WILL
THIS BE THE PRIMARY STATE READ
REBATE PROGRAM FOR NOW ON SINCE
WE ARE NOT FUNDING C. V. R. P.
I'M- SAID THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REVERSAL- WE ARE
CONTINUING TO FIND C. VIP THE
VIP'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
PROGRAM FOR US WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE TRANSPORTATION SIGNIFICAN
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS IN
THIS PROJECT WE JUST WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE PRIORITIZE
EQUITY BASED TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS THAT FOCUS
SPECIFICALLY ON LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AND REDUCING AIR
POLLUTION FROM HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. I'M THE CITY OUR
PROGRAMS THE UPKEEP PROGRAM- IS
AN IMPORTANT HELLO- WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE ALL BASICALLY FOR
THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS
IT IT BASICALLY PROVIDES
INCENTIVE FUNDING AT THE TIME
OF SALE FULL ELECTRIC VEHICLE
PURCHASES AS YOU MENTIONED-
THAT THERE ARE THERE SOME OF
THE WAYS THAT THAT THAT IS
BEING FUNDED SO FESTIVAL WE
HAVE A FORTY NINE MILLION
DOLLAR. BALANCE IN THAT IN
ADDITION THROUGH- THAT CLEAN
FUELS PROGRAM WE HAVE ABOUT A
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
THAT'S PAID FOR THROUGH- THAT
PROGRAM AT THE TIME OF SALE
LEASE SAYS THAT IS WE ALSO
LOOKING AT- THE FEDERAL
ELECTRIC VEHICLE TAX REBATE
PROGRAM OF SEVENTY FIVE
HUNDRED- AND- THAT NEW ADMITTED
MINISTRATION LOOK AT HOW THAT
IS EXTENDED SO WE ARE A 100%
THAT THOSE WITH YOU ON MAKING
SURE ALL THAT. THE PACKAGES OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLES IS IT MAKE IT
EASIER WE WANT TO MAKE SURE OF
IT IS MADE EASIER PARTICULARLY
FOR LOW INCOME AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES BUT
WE CONTINUE THE CDO PROGRAM C.
V. I. P. PROGRAM WE CONTINUE TO
BELIEVE IN IT- WE IN THIS
BUDGET JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR- FUNDING IS VERY
TARGETED AT THE COMMUNITIES.
THAT NEEDED THE FUNDING THE
MOST. OKAY THANK YOU NOT I WITH
YOU THAT WE BE FOR. ON LOW AND
INCOME CAN. AND THAT THEIR SH
BE. MORE PROGRAMS AND YOU KNOW
MORE FUNDING REBATE FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO THEM AND THAT- I
APPRECIATE THAT- THAT IS A
PRIORITY FOR YOU- IN MY NEXT
QUESTION WAS RELATED TO THE
URBAN GREENING PROGRAM WHICH IS
ALSO NOT INCLUDED- IN THIS
BUDGET OF YOU KNOW I THINK. THE
URBAN GREEN PROGRAM IT WAS A
PRIORITY FOR ME AND IT'S BEEN
PROVEN TO REDUCE HEAT. AND
MITIGATE URBAN HEAT ISLANDS OF
YOU KNOW LAST YEAR WAS THE
HOTTEST ON RECORD ESPECIALLY IN
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY WHICH
IS THE AREA THAT I REPRESENT.
OF THERE'S A LOT OF YOU KNOW I
THINK BY NOT INCLUDING URBAN
GREENING WERE NOT ACKNOWLEDGING
THE DANGER OF HEAT- THAT HE HAS
ON RESIDENTS IN OUR STATE.
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHERE LIVE
THAT LIVE IN COMMUNITIES WHERE
THEY MAY NOT HAVE AIR
CONDITIONING AT HOME AND I
THINK. SO I JUST WANTED TO HEAR
YOUR COMMENTS ON WHY THIS IS AN
INCLUDED THIS YEAR ESPECIALLY
AFTER THE EXTREME HEAT EVENTS
THAT WE HAD LAST SUMMER. I'S A
GREAT QUESTION AND I'M AYE DATS
AYE LIZZY OLD TO REJECT FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MAYBE
WEIGH IN ON THIS ONE. CERTAINLY
THANK YOU SECRETARY WITH TH-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT WE DO HAVE BEEN.
PHYSICAL CONSTRAINTS ON
AVAILABILITY I HAVE YOUR
ACTION. SEATS HOWEVER EACH YEAR
THE ADMINISTRATION SHOULD
REEVALUATE THE CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN. ATHLETE BILLS
SEEK ADDITIONAL. INFORMATION ON
AUCTION PROCEEDS. OKAY LOOK AT
WHAT I DO I THINK THAT WE NEED
TO RE CONSIDER THIS YOU KNOW
THERE'S LOTS OF ADVOCATES- THAT
ARE YOU KNOW CONTACTING US
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF-
INCLUDING THE URBAN GREEN
PROGRAM AND CONTINUING TO FUND
IT- AND YOU KNOW I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT- THAT MY
COMMENTS ARE HEARD AND THAT
KNOWING THAT THIS IS A PRIORITY
THANK YOU IT'S A SUPER BIG
PRIORITY TO ME AND WHEN I GO I
WAS JUST INTRANSITIVE ON FRIDAY
AND HAD THE SAME THING- SEVENTY
ISSUES ARE I KIND OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AT ISSUE THAT DOESN'T
GET THE ATTENTION THAT WHILE
CLOSE ALL SEA LEVEL RISE- BUT-
HE ISSUES- I HUGE AND- HAVE
BEEN CANOPY CAN REALLY BRING
DOWN- THAT TEMPERATURE
SIGNIFICANTLY SO. I WOULD LOVE
TO- WHAT WOULD EVEN THINK ABOUT
WAYS THAT WE CAN GET FUNDING G.
CARE ACT OTHERWISE TO MAKE TO
MAKE IT HAPPEN IS DEFINITELY
NOT FALLING ON DEAF EARS AND
IT'S A BIG EQUITY CAN STAND UP
FOR US. YEAH I AGREE IT DOESN'T
GET ENOUGH ATTENTION COMPARED
TO THE OTHER ISSUES THAT YOU
THAT YOU RAISED IN YOU KNOW I
WANT TO MAKE SURE TO CONTINUE
TO ADVOCATE- FOR PRE THESE
PROGRAMS YOU KNOW OF THERE ARE
MORE HEAT DEATHS IN OUR STATE
THEN ON COMPARED TO OTHER AREAS
OR TO OTHER- REASONS FOR DEATHS
AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT- ONLY BECAUSE IT'S
AFFECTING LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES THAT WE DON'T PUT
IT ASIDE AND SO IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME THAT LIKE YOU
SAID IT IS AN EQUITY ISSUE-
AND- IT'S DEFINITELY ONE OF MY
PRIORITIES. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN THANK YOU MR
SECRETARY IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU
THANKS FOR BEING HERE SO I'M-
VERY EXCITED- I WAS VERY
EXCITED TO HEAR GOVERNOR
NEWSOM'S EXECUTIVE ORDER ABOUT-
EV'S AND REALLY EXCITED TO-
WORKING ON. MAKING THAT A
REALITY HOWEVER EV'S ARE ONLY
PART OF THE EQUATION I BELIEVE
VERY STRONGLY THAT WE STILL
HAVE TO FOCUS ON REDUCING
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED. BECAUSE
OF COURSE CARS HAVE A HUGE
AMOUNT OF IMPACT ON LAND USE ON
HEAT ISLAND EFFECT ON THE
AMOUNT OF LAND THAT WE USE FOR
PARKING AND CONGESTION IN OUR
URBAN AREAS ON TRACK ON SAFETY
ON ON SO MANY THINGS ON
POLLUTION DIRECTLY OTHER FORMS
OF POLLUTION THAT ARE EMISSIONS
RELATED. SO WHAT THE L. A. O.'S
CLAIMED IN THE PAST THAT
THERE'S ALMOST A BILLION
DOLLARS IN CAP AND TRADE
SPENDING THAT THAT'S THERE TO
SUPPORT SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE
THE- SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
STRATEGY PROGRAM. HOWEVER WE'RE
STILL GOING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION IN CALIFORNIA IN
TERMS OF REDUCING VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED WITH EVEN MORE. MILES
BEING TRAVELED WITH. LESS AND
LESS YOU KNOW YOU DID NOT IS
NOT FOCUSED STILL ON TRANSIT
ALTERNATIVE MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION CERTAINLY LAND
USE. TO MAKE ALL THAT POSSIBLE.
ISN'T ALWAYS DONE WITH AN EYE
TOWARDS REDUCING VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED. A LOT OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE A CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED BUT I DON'T THINK
THAT THAT MEANS THAT WE NEED TO
WE CAN NEVER RECONSIDER. ANY OF
THOSE STRATEGIES SO YOUR ANY
THOUGHT GIVEN. AS TO HOW TO
MAKE BETTER INVESTMENTS THREE
THREE SEVENTY FIVE. TO REALLY.
FOSTER BETTER LAND USE- SO THAT
WE CAN MAKE TRANSIT MORE
FEASIBLE AND SO THAT WE- CAN
HELP PEOPLE REDUCE THEIR OWN
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED I KNOW
THAT'S A BIG QUESTION BUT I'M
WONDERING IF YOU'RE- GIVING ANY
THOUGHT TO THAT IS WERE. YOU
KNOW CONTINUING TO APPROPRIATE
MONEY UNDER THREE SEVENTY FIVE.
YEAH IT'S A HUGE IN REALLY
IMPORTANT POINT- AND SADLY ONE
THAT WE THINK ABOUT HOW. I'M IN
EVERY CONTEXT- AS IF YOU'VE
BEEN A LEADER IN CHAMPION N
EVERYTHING FROM. PORTABILITY OF
HOUSING BECAUSE THAT YOU KNOW
IF YOU HAVE TO. EVEN DURING
CALVET MANY ESSENTIAL WELCOME
TO TRAVEL HUNDREDS OF MILES TO
THAT JOB BECAUSE OF THE
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS AND THE
STATE. I'M ALSO T. APPLYING
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION AND THOSE
OPTIONS AND HOW THEY RECOVER
OUT OF THE PANDEMIC OR LAKE TO.
HOW WE THINK ABOUT I'M- MOVING
AROUND THE STATE AND DOING IT
LASTS AND SHORTENING THOSE
DISTANCES YOUR 100% RIGHT WEEK
WE CAN'T JUST FOCUS ON
TECHNOLOGY WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT THE BIG PICTURE IS A
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT POINT.
THANKS A WE'RE GONNA BE WORKING
ON THAT THIS YEAR AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO PARTNERING WITH YOU
ON TRYING TO FIND SOME OF THE
SOLUTIONS BUT I GUESS MY POINT
IN TERMS OF BUDGET IS THAT I DO
THINK WE NEED TO RE EVALUATE
SOME OF THE SPENDING AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE FOCUS SAID- BETTER
ON ON. PROJECTS THAT TRULY
REDUCE VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
THANKS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DID I CALL ALEJO. SORRY ABOUT
THAT OF HERE FROM LA OF. HOME
GOOD MORNING AGAIN ARE EXCUSE
ME GOOD AFTERNOON- KNOWLEDGE
EITHER IN PROGRESS NO PROBLEM
ROSS BROWN AT THE L. A. AGAIN-
I'M GONNA IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME KEEP MY COMMENTS ON THIS
ITEM VERY BRIEF IN JUST A FEW
MAIN POINTS ARE COMMENTS ON THE
OVERALL PACKAGE ONE JUST
RELATED TO WHICH PROGRAMS TO
FUND I WON'T REPEAT AND A LOT
OF THE COMMENTS THAT WOULD MAKE.
YOUR YEARS ABOUT. ISSUES TO
CONSIDER- WHEN OF THE TERM THE
PRIORITIES BUT ULTIMATELY HAVE
A LOT OF THESE DECISIONS DO
DEPEND ON LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES. ARE DEPENDING ON
HOW IT PRIORITIZES GREENHOUSE
GASES LOCAL AIR QUALITY
WILDFIRE SAFETY SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FOR
EXAMPLE AND SO- JUST IMPORTANT
TO KNOW THAT YOU KNOW THIS
PACKAGE REFLECTS THE GOVERNOR'S
PRIORITIES IN THE LEGISLATURE
AND ARGUE CANNON SHOULD. ADOPT
A PACKAGE THAT REFLECTS THE
PRIORITIES. I'M NOT FOCUSED MY
OTHER COMMENTS REALLY MORE ON
THE OVERALL STRUCTURE OF THE
PACKAGE INCLUDING THE AMOUNT
AND TIMING OF THE FUNDING. SO
WHEN IT COMES TO THE OVERALL
REVENUE AND SPENDING AMOUNTS IN
THE PACKAGE- WE DO THINK THE
BETTER- GOVERNOR'S REVENUE
ESTIMATES ARE REASONABLE. BUT
AS YOU KNOW THIS IS A VOLATILE
REVENUE SOURCE AND IT'S SUBJECT
TO SOME UNCERTAINTY- THE CHAIR
MENTIONED THAT THE FEBRUARY
AUCTION RESULTS DO SHOW THAT
REVENUES. ARE TRACKING SLIGHTLY
HIGHER THAN WHAT THE OF THE
BUDGET ASSUMES BUT WE WILL HAVE
MORE INFORMATION- AFTER THE MAY
AUCTION RESULTS ARE RELEASED AS
WELL. ONE IMPORTANT THING WE DO
WANT TO NOTICE THAT THE
PROPOSAL WOULD LEAVES ARE
SLIGHTLY MORE THAN A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS- AND AS SORT OF
A RESERVE IN THE FUND AFTER
BOTH THE CURRENT YEAR AND
BUDGET YEAR. WE DO THINK THIS
IS A RELATIVELY SMALL AMOUNT
IT'S ABOUT 5% OF ANNUAL
REVENUE. IS RELATIVELY SMALL
GIVEN- THE REVENUE UNCERTAINTY
AND SO WE THINK THAT OVER THE
LONG TERM- THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD CONSIDER OPTIONS FOR
PROMOTING. LONG TERM FUND
SOLVENCY AND FUNDING
PREDICTABILITY- ONE EXAMPLE
WOULD BE TO- CONSIDER JUST A
LARGER RESERVE- AND THERE'S NO
REAL MAGIC NUMBER AND KIND OF
WHAT THEY ARE THE BEST KIND OF
SIZE OF A- RESERVE WOULD BE.
BUT WE DO THINK A GOOD STARTING
POINT TO THINK ABOUT IS YOU
KNOW ROUGHLY 10% OR OR ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
OUR SERVERS DIRECTOR TO
MAINTAIN THAT SOLVENCY AND
PREDICTABILITY. THE FINAL POINT
IS- EARLY ACTION- THERE IS A
SIX HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS AS PART OF EARLY
ACTION. MY COLLEAGUES- MISTER
BROWN MENTIONED KIND OF OUR
OFFICES. OVERALL THOUGHTS ON
THIS WE THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE
A STRONG. FOR EARLY I WOULD GET
THE WHILE. PIECE THAT'S BEEN A
ONE ONE. P. SORT OF- THAT. BUT
A LOT OF THE OTHER AT. ARE ARE.
SPENDING PROPOSALS PART PACKAGE
DO NOT MESS. AND SO WE THINK.
OF THE LEGISLATURE SPOKEN
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF ACTION
FUNDING AND JUST FOCUS. ON A
WILDFIRE FOR A IS ONE OF. YOU
KNOW THERE ARE IF THERE ARE
SOME HIGH. PROGRAMS THE WHAT IS
THE DOES ONE TO ALLOCATE MONEY
IF YOU- A FEW MONTHS EARLIER-
THINKING ABOUT YOU KNOW HOW
MUCH MONEY IS ESSENTIALLY IN
THE BANK WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT HOW
MUCH MONEY WAS COLLECTED SO
FAR. AND THEY START POPULATION
SO FAR THAT'S ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND
MONEY AVAILABLE FOR
DISCRETIONARY SPENDING AND SO I
THINK IT KIND OF CONSIDERED YOU
KNOW- USING THAT AMOUNT- WHICH
WOULD BE SLIGHTLY LESS THAN
WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
ENOUGH IT DOES. HAVE SOME HIGH
PRIORITY ON A SPENDING THAT
WOULD LIKE TO ALLOCATE A FEW
MONTHS EARLIER SO I'LL IN MY
COMMENTS THEIR ANSWER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HI GUYS
THANK YOU IN A- TO THE
SECRETARY'S COMMENTS ON C.
EUROPEAN RESPONSE IN RESPONSE
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER REVISED AS
QUESTION. WE ALSO JUST WANTED
TO NOTE THAT WE APPROACH AND-
THE APPROACH TO INCREASING
SEVEN DOT. WE LOOK AT IT
HOLISTICALLY. AND
INFRASTRUCTURE REMAINS ONE OF
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS
TO SEVEN OPTION AND PROVIDES A
VERY HIGH RETURN. ON PUBLIC
INVESTMENT BECAUSE IT SUPPORTS
LONG TERM ASSETS THAT HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT USEFUL LIFE. AND E
LOOK FORWARD TO DISCUSSING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S THAT PACKAGE
WITH THE WITH A COUPLE OF WEEKS.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE
TO PUBLIC COMMENT- ARE THERE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO GET PUBLIC
COMMENT ALL RIGHT KEEP YOUR
DISTANCE PLEASE BUT PLEASE STEP
FORWARD FOR THE MICROPHONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON REFER CARE
NUMBER THREE COME UP WITH
ANOTHER WITH THE PROPER PUBLIC
LAND. TIME HERE AT THE READY TO
RESTORE FUNDING FOR THE URBAN
GREENING PROGRAM VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS THANK
YOU. URBAN GRANT PROGRAM IS
WANTED TO MAKE SURE BASED
CLIMATE SOLUTIONS PROGRAM IN
THE CAP AND TRADE UP THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO IMPACT LOW INCOME
PERFECT COMMUNITIES. HAVE THE
PRODUCTS THEY FONG POOL AND
MITIGATE FLOODING. THANKS TO
QUESTOR CARBON BUT THEY ALSO
CLEAN THE AIR WATER FILTER
WATER AND PROVIDE. BENEFITS TO
HUMAN HEALTH. YEAH- RECREATION.
CONTACT THE FRONT CAN BE. IN
YEARS. PARDON ME IN MONTHS NOT
YEAR LIKE OTHER- FEATURE ABOUT
THE- THANK GROW BUT IN MANY
ABOUT HEAT. HE MORE PEOPLE IN
THE HOUSE KILL MARC THAN ANY
WEATHER RELATED MATH AND HE'D
ARE INCOME. IS A PATH WAITING
TO HAPPEN THAT CAN BE PREVENTED
CHAIR YOU TALK ABOUT PREVENTION
EARLIER WITH REGARD TO
WILDFIRE- HE CAN BE PREVENTED
OR AT LEAST MITIGATED- BY
PROGRAMS LIKE URBAN GREENING.
AND WE'RE NOT FINDING IT AT ALL
AND IT WASN'T FUNDED LAST YEAR
SO WE'RE ASKING IT TO BE
RESTORED AT FIFTY MILLION FOR
TO MAKE UP FOR LAST YEAR'S
COUNT FOR LAST YEAR AND ALSO
THIS YEAR. AND LET'S HELP
PROTECT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES PERTH. SOMETHING WE
KNOW IS COMMON. THANK YOU. I
THANK THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
STEVEN MYERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS- SPEAKING ON
ISSUE FIVE WE APPRECIATE THAT
THIS IS ON WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IN THE PROPOSAL AND
THE PROPOSED WILDFIRE
INVESTMENT- BUT WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO ALSO INCLUDE THE
LOCAL CONSERVATION COURTS ON
THE WORK FORCE- THE FOURTEENTH
LOCAL PORTION OF SOME OF THE
MOST DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
IN THE STATE AND THERE ARE TWO
THOUSAND FOUR MEMBERS ARE READY
TO TAKE A SIGNIFICANT PIECE OF
THAT WORK. WE APPRECIATE THE
CHAIRS DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
SENATE COUNTERPART AND HOPE
THAT THOSE DISCUSSIONS RESULT
IN TIMELY APPROPRIATIONS FOR
SHOVEL READY PROJECTS IN EARLY
ACTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF
HUMBLE MENDOCINO REDWOOD COME
SORRY BUT THAT THAT WE ARE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
FIVE A WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS FOR
FOREST HEALTH AND WILDFIRE
PREVENTION- I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE LAST YEAR AS WITH
PRIOR YEARS LAST YEAR WE SAW
OVER FOUR MILLION ACRES
DESTROYED- WHAT OVER A HUNDRED
MILLION TONNES OF GHG EMISSIONS
WERE EMITTED E SPENT MORE THAN
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
FIREFIGHTING SUPPRESSION COST-
WE HAVE OVER TEN BILLION
DOLLARS AN INSURED LOSS THAT
NEED TO BE COVERED. SO IN
ADDITION TO THESE FUNDING
PROPOSALS OUR COMPANIES-
STRONGLY SUPPORTED DECISIONAL
POLICY CHANGES- THE
ADMINISTRATION DID TALK BRIEFLY
ABOUT DURING THE HEARING
PRESCRIBED FIRE PARTICULARLY ON
THE LIABILITY SIDE- BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO FIND WORK IN THE BIO
MASS AREA AND WE ADVOCATE
HAVING ONE PERSON IN CHARGE OF
GOING AFTER THOSE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PLUS ACRES THAT WE
NEED TO- HANDLE EACH AND EVERY
YEAR TO GET OUT OF THIS PROBLEM
SO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSE. THANK YOU. OPERATOR ARE
YOU READY TO. CONNEXXION FOLKS
TO US. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
YES WE ARE WE HAVE PEOPLE
QUEUED UP RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
COUNT OF SEVENTEEN PEOPLE
QUEUED UP TO MAKE WATER COMMENT
THAT ONE SEVERAS COMES FROM THE
LINE. SEVENTEEN THANK YOU. OUR
OUR OURFIRST COMMENTS WILL
COME FROM LINE TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
READ OUT AT SOME TO HALF OF
STATE THE REDWOODS LEAGUE AND
NATURE FOR ALL WE'RE HERE TO
SPEAK ON THE ISSUE FIVE RELATED
TO RESILIENCE CHORUS AND
LANDSCAPES. IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL ON EARLY ACTION. WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S THE IMPORTANT
POLICY DISCUSSION GOING ON IN
THE LEGISLATURE ABOUT THE
APPROPRIATENESS. OF THE
REGION'S AN ECOLOGY RELATED TO
THOSE REGIONS THAT FIRE WE
THINK THOSE BEEN DISCUSSIONS
ARE IMPORTANT BUT WE ALSO
BELIEVE IT IS. TOTALLY
APPROPRIATE TO MOVE FORWARD
QUICKLY NOW WHAT'S EARLY ACTION
ITEMS IN THE RESILIENT FOURTH
IN LANDSCAPE SPACE. IN ADDITION
AT THE CHAIR MENTIONED THERE'S
A DISCUSSION GOING ON IN THE
SENATE. ABOUT BUILDING OFF OF
IT POTENTIALLY IMPROVING SOME
OF WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION PUT
FORWARD. WE'RE EAGER TO HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION BOTH WITH THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE RELATED TO
THE CONCORD DISCUSSIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. NOW
GO. TO ONE THIRTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON NATALIE MAX ON BEHALF
OF THE PRESIDENT BY REGIONAL
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT AND
COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION- I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR EARLY ACTION WILD
FIRE INVESTMENT WE NEED NEED TO
ENSURE THAT CRITICAL PROJECTS
GET DONE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE IN
ORDER TO PREPARE FOR THE NEXT
WILDFIRE SEASON. THANK YOU. NOW
GO TO LINE THIRTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR ABOUT ROBINSON
WE SHUDDER EDUCATIONAL TURN
LACK ON THE TOP OF THE OFFICE
CATERPILLAR BUT WE JUST WANT TO
CONVEY OUR SUPPORT MORE THAN
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS PROPOSED
TO BE FUNDED FROM CAP AND TRADE
FOR THE HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM.
AS WELL AS THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT BOB FROM FORM
THE CLIMATE COUNTY WAS FOUND TO
BE I THINK THAT WOULD SUPPORT
MORE SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURAL.
ACTIVITIES THANK YOU ADULT
THOSE ITEMS ON MOBILE ALL THE
WAY THE. LINE. TWENTY NINE. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRENDAN
TELLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
GIVEN THE ENORMOUS CHALLENGES
CALIFORNIANS FACING TO MEET
HEALTH BASED AIR QUALITY
ATTAINMENT STANDARDS AND IN
REDUCING AIR POLLUTION IN
TOXICS AND DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED COMMUNITIES WE
APPRECIATE THE AIR QUALITY AND
PUBLIC HEALTH THAT PRIORITIZE
FOR FUNDING IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET. I WE SUPPORT
THE EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION
PROGRAM FUNDING WITH A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN EARLY ACTION FUNDING IN A
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE MILLION IN
THE BUDGET YEAR FOR INCENTIVES
TO CLEAN UP POLLUTION IN
COMMUNITIES AND WE APPRECIATE
THERE'S FIFTY MILLION IN
FUNDING FOR A. B. SIX SEVENTEEN
IMPLEMENTATION BUT HOWEVER WE
MUST NOTE THIS AMOUNT DOES NOT
COVER CURRENT COSTS FOR ACCOUNT
FOR ADDITIONAL COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN ADDED TO THE PROGRAM.
FURTHER WE SUPPORT THE
PRIORITIZATION OF THE FARMER
PROGRAM WITH NINETY MILLION IN
INCENTIVES FOR EARLY ACTION AN
EIGHTY MILLION IN THE BUDGET
YEAR AND WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
TWO MILLION FOR CONTINUING THE
SB TWELVE SIXTY MANDATED LOCAL
AIR DISTRICT PRESCRIBED FIRE
PROGRAM WHICH EXPANDS
PRESCRIBED FIRE BURN PERMITTING
AIR QUALITY MONITORING PUBLIC
OUTRAGE AND OTHER RELATED WORK
MEAN KERR G. TO INCREASE
FUNDING SO WE CAN DO MORE AND
FINALLY WE ASK YOU TO CONSIDER
INCLUDING FUNDING FOR THE NEW
INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO ESTABLISH
CLEAN AIR CENTERS WHICH
PROVIDES SAFE REFUGE DURING
WILDFIRE SMOKE. ADVANCE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE. NINE
CREEK ROAD ON BEHALF OF HELP
FOR IT THE CALIFORNIA FORESTRY
ASSOCIATION- WE ARE BOTH THE
COURTS OF THE FUNDING BE
CLIMATE RESILIENCY PACKAGE AND
THE CATALYST FUNDS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PUT FORWARD
PLEASE NOTE INFRASTRUCTURE
BUILD BIO ENERGY IT REALLY MUST
BE FUNDED PILE BURNING IS NOT A
SMART ALTERNATIVE TO MELT PILE
BURNING IS NOT MARKED
ALTERNATIVE TO BIOENERGY WE
REALLY HAVE TO HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN WITHOUT IT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO TURN THE
CORNER ON WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
RIGHT NOW THE SHEER VOLUME OF
WORK THAT WE HAVE ON THE GROUND
WE WOULD NEED TO BRING INCREASE
IN. CALIFORNIA DON'T DIRECTLY
INVEST IN WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BASED AND EFFICIENT TO THE
GREAT ECOLOGICAL BENEFIT THIS
WILL HAVE A REAL AND POSITIVE
IMPACT ON CALIFORNIA'S OVERALL
ECONOMY ON PERMIT EFFICIENCIES
PLEASE SEE THAT THAT THE
PRIORITY IS TREMENDOUSLY
IMPORTANT WE'RE ESPECIALLY
INTERESTED IN EFFORTS TO ALLOW
FOR SYNCHRONICITY IN PERMITTING
AND LASTLY WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE CLIMATE CATALYST FUNDS WE
REALLY NEED ACCESS TO CAPITAL
COMMERCIAL LOANS ARE NOT
AVAILABLE TO US WITHOUT LONG
TERM SUPPLY AND MARKET
CONTRACTS IN PLACE SO THE
PROMISE OF LOW INTEREST LOANS
VIA THE CRIME A CATALYST FUND
IS SOMETHING THAT E REALLY
TRULY NEED. FOR THESE REASONS
WE ASK THE COMMITTEES FAVORABLE
CONSIDERATION FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE PACKAGE INCLUDING
THE CAPITAL. FUND THANK YOU
THANK YOU. BY TWENTY EIGHT. BUT
AFTER MR CHAIRING THIS IS NO
CRAMER WITH WHITE INSTITUTE AND
I'M HERE TODAY TO SPEAK SUPPORT
OF ISSUE FIVE THE WILD COURSE
RESILIENCE STRATEGY. WE ARE
STRONGLY SUPPORTED THE- AND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AND URGE THE ADOPTION
OF THE EARLY ACTION PLANS.
CALIFORNIAN WINERIES AND
VINEYARDS ARE EXPECTED TO SEE A
LOSS OF THREE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE TWENTY
TWENTY WILDFIRES. AND THE
TWENTY TWENTY GREAT CRUSH
DECLINED BY NEARLY 14% AND
THAT'S DUE PRIMARILY TO SMOKE
EXPOSURE TO GREAT THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. SH AND OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED SIGNIFICANTLY BY
WILDFIRES IN RECENT YEARS AND
MUCH ACTION IS NEEDED TO HELP
ON IMPROVE THE RESILIENCE OF
THE FOREST IN THE LAND AROUND
AND- WINERIES AND VINEYARDS.
ONE EXAMPLE- ON PROJECTS THAT
WOULD BENEFIT FROM EARLY ACTION
NAPA COUNTY HAS SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF. FUEL BREAKS
AND THAT IS DONE THIS YEAR AND
HAVE A MUCH STREAMLINED.
PERMITTING PROCESS TO GET THOSE
ON THE GROUND SO EARLY FUNDING
WILL HELP SPECIFICALLY NAPA
COUNTY AND PROTECT ITS CITIZENS
AND COMMUNITIES IN THE FUTURE.
SO WE URGE THE ADOPTION AND
INCLUSION OF EARLY ACTION IN
THE FUNDING AS WELL AS THE
INCREASED FUNDING FOR WILDFIRE
ON PREVENTION COURSE RESILIENCE
GOING FORWARD THANK YOU. BY.
THIRTY TWO. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS MARK STIVERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP-
BEGAN BEHALF OF A COALITION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ORGANIZATION DIFFICULT
OF CONTINUING FUNDING FOR THE
LOW INCOME WEATHERIZATION
PROGRAM AT THE PROGRAM UNLOCK
THE BENEFITS OF ENERGY AND
SOLAR UPGRADES FOR BOTH
RESIDENTS AND OWNERS OF
MULTIFAMILY LOW INCOME HOUSING
INCLUDING FARMERS THE
PROPERTIES AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITY. OF THIS PROGRAM
MEETS THREE GONNA HE STATED
OBJECTIVES REQUIRED IN ONE OF
THE DEFENSE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS TO IT IT SUPPORTS THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND THREE IT PORTS
EQUITY WITHIN THEIR VERY FEW
PROGRAMS THAT THAT MAKE THIS
THREE FOR AND BUT THE BENEFITS
AND WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY DEVELOPMENTS ON A
WAITING. LIST SPEAKING FUNDING
WE- ORGANISERS. FUNDING THE
PAST WE THINK SHOULD BE A- HIGH
PRIORITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
INTO SUPPORT THANK YOU MUCH. BY.
FIFTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN BIRTH TAYLOR OCEAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
CONCERN ON ISSUE NUMBER SIX BUT
WE DON'T OPPOSE THE MODEL OF
THAT THE CALIFORNIA ON ITS FACE
I'M PARTICULARLY FOR SMALL
DAIRY AND LIVESTOCK SECTORS
MANY OF THESE MEN ARE
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES ARE NOT
REVENUE GENERATING AND WE WOULD
HAVE MEANT THAT A LOAN LOW
INTEREST OR NOT. AND MAY NOT BE
FUNCTIONAL WITHOUT A RETURN ON
INVESTMENT FOR ADDITIONAL
INCENTIVES EVER WE ASK THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO CONSIDER RE
APPROPRIATING THESE PROGRAMS
UNDER THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND OR SOME OTHER
FUND DOORS I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
AGRICULTURAL EXPENDITURE IN THE
CAP AND. TRADE ON ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN THANK YOU. BY. FORTY
EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS JULIE
MALACHOWSKI BALL THAT THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION
SPEAKING TO ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN-
CAL ICHIKI REPORTS THE
GOVERNOR'S SIERRA THE PROPOSAL
JIM BACK FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FIVE MILLION OF CAP AND TRADE
FUNDS TO EXPAND ACCESSIBILITY
TO ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES SUCH
AS THE CENTRAL INVESTMENTS
REPRESENT THOUGH THE ABSOLUTE
MINIMUM FUNDING REQUIRED. SCOPE
SCALE OF TRANSPORT FOR ME IN
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR ONE
ZERO EMISSION AND THE
OPPORTUNITY THIS TRANSFORMATION
PROVIDES FOR THE ENVIRONMENT
JOBS IN THE ECONOMY IS BEING.
OUT WE DO ASK HOWEVER THAT HE-
THAT WE RESTORE THE FUNDING FOR
LIGHT DUTY IN THAT INVESTMENT
COULD BE THE ACTUAL PROGRAM TO
IT TWO HUNDRED MILLION BASELINE
CALIFORNIA IS CURRENTLY FALLING
BEHIND ITS ORIGINAL AMBITIOUS
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION GOAL BUT
FIVE MILLION THAT BY TWENTY
THIRTY A 100% NEW CAR SALES BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE IN A
PANDEMIC IS ONLY AMPLIFIED THAT
CHALLENGE IN MEETING WITH GOAL-
DO WE- AT THAT. BE RIVAS AND
I'M WE'LL TO. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WHY FIFTY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MICHAEL
PIMENTEL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING EIGHTY
FIVE TRANSIT AGENCIES ACROSS
OUR STATE I'VE ALWAYS SPENT
MUCH OF THE LAST YEAR ON
PANDEMIC RESPONSE AND FOCUSED
ON MATTERS LIKE EMERGENCY
FUNDING FOR CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
AGENCY AND WHAT WE BELIEVE THAT
THE MORAL IMPERATIVE OF VACCINE
ACCESS FOR FRONT LINE WORKERS
WEREALSO LASER FOCUSED ON
SUPPORTING OUR AGENCIES AS THEY
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES AS REQUIRED BY A
OR B. THE INNOVATIVE CLEAN
TRANSIT REGULATION. TODAY I AM
PLEASED TO BOYS COLON
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT FOR THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS BUSES AND
OFF ROAD FREIGHT THAT LINE ITEM
DIRECTLY SUPPORTS PROGRAMS LIKE
A. R. P. H. BETH WHICH BUYS
DOWN THE INCREMENTAL COSTS OF
YOUR MISSION TECHNOLOGY NOW YOU
CONTINUE CONSIDER THIS
INVESTMENT WE URGE YOU TO
CREATE A CREDIT CARD WITH IN
THAT LINE ITEM OF AT LEAST
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
DEPLOYMENT OF ZERO EMISSION
BUSES BY TRANSIT AGENCIES
SPECIFICALLY. AIRBNB A TRIP
PROGRAM IS FIRST COME FIRST
SERVE AND WHILE THAT'S GREAT
FOR GETTING DOLLARS OUT THE
DOOR IT MEANS THAT AGENCIES
TRANSIT AGENCIES OFTEN HAVE
LONG PROCUREMENT CYCLES ARE AT
A DISADVANTAGE WILL COMPETING
FOR THOSE DOLLARS THE SENATE
SIDE WOULD GET AT THAT BY
PROVIDING A MINIMUM LEVEL OF
INVESTMENT FOR TRANSIT AGENCIES
AND THE DEPLOYMENT OF ZERO
EMISSION BUSES THANKS. FOR YOUR
TIME FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANKS. BY. EIGHT THANK YOU
SURE NUMBER THINK YOU HAVE TO
TELL BY TELL WITHIN TO RETURN
DEFENSE COUNCIL ON ISSUES THE
CABINETRY PLAN WE COULD FORTY
MINISTRATIONS REQUEST FOR THREE
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
TRANSITION TO CLEAN TRUCKS
BUSES AND OFF ROAD EQUIPMENT
RECOGNIZING THAT THE DEPLETION
OF THE SIGNIFICANT THREAT TO
PUBLIC HEALTH AIR QUALITY
PARTICULARLY- MOST
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR REQUEST FOR CLEAN CARTS
FOR ALL IN OTHER TRANSPORTATION
EQUITY PROJECT WHEN SURE THAT
ALL CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME DRIVERS
HAVE ACCESS YOU CAN BENEFIT
FROM THE DEEP CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENT. WE
SUPPORT THE THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL FOR CDFA IS
INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL HEALTHY
SOIL PROGRAM WHICH NOT ONLY
INCENTIVIZE THE PRACTICES THAT
IMPROVE SOIL HEALTH THE CLUSTER
CARBON AND REDUCE GHG BUT ALSO
SUPPORT THE ECONOMIC VITALITY
OF CALIFORNIA FARMERS INCLUDING
SMALL AND THAT CALPERS AND
RANCHERS AS WELL AS FARMERS OF
COLOR FINALLY I'M GOING TO COME
AT THE MARKET BY BIRTH WHICH
SPEECH BC EARLIER THE REQUESTED
INCLUSION AT THE AT THE LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM
AND THE FINAL EXPENDITURE PLAN
WHICH IS THE ONLY PROGRAM OF
ITS KIND IN CALIFORNIA THAT
FOCUSES EXCLUSIVELY ON SERVING
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. THE
COLOR AND ENERGY EFFICIENCY
UPGRADES THAT REDUCE EMISSIONS
A BANERJEE AND IMPORTANTLY SAVE
PEOPLE MONEY ON THEIR ENERGY
BILLS THANKS MUCH. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAP THE FACT
THAT. THANK YOU. WHY FIFTY.
THANK MISTER CHAIRMAN THE
NUMBER ARE FREE TO IS ABOUT
ABOUT GIRL OF THE CAN WE ARE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE THE
PUBLIC COMMENT MORNING THERE'S
A LOT SUPPORT ON AND
SPECIFICALLY WE WANT TO SPEAK
TO ISSUE FIVE THE WILDFIRE
IMPORTS RESILIENCE. ARE THE
MAJOR CONCERN STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THE GOVERNOR'S THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
EARLY ACTION APPROPRIATION FOR
WILDFIRE RESILIENCE THERE ARE
SHOVEL READY PROJECTS CRITICAL
TO ADDRESSING THE THREAT OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE HOWEVER
MANY OF THESE PROJECTS THAT
IDOL TO BE WAITING FOR FUNDING
TO IMPLEMENT THEM THE PRIMARY
REASON FOR DOING THAT IS THE
TINY BIT SOONER WE CAN ALLOCATE
THE GOAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SPENDING THE MORE
LIKELY THESE PROJECTS CAN BE
COMPLETED IN ADVANCE OF THE
UPCOMING FIRE SEASON. ALSO TNC
SUPPORT OF ISSUE THANKS THE
CLIMATE CATALYST FUND- THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING A MORE
FOCUSED PAN CLIMATE CATALYST
FUNDS WE GOT INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS AN AGRICULTURAL SECTOR
AND TO INCREASE FIRE PREVENTION
ACROSS THE STATE THIS FUNDING
IS CRITICAL TO REGIONAL
ECONOMIC RECOVERY IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS FUTURE
CLIMATE RESILIENCE- WITH REGARD
TO WILDFIRE FINALLY IT READ
ISSUE NUMBER THANK THE PROPOSED
HAPPEN TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN
HE APPEARED IN COURT THE
PROPOSAL MANAGER IN APPRECIATE
NUMEROUS ASPECTS OF THE PLAN
INCLUDING FUNDING PROTECT
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
HEALTHY SOIL OF INVESTMENT. AND
SB NINE A ONE FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES WE DO AGREE WITH THE
STAFF COMMENTS AS WELL AS
COMMENTS MADE BY THE WOMAN
RIVAS AND OUR COLLEAGUE RICK
BILL WITH THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC
LAND I BELIEVE THAT THE CAP AND
TRADE FUNDING IS WARRANTED
BURBANK GREETING AND OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE PREVIOUSLY
BEEN FUNDED I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ONGOING DISCUSSION
THANK YOU. THANKS BYE THIRTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND GET
A BETTER OF A VENN YOUR
ADVOCACY WITH AMERICA LUNG
ASSOC ACCORDING TO ISSUE OF THE
HONESTY. CALIFORNIA TO FACE HIM
BOB AIR CUSHION AND WE GET THE
BETTER POSSIBLE RECALL BETWEEN
THE PROVIDE A AIR QUALITY THE
START OF NEXT TO ALLOCATE YOU
JERICHO DISPARITIES YOU'RE
EMISSION VEHICLE PROGRAM
BECAUSE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION HEAVY DUTY THERE ARE
TRUCKS BUSES AND OFFERED AND
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE DIGITAL
TRANSPORTATION WITH PEOPLE.
SHOULD THE POLICE ACTION- OF
THE TEACHER. AND EVERYTHING
FROM THE FINANCING. WHAT OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE OCCUPATION YOUR-
OF THE EIGHTY EIGHT AIR PROGRAM.
OF THAT'S ONE DOLLARS EACH
EXTRACTION HELLO WITH A CASE
ACROSS OF AB AND A LOOK
PRACTICE ASIAN. INVESTMENT THAT
THE STRUCTURE OF THE POWER FOR
OUR MISSION THANK YOUNG. IT
SHOULD AT THE END OF YOUR
MICHIGAN. AND OFFICIAL COULD BE
IN THE STATE PUBLIC. CLINICS
ACROSS THE STATE. OF THE ARCH.
AND THE PRIORITY SUPPORT FOR
EACH SIX IN. EIGHTY EIGHT YOU
PROGRAMS THANK YOU VERY HIGH.
GOING TO MOVE ON TO LINE SIXTY
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS FULL
OF CRAP IN THE SOUTH BECAUSE H.
U. N. G. WE APPRECIATE THE
BILLION DOLLARS EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN. FUND FOR AIR
DISTRICTS THE GOVERNOR'S.
HOWEVER WE SEE A HIGHER LEVEL
FUNDING AND WITH ACTUAL KA-
COMMITTEE ARE ADDED TO THIS
PROGRAM EACH REQUIRING. AND
SUSTAINED RESOURCE THIS FUNDING
IS CRITICAL PROTECT COMMUNITY
WE ALSO APPRECIATE TO OUR TO
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN AB
SEVENTEEN FUNDING FOR A
DISTRICTS AND GOVERNOR'S BY AND
IT'S FUNDING WITH TOTALLY MISS
LAST YEAR. ADDITIONAL FUNDING
IS NEED TO EXCEL THE PLAN OF
TECH. THIS IS CRITICAL GIVEN
FIVE THAT THE EXPOSURE CARE TO
WITH LIKE BEING CREASED AND
NEGATIVE HEALTH. SOUTH BECAUSE
THIS SINGLE FED DEADLINE TO
REDUCE AIR POLLUTION AND NOT
MET WILLIAMS OF DOLLARS AND
THANKS RISK ON AND A PENALTY
COULD. BY SOUTH COAST SUPPORT
OF A THE GOVERNOR'S FOR TO
EXPAND SOURCES OF AIR QUALITY
PREVIOUSLY WE AUTHORIZED BY
EIGHTY EIGHT EXPRESSION AFTER
THE OF THE CAR WHERE PER. AND
MY ATTACKER CORRECT BILLING THE
WHERE THANK YOU. YOU'RE CALLING
IN SUPPORT. OF EIGHTY SEVEN-
NAMELY THE AG DIESEL ENGINE
REPLACEMENT FUND. THE NINETY
MILLION FOR EARLY ACTION IN THE
EIGHTY MILLION PER FISCAL YEAR.
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
INTENTION OF THE EIGHTY EIGHT
FUNDS. WHICH WILL BE OFF RIGHT
AND YOU CAN CALL WHERE. ARE
THESE PROGRAMS COLLECTIVELY.
HUGELY SUCCESSFUL SPECIALLY.
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. REPUBLICANS
AND PROVIDING FOR CLEANER AIR-
TO ALL HELLO. ALLEY WE ASK YOUR
SUPPORT YOU SHOULD BROUGH THANK
YOU HAVE A GOOD DAY. LINE.
THREE GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS DILLON JACK HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING ASSOCIATION MY COMMENT
IS ON ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN WE
SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION GDR
PROPOSAL AND THE OPPOSITE THAT
EQUITY WE WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
THE CONCERN THAT THE PROPOSAL
DOES FALL SHORT OF DIRECTING TV
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING TO
INVEST IN THE LOW INCOME OR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
WORK ACTUALLY BENEFIT FROM THE
PROGRAM. ADDITIONALLY WE WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE GDR AFTER
EARLY ACTION FOR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION IS ESSENTIAL TO
MEETING OUR DEPLOYMENT FOR THIS
PROPOSAL PLAYED THE CRITICAL
ROLE IN JUMP STARTING THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
MARKET AND WILL REMAIN CRITICAL
TO HELPING INDUSTRY ACHIEVE THE
ECONOMIES OF SCALE NEEDED TO
NEEDED TO MAKE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE MORE AFFORDABLE
AND ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING.
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU. PINE.
SIXTY GOOD AFTERNOON CARING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S ALAN ABSENT WITH THE BAY
AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT I'D LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
CAPCO- IN FROM THE SOUTH COAST
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
WITH SUPPORT FOR A BI SIX
SEVENTEEN INCENTIVES IN THE-
ITEM SEVEN THE G. CARE ACT
BUDGET THAT THE EARLY ACTION-
MEASURES OF ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION AND THE FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY TWO
AMOUNT OF ONE HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION I'D ASO LIKE TO ECHO
THEIR COMMENTS ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING OF FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS SUPPORT FOR
THAT BUT ALSO KNOWLEDGE MEANT
THAT THE FUNDING AVAILABLE DOES
NOT REFLECT THE TRUE COST OF.
RUNNING THE PROGRAM AND WE HOPE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WILL
CONSIDER MOVING THAT AMOUNT UP
IN IN THE FUTURE BUDGET ALSO
SUPPORT FOR THE GREEN CARD FOR
ALL EQUITY PROGRAMS WHICH ARE
CURRENTLY OVER SUBSCRIBED IN
THE BAY AREA AND- WOULD LIKE
THE LEGISLATURE TO ALSO
CONSIDER FUNDING OF THE CLEAN
AIR CENTER PROGRAM NUMBER
EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX WHICH
HAD FUNDING IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET BUT WAS NOT. FUNDED IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WHY. TWENTY SIX.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GANDER ENTRY ON BEHALF OF
ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY OUR
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
ADVANCED ENERGY BUSINESSES OF
WHICH FOR THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY AND WE'RE HERE TO
SUPPORT- STRONG FOCUS ON CLEAN
THE STRUCTURE AND JOBS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET. AB
AND TRADE AND THE BEST PLAN AT
THE JUVENTUS TODAY. WAS FOR
BARCA FROM AND- THE UK. CLOSE
IMAGE. GAP WE SUPPORT FOCUSING
BEACH ZERO FUNDS IMPROVING
ACCESS TO EQUITABLE. MOBILITY
OPTIONS AND ACCELERATING
TURNOVER THE MOST POLLUTING
MEDIUM AND. HEAVY DUTY FLEETS.
WE RESPECTFULLY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONTINUED SUPPORT
FUNDING FOR LAW DUTY STAND. FOR
LOWER MODEL INCOME. POLICE OUR
OWN A CLEARER VEHICLE OF THEIR
OWN. IMPORTANT TO STAY PENSION
OF THESE REBATES. NEW MODELS
EMERGE SO THE CONSUMERS IN THE
MARKET. FOR A NEW VEHICLE ARE.
ABLE TO AFFORD A GAS MASK.
ECCLESIOLOGICAL TO TAKE SWIFT
ACTION ON CROPPING TO YOUR
BUDGET FOR THE CURRENT FISCAL.
WHICH WILL MEAN REINSTATE AND
BRING CONTINUITY AND CERTAINTY
BACK CORE PROGRAMS. THIS OF
IMMEDIATE ACTION DIDN'T. WHAT
WE NEED IN THE STATE FINALLY WE
ENCOURAGE ALLEGE THAT DETECTS
ACTION ON ADOPT A JUDGE BUT TO
GROW JOBS. SPORTFISHING
COSTUMES SPUR SUPPLY CHAIN
DEVELOPMENT IN VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES ISSUED THE POPULAR
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE THE PUBLIC COMMENT AND
COMMEND YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
YOUR COLLEAGUES FOR. WORKING
YOUR WAY THROUGH. A VERY LONG
AND FOLGENDEM. THANK YOU. BYE
BY. SIXTY SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON
TERRIBLE IN THE SPEAKING WITH
LAURA COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA AND SPEAKING ON BOTH
ITEMS FIVE AND SEVEN
CONSPIRATORIALLY INTER RELATED-
R. C. R. C. REPRESENTS THIRTY
SEVEN WORLD COUNTY STATEWIDE-
OBVIOUSLY MOST OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE FORCED TO
COMMUNITIES SO WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND FOREST
MANAGEMENT IS VERY VITAL TO BE
AT PUBLIC SAFETY AND HEALTH OF
OUR COMMUNITIES WE ARE VERY
MUCH SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS ON BOTH OF
THESE ITEMS AND I WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF GETTING AS MUCH
MONEY ON THE GROUND FOR FOREST
HEALTH WILDFIRE PREVENTION AS
POSSIBLE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
ABOUT THE COMMITMENTS TO SB
NINE A ONE FUNDING THROUGH THE
G. ARE ASKED WE BELIEVE IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO MAINTAIN
THESE COMMITMENTS IN THE GT R.
S. AND WHILE WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF OTHER PROPOSALS
THAT PUT MORE MONEY ON THE
GROUND WE DO BELIEVE IT IS ALSO
IMPORTANT TO MAINTAIN THE SB.
NINE A ONE MINUTE THANK YOU.
I'M FIFTY SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ELIZABETH
SHORT HERE ON BEHALF OF CAL
START A NONPROFIT TECHNOLOGY
CONSORTIUM WITH OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY MEMBERS
DEDICATED TO THE GROWTH OF THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION INDUSTRY
SPEAKING ON ISSUES SEVEN WE
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR
GOVERNOR NEWTON'S PROPOSED
BUDGET WHICH INVESTS ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
IMMEDIATE FUNDING FOR THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR INCLUDING
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
IN EARLY ACTION FUNDING FOR
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY OFF ROAD
AND EQUITY PROGRAM. WE ARE
ESPECIALLY CONCERNED WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ACTING ON THE EARLY
ACTION BUDGET TO APPROPRIATE
GIGI R. F. FUND FOR THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR CONSIDERING LAST
YEAR'S FUNDS WERE NOT
APPROPRIATED MOST CLEAN VEHICLE
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN WITHOUT
FUNDING FOR OVER EIGHTEEN
MONTHS AND OTHERS HAVE RUN
THROUGH THEIR ONE TIME FUNDING
AND ARE IN NEED OF
APPROPRIATIONS TO CONTINUE
OPERATING EFFECTIVELY WELL WE
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE PROPOSED
BUDGET WE URGE THAT CD R. P. BE
RESTORED AND THAT IS A CRITICAL
PROGRAMS THAT INCREASE OF
MEDIUM AND LOW INCOME FAMILIES
AND PLEATS ACCESSIBILITY TO THE
OUR MISSION VEHICLES. THANK YOU
FOR TIME. THANKS FOR YOUR
COMMENTS PINE. FORTY TWO. GOOD
MORNING BIG BLUE AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TIM EDWARD
PRESIDENT OF CAL FIRE LOCAL
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY ONE
REPRESENTING YOUR STATE
FIREFIGHTER JEREMY BLOOM YOU
MAY RECALL ABOUT THREE YEARS
AGO HE CAME TO SPEAK AT OUR
ANNUAL CONFERENCE. AT THAT TIME
WE STRESS THE NEED TO BUILD
SCALFARI FIREFIGHTING FORCES
HERE WE ARE THREE YEARS LATER
IN THE PART IN THAT INCREASES
THE KALIFORNIA BEING
INSIGNIFICANT ARE YOU KNOW ONE
OF THE BIGGEST ISSUES WITH- THE
AIR QUALITY TODAY WILDLAND FIRE
THE CATASTROPHIC FIRES. BURNING
OVER TWO THOUSAND PLUS HOME BUT
DR CHEMICALS INTO THE AIR THE
MOST EFFICIENT WAY GIVE PROJECT
GREENHOUSE GASES WITH THE JUMP.
ON HE FIRED IMMEDIATELY. NOW
ARE GOING INTO TWO TWENTY ONE
WITH LED BY. WE LAST. WE ARE
OUT THE ENACTED. GET THE GETS
BOARD THE SENATE COMMITTEE. IN
BOTH THE FIRE BY FOR THE- IT
TOOK MANY YEARS FOR ARE FORCED
TO GET THE WAY THEY ARE IN CAN
TAKE MANY YEARS FOR THEM TO GET
BETTER BUT IN THE MEANTIME
WE'RE STILL GONNA HAVE
CATASTROPHIC FIRES. WE ARE
ASKING THAT YOU REVISIT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TWENTY
TWENTY. FOR THE FIVE HUNDRED
FORTY THREE ADDITIONAL STAFF.
IN ON TOP OF THAT THE TWENTY
ONE HERE INCREASE DESPERATELY
NEEDED WE HAD LAST YEAR. ARE
YOU KNOW JEREMY BLOOM MY FIRST
FIRE WOULD NINETY THREE M. OUT.
THIRTY CALIFORNIA'S RAINY HAS
BEEN VERY MINIMAL THIS YEAR. I
AM EXPECTING BETTER CALIFORNIA
BEING SPRING CONDITIONS AGAIN
THIS YEAR. AND UNFORTUNATELY
CALIFORNIA NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES PROPRIA. PLEASE TAKE
THE TIME TO GET WITH THE SENATE
I THREATEN YOU FOR FIREFIGHTING
FORTY ON TOP OF THE NEED FOR
PREVENTION. AND MANAGEMENT THEY
ALL COME IN HERE. ARE BARBER
ONE CRUISE ACT 73% OF THEIR
TIME IN FIELD MANAGEMENT. WHILE
BEING ABLE TO RESPOND TO FIRE
THEY ARE THE MOST VERSATILE
FIREFIGHTING FORCE IN THE
WORLD. AND CAN DO THE JOB THAT
YOU'RE ASKING THEM TO DO. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. BY. SIXTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON- BLOEMEN MEMBERS OF
THE ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT I AM
GOING TO COMMENT ON ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN THE CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN. WE LIKE TO
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION
FURTHER FOCUS ON EQUITY IN
TERMS OF THESE EXPENDITURES
GIVEN THAT THE VALUE COME TO
TWENTY OF THE THIRTY MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
THE STATE. WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE FINDING THAT. HAD BEEN
INCLUDED FOR THE FARMER
PROGRAM- THAT IS A PROGRAM THAT
IS- CONTINUALLY OVERSUBSCRIBED
WITH SIGNIFICANT MATCH
INVESTMENT FROM THE ACTION
UNITY THAT COULD QUICKLY
PROVIDE TREMENDOUS ECONOMIC
STIMULUS AND PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS. WE ARE ALSO VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE FUNDING FOR
THE COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION
PROGRAM WE WOULD SIMPLY ASK
THAT WITH ADDITIONAL
COMMUNITIES CONTINUALLY
ENSURING THAT PROGRAM AND
ASSOCIATE BECAUSE CONTINUING TO
INCREASE. OUR THAT WE PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT ADDITIONAL FUNDING I
WOULD. ALSO LIKE TO AND- BUT
YOU KNOW OUR- THAT MILLION FOR
SO. AS WELL AS FUNDING FOR THE
GREEN CARD FOR UP AND OTHER A
PER. AND WHILE NOT ON TODAY'S.
WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
RE AUTHORIZATION OF THE EIGHTY
EIGHT PROGRAMS THAT ARE VERY
CRITICAL PROGRAMS TO HELP US
MEET OUR AIR QUALITY COOL IN
THE DISTRICT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. NINE SIXTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NUMBER
EIGHT CALMLY WITH THE L. A.
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ON
ISSUES SEVEN WE OPPOSED THE
ELIMINATION OF THE BE
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM FROM THE
CAP AND TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN-
THE PROGRAM FUND DEVELOPMENT
AND INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IT SHE
MAJOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC. AND BENEFITS THAT ARE
MOST DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
WE WOULD URGE THAT THE
COMMITTEE TO RESTORE THE
ELIMINATION THANK YOU. LINE.
SIXTY EIGHT. AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
PLAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- THIS IS NOT POPPING
TINA CALIFORNIA BITERS CALLING
ON BEHALF TWO CLIENTS- FIRST
BEHALF OF FLOOD. ISSUE FIVE
WE'D LIKE TO STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE EARLY ACTION BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR WILDFIRE AND
FOREST RESILIENCE FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE PROJECTS
SHOVEL READY PROJECTS READY TO
GET GOING NOW AND- THIS YEAR WE
CAN GET GOING ON THAT THAT
BETTER LIKE WE HAD WE HAVE A
YOU KNOW PREVENTING FIRES BUT
ALSO JUST PREVENTING FIRES FROM
BECOMING THE CATASTROPHIC
CATASTROPHIC FIRES- THAT THAT
WE FEAR- AND THEN ALSO PERSON I
DON'T ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN. WE
ARE OVERALL VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S CAPITATE
PROPOSAL HOWEVER WE DO URGE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR YOUR
MACHINE VEHICLES BE INCLUDED-
THE CRP PROGRAM IS NOT
RECEIVING FUNDING- BUT WE ARE
SUPPORT OF THE OTHER-
COMPONENTS OF THAT PROGRAM THAT
OUR FOCUS ON EQUITY- AND
DEDICATE DIGITAL MONEY TO BE A
CALLS. SO- YEAH CLIENT IS ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTRE FOR SO. I
SUPPORTS MY OF THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSAL- ESPECIALLY RELATED
TO. CLEAN TRUCKS AND BUSES
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE EQUITY
PROGRAMS BEING SUPPORTED ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN UNDER THE CAP AND
TRADE- ECCENTRIC PLAN. HOWEVER
WE DO URGE LEGISLATURE TO
INCLUDE FUNDING FOR C. P. R. P.
WHAT CALIFORNIA IS CERTAINLY
MAKING PROGRESS TOWARDS OUR OUR
ELECTRIFICATION GOALS- WE ARE
FALLING BEHIND IN IN REACHING
OUR FUTURE TARGETS- AND
OVERALL. I LIKE YOUR VEHICLES
ARE STILL IN INCOME VERY SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF TOTAL VEHICLE
SALES. AND SO- WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT- TWENTY P. R. P. TO
SUPPORT LOW AND MIDDLE INCOME
CALIFORNIANS IN OUR TRANSITION.
TO ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LINE. SEVENTY
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
LIMóN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CAN DEL PINO ON THE BEHALF OF
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE MY
COMMENTS ARE FOCUSED ON ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED GENERALLY
SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION BY
RESILIENCY BUDGET PACKAGE GIVEN
THAT WE'RE HEADING INTO A
DROUGHT IN ANOTHER POTENTIALLY
SEVERE FIRE SEASON IT IS
CRITICAL TO GET DOLLARS ON THE
GROUND. QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE TO
THOSE WHO ARE ALREADY WORKING
TO REDUCE FIRE RISK RESTORE
LANDSCAPE RESILIENCY AND NEED
NEW FUNDING KEEP GOING THERE
ARE PROJECT WAITING FOR EARLY
FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO GET
MOVING NOW I'M ADDICTED THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN BLOOM FOR YOUR
QUICK ACTION TO WORK WITH THE
SENATE AND WE URGE THE THREE
KEY PARTY TO WORK TOGETHER TO
DELIVER AN EARLY ACTION BUDGET
AGREEMENT WITHIN THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS- IN PARTICULAR DEFENDER
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE INCREASED
EMPHASIS ON FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES PARTICULARLY FOR
THREE BILLION TO PRESCRIBED
FIRE. AND THE FUNDING FOR
TRIBAL ENGAGEMENT DEFENDER ALSO
SUPPORTS THE FUNDING FOR CDFW
AND STATE PARK TO BETTER MANAGE
FIRE ON THEIR LANDS HOWEVER THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL AND
EXPLICABLE HE FAILED TO INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR CDFW TO
ENSURE THAT THE DEPARTMENT WILL
BE ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY CONDUCT
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW AND
PERMITTING OF FIRING COURSE
RESILIENCE PROJECT AND THAT
MEDIA THIRTY RECEIVED THE GIFT
OF THE SERVICE STATE BUDGETING
REPORT IN WHICH THE DEPARTMENT
REPORTS YOU CAN ONLY CARRY OUT
TWENTY SIX PERCENT. WITHIN
BAYERN MENTAL REVIEW AND
PERMITTING RESPONSIBILITIES
GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE OF TO GET
THAT HE'S REVIEW AND PERMITTING
FOR FIRE PROJECT TO PROTECT
BIODIVERSITY RESOURCES
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SHOULD BE
INCLUDED TO EXPAND OTHER
DEPARTMENTS EMPIRE MENTAL
REVIEW AND PERMITTING CAPACITY
FINALLY DEFENDER STRONGLY
SUPPORTS INVESTMENTS IN SCIENCE
BASED MANAGEMENT PARTICULARLY
IN THE INVESTMENT IN REMOTE
SENSING AND CARDS OVERSIGHT
COULD PRESCRIBE PRESCRIBED BURN
PERMIT. ARE THEY ARE CRITICAL
INVESTMENTS TO IMPROVE DECISION
MAKING AND ACCELERATES
IMPORTANT TOOL OF PRESCRIBED.
FIRE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WHY
SEVEN FIVE. THANK YOU MEMBERS
OF COMMITTEE BENEFITING ON
BEHALF OF YOUR BUSINESS COUNCIL
AND THE FEAR CONSORTIUM
SPEAKING ON ISSUE FIVE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE EARLY
ACTION WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
PROPOSAL PARTICULARLY TO THE
BENEFITS OF GETTING FUNDING ON
THE GROUND BECAUSE HEARING
ABOUT IN CALIFORNIA TAHOE
CONSERVANCY ALONGSIDE THE
PROPOSED INVESTMENT IN
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT I'D LIKE
TO REITERATE CAN DELFINO OF
DEFENDERS POINT ON THE NEED FOR
URGENCY ON EARLY ACTION AS WE
BASED ON THE COMING PEAK FIRE
SEASON WHILE REQUESTING FULL
CONSIDERATION OF THE SHORT AND
LONG TERM BENEFITS OF THE CRIME
THE CATALYST FUND. THAT EARLY
ACTION FUNDING TO SUPPORT
PRIVATE INVESTMENT AND ADVANCE
MARKET SOLUTIONS. IN WILDFIRE
PREVENTION THAT WILL HELP.
EXCUSE ME HEALTHCARE. REAP THE
BENEFITS OF THOSE PROTECTIONS
ALL THE SPINNER. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. BY SEVENTY THREE. I COULD
AFTERNOON TO SEE WHAT THE
PUBLIC BUDGET SUB A COUPLE
ITEMS TO COMMENT ON FIRST
COMING UP THE COMPANY POWER-
ONE EXPECTS THEIR SUPPORT FOR
THE SUPPORT WHILE PIRATES ON
CHEAP EXPECTED. OPTICALLY THE
EARLY ACTION BUT HERE I- UPON
THAT ARE IN THERE FOR THE TOP
TALKING- THE SECOND ITEM YEAH
CONTRA TRANSIT. ONE EXPECTS
THEIR SUPPORT WITH THE.
EVENTUALLY ARE PLANNED FOR THE
AND BUS. IT ALSO AFTER THE BY
MR GONZALEZ HEALTH WHICH OF
SUCH. TO CREATE A STEP SPOT
PROGRAM FOR PUBLIC TRANSIT
OPERATORS DO THEIR WORK THE
LONG CONTRACT COULD COME
PROCESS. THANK YOU. ONE SEVENTY
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS FOR
BEHALF OF VALLEY CAN'T CAL THE
SPEAKING ON ITEM SEVEN VALLEY
CAN OPERATE CARS FOR ALL ON THE
VOLLEY AIR DISTRICT CALVIN
PROVIDE RIGHT SURE VANS TO
FARMWORKERS THE- WE WANT TO OUR
FOR THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED WOULD
INCLUDE ERLY ACTION OF SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS CLEANING FOR
ALL AND OTHER CO. IF EARLY
AFTER FOR THE FOR ARE NOT. THEY
WILL BE FORCED DOWN THE BY
BECAUSE AVAILABLE FROM BUDGET
ITEMS LATER IN THE FACT HE
CANNOT BE UNDERSTATED HOW
CRITICAL IT IS FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED EARLY ACTION
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING IN ORDER
TO SUPPORT. CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES. MOST VULNERABLE TO
AND OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND AIR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR.
THANK
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PARDON ME EIGHT THEN WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO LIVE FIFTY
NINE. H. THANK YOU CHAIR BLOOM-
BUT INSTRUCTS QUICKLY ON BEHALF
OF SAVE THE BAY- SPEAKING ON
ITEM NUMBER OR ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN CLICK TO REQUEST BEAR
COMMITTEE RESTORE FUNDING TO
THE URBAN GREENING PROGRAM AT
FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS- FOUNDED
IN NINETEEN FIFTY ONE SAVE THE
BAY IS NOW THE LARGEST REGIONAL
ORGANIZATION WORKING TO PROTECT
AND RESTORE THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY- AND IT'S OBVIOUS THAT THE
LONG PREDICTED IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE ARE ALREADY
BECOMING OUR DAILY REALITY.
TWENTY TWENTY WAS THE HOTTEST
YEAR ON RECORD FREQUENT
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES
PERSISTENT DROUGHT RECORD
SETTING URBAN SHEET AND
COMPROMISED AIR QUALITY ARE ALL
BECOMING COMMON. IN THESE
CHALLENGES ARE CERTAIN TO BE
COMPROMISED BUT- COMPOUNDED BUT
WILL RISE TO MORE FREQUENT
INLAND FLOODING. URBAN GREETING
PROVIDES A HOST OF CLIMATE
ADAPTATION BENEFITS THAT LOCAL
CITIES URGENTLY NEED READING
PROJECTS ALLEVIATE URBAN SHE'D
BETTER MANAGE STORMWATER
IMPROVE AIR AND WATER QUALITY
REDUCE ENERGY DEMAND DIFFICULT
MILES DRIVEN AND MAKE STREETS
SAFER AND MORE APPEALING FOR
BICYCLISTS AND PEDESTRIANS. BE
THE BEST MINTS ARE MULTI
BENEFIT CLIMATE RESILIENT AND
IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR OUR
RESIDENTS. SHOULD BE MADE
EXPANDING URBAN GREENING A
PRIORITY FOR A LOCAL ADVOCACY
THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA. MANY
COULD YOU SEE THE ADVANTAGES TO
EXPAND THE GREENING PROJECTS
PARTICULARLY FOR LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES THAT LACK- DATA
ENTRY CANOPY BUT THEY STRUGGLED
SECURING RESOURCES TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS PROJECT. THE
FUNDING THIS PROGRAM PROVIDES
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
ENSURING THAT OUR STUDENTS HAVE
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
ADAPT TO THE EXISTING CLIMATE
RISKS AND ENSURE THAT. THEIR
COMMUNITIES REMAIN RESILIENT.
HE DO THAT NEED THE FUNDING OF
THE PROGRAM PROVIDES. AND
THEREFORE I WANT AND- URGE AND-
I NEED TO RE FUNDING FOR THE
HERB GREEN PROGRAM AT FIFTY
NINE DOLLARS THANK YOU. WINDS
ONE. AFTER MY NAME JONATHAN NOT-
CALLING FROM THE TAKE UP- NOT I
WANTED TO OF THE THAT- PREVIOUS
CALLER WE'RE ALSO CALLING FOR
INDUSTRY- GREETING FROM THE CAP
FONG I'M ACTIVELY LOOKING-
FUNDS WHICH IS A GOOD TIME
PROGRAM IS FUND- PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- HI MUCH
EVERYONE THE STATE HAS. ABLE TO
THE IN THE PUBLIC- THERE THE
URBAN HEAT EFFECT. IS GET A
MORE MARKUPS DAVID THE YEAR
ESPECIALLY THE LAST ABOUT SEVEN
WE HAD A. BROWN IS REALLY. WE
THE OVERALL GOLD- OF- KIND OF
MEDICATION PARTICULARLY ON
AROUND LOAD CHEN OF THE
PRECLUDING PROGRAM CAN- AND IN
MANY OF HIS FUND TRANSPORTATION
FOR. AND A COUPLE- TO I THINK
THAT BURKE TO- IT A WALKING AND
BIKING. WHICH- DESPITE WITH
EVEN IN CASE IN WHICH- INTEREST
IS. PUT IN PLACE TO FACILITATE
THAT MODES- THE- DE SQUADS
UPPER. AGAINST- THE TWENTY
TWENTY AND THAT A LOT OF THE
SERVICE- SO WE WOULD LIKE TO.
SEE THAT PROGRAM IS STILL. IN
THIS YEAR'S CAPPING TRADE THAT
EFFORT THANKS VERY MUCH. CLEAN
VEHICLE REGULATORY COMPLIANCE
AT HYUNDAI MOTOR NORTH AMERICA.
MONDAY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT TODAY ON
ISSUES LIKE THAT AND THE CAP
AND TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN.
SOUNDED VERY CONCERNED THE LACK
OF FUNDING IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET FOR THE CLEAN
VEHICLE REBATE PROGRAM AT A
TIME WHEN THE GOVERNOR IS
CALLING FOR AUTO MAKERS TO
ACHIEVABLE A 100% ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES AND NEW CAR SALES BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. PUT SIMPLY
IF THE T. V. R. P. IS UNFUNDED
OR UNDERFUNDED ACHIEVING THE
GOVERNOR'S VISION IS OUT OF
REACH. WE ARE JUST SUB
COMMITTEE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE THE PHARMACY THE R. P.
AT A MINIMUM OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR. THIS AMOUNT IS
MORE THAN REASONABLE IN LIGHT
OF LAST MONTH SIGNIFICANT CAP
AND TRADE AUCTION PROCEEDS AN
AIRBASE ON C. B. R. P. NEED
PROJECTIONS WHICH IDENTIFIED A
FUNDING RANGE. FOR THIS
UPCOMING FISCAL YEAR BETWEEN
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTEEN MILLION.
AND FIVE HUNDRED ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS. IN ADDITION THE EXIST
FORTY. DOLLARS TO FEED YOUR THE
FUNDING CANNOT BE EXPECTED TO
CARRY INTO NEXT YEAR. AT THEIR
BE ITSELF PROJECT IT WILL BE
EXHAUSTED IN THE NEXT TWO TO
THREE MONTHS. AS YOU KNOW THERE
ARE STILL SIGNIFICANT CONSUMER
APPREHENSION ABOUT ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AND WE NEED THESE
CONSUMERS- IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE
THE GOVERNOR'S GOAL. THAT'S WHY
THIS INCENTIVE PROGRAM IS SO
IMPORTANT. BUT PERHAPS MOST
IMPORTANTLY AND PERHAPS IT WAS
DONE BY OVERSIGHT BUT DROPPING
THE CD ARE P. MEANS THERE ARE
THREE FUNDING FOR FUEL CELL
VEHICLE. THESE VEHICLES ARE NOT
COVERED BY A PROGRAM LIKE THE
CLEAN SOBRE WARDS PROGRAM. AND
FAILURE TO. YOURSELF IN CAN'T
MOUNT TO. THE STATE COMMITMENT
TO EFFECT. AND SICKENING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND INVESTMENT
THE STATE HAS MADE TO SUPPORT
IT. YOU'LL THE OTHER ESSENTIAL
TO A 100% THAT PORTFOLIO AS AIR
BE ON BOARD MEMBERS HAVE
RECOGNIZED AT RECENT BOARD
MEETING. ENCLOSING HELP IS
SERIOUS ABOUT ACTUALIZING A
100% THAT TARGET BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE ALIVE ONCE THE
SAINT PETER P. FUNDING BY THE
STATE IS A NECESSITY. FIFTY
SHOULD APPROPRIATE AT LEAST TWO
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE PROGRAM
IN THE UP COMING FISCAL YEAR
AND WE WOULD FURTHER REQUESTED
FEDERATION OF A DEDICATED
FUNDING SOURCE FOR THE PROGRAM
THROUGH TWENTY THIRTY WHEN YOU
THINK YOU NEED FOR A CHEAP
PRICE PARITY WITH ICE. VEHICLE
AND MOST VEHICLESEGMENT BUT NOT
ALL I KNOW. WE HAD SUBMITTED
WRITTEN TESTIMONY FOR THE
RECORD THAT FURTHER EXPLAINED
THEIR POSITION THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION
HYUNDAI LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE. AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON THIS ITEM.
LIKE SEVENTY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN GOING TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AARON
RODRIGUEZ FOR THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS BEGAN TO
ITEM SEVEN WE SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S REQUEST FOR
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FOR
CLEAN TRUCKS BUSES AND OFFERED
A QUICK MINUTE UCS ALSO
SUPPORTS THE GOVERNOR'S REQUEST
YOU A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
PASSENGER VEHICLE EQUITY
PROJECTS SUCH AS GREEN CARDS
ALL BUT YOU BELIEVE IMPORTANTLY
FOCUSES ON LOWER INCOME BUYERS
AND YOU THE USED CAR MARKET.
LAST YOU WANT TO MENTION WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
REORGANIZATION OF THE QUEEN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM AND AIR
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH.
YOU THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS
THANK YOU. ONE FORTY FOUR. MY
NAME IS MELANIE SLAUGHTER BACK
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
REPRESENT FROM THE PUBLIC
BEACHES AND PARKS WHICH OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BASED
NONPROFIT I'M ASKING THE
COMMITTEE AND ASSEMBLY TO TAKE
ACTION TO RESTORE FUNDING THAT
THE URBAN GREENING PROGRAM AS
PART OF THE CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN ISSUED SEVEN
AT FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
ORDER TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND MEET OUR STATE
WIDE TARGETS WE MUST TAKE EVERY
REASONABLE OPPORTUNITY TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT. URBAN GREENING
OF THE T. MOBILE IT'S IMMEDIATE
AND IT'S SUPPORTED BY SCIENCE
WITH TEMPERATURES ON THE RISE
WILDFIRES RAVAGING THE STATE
AND DROUGHT CONDITIONS IN MANY
REGIONS CLIMATE IMPACTS ARE
ALREADY HERE THIS PROGRAM WILL
THE QUESTER CARPENTER PLANTS
CREATE CLEAN AIR REDUCE URBAN
HEAT ISLAND MAKE MORE BEAUTIFUL
CITIES IMPROVE WRITER
EXPERIENCES THAT BOUGHT THE
TRANSIT STATION AND LET'S NOT
FORGET THAT TREES PROVIDE
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS FOR
IMPROVING THE QUALITY. OF LIFE
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS. PROGRAM
CAN BENEFIT COW ABOUT THOSE
THAT ARE. BURDENED BY
INVULNERABLE TO POLLUTION
RESTORING FUNDING AT THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR LEVEL FOR THE
URBAN GREENING PROGRAM IS
EXCEEDINGLY IMPORTANT TO THE
HEALTH AND WELLBEING OF
RESIDENTS. AND PROVIDES
IMMEDIATE BENEFITS THANK YOU.
LINE. THIRTY NINE. PARDON ME
FIND. FIFTY SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAPLAIN AND MEMBERS TRICHET
GARINGER WITH AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA CALLING
WITH REGARD TO A FEW ITEMS
WITHIN ISSUE SEVEN THE CAP AND
TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN THE
DIFFICULTY WE SUPPORT HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION IN FUNDING
OUTLINED FOR THE ACT DIESEL
ENGINE REPLACEMENTS KNOWN AS
ARMOR PROGRAM BENEFITING PUBLIC
HEALTH PARTICULARLY IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
ADEQUATE. MEANT MISSIONS
PROTECTION. NINETY MILLION OF
THOSE DOLLARS GO TOWARD EARLY.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THIRTY MILLION
FOUR HOTTEST PRO WITH FIFTY
MILLION OF THAT TOTAL GOING
TOWARD EARLY ACTION. AND ALSO.
IT PLAN FUNDS GOING TOWARDS THE
STATE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER PROGRAM AND FINALLY WE
CONCUR WITH THE STATEMENTS BY
RUSSIAN FROM FARM BUREAU. TO
PROVIDE SOME. YOUR ACT HEATING
PROGRAM HELP CALIFORNIANS DAIRY
FARMING YEAH EACH PARTNERING
WITH THE REDUCE. MUSCLE.
ADDITION COMIC APPROX THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WHY FORTY FIVE.
HELLO MY NAME IS VERY GO AND I
AM THE OF CLIMATE WITH AGREE
BUCKLING A NONPROFIT THEIR
WE'RE INFO SUPPORT OF THE
WILDFIRE BILLION BUT I AM NOT
YOU COULD TO TAKE ACTION TO
RESTORE THE FOR URBAN GREENING
AS PART OF A COMPANY TRADE
BETTER PLAN AT FIFTY MILLION.
HERE HE DEMONSTRATED THAT THE
LONG PREDICTED IMPACT OF
CLIMATE. ARE ALREADY. OUR
REALITY. THE MORE YOU'RE GOING
TO UP GETTING. COULD THIS.
DROUGHT RECORD SETTING BUT NEED.
A COUPLE AIR QUALITY ARE BIG
COPS. COMMON AND THE TOWN. WILL
BE COMPOUNDED THE FIGHTING THE
FAR AND IN THE THEM YOU KNOW
RIGHT AND MORE FREQUENT.
ECONOMIC DOT START AGAIN. TO
THE FACT THAT NO. OF HEALTH.
YOU'RE NOT EVEN ACCESS TO.
GREENSPACE IN THE AFFECTED
PHYSICAL MENTAL HEALTH. ANY
PROGRAM HELP MEDICAID
INEQUALITY INCREASING ACCESS TO
COOL. TO QUALIFY LATER REFRESH
CARE ACTOR AND- JADE NOT BURKE
BALLOTS. IN DISADVANTAGE AND
UNDER COMMUNITIES. MAJOR
RESOLUTION BUT URBAN COULDN'T
BRING GARDEN BIO SO I NATIVE
YOU CAN'T BEAT CAN HELP MANAGED
INTO WHAT QUALITY HE PROVIDE A
HOST CRIME AT BETTER- URGENTLY.
THANK MORE TREES VEGETATION IN
THE DESIGN THE PUBLIC. URBAN
GREEN CAN LEAD IRVING APARTMENT
HABITAT BETTER MANAGE WORKING
RAIN IF I IMPROVE AIR QUALITY
AND MAKE SAFER AND MARK YOUNGER
BECAUSE AND PEDESTRIANS. I YOU
TODAY TO THE RIGHT THING AND
CAN FOR THE DRUG. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO LINE THIRTY NINE.
THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHAT CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE ON ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN AMONG CALIFORNIA'S
LAUDABLE CLIMATE GOAL IS THE
GOAL TO REDUCE 75% OF SHORT
LIVED COMIC BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE AS OUTLINED IN SB THIRTY
THREE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN STEPHEN
I KEEP BEING WRITTEN REPORT
STATING WE HAVE WHAT JUST TEN
YEARS WITH THE TICKET WE REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS BEFORE
FACING ABOUT CATASTROPHIC.
EFFECTS CLIMATE CHANGE REDUCING
THE MOST- IN IN HARMFUL OF THE
COMMISSION SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZED IN OUR STATE
STRATEGYAND THAT IN THE BUDGET
I THINK THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
REGULATIONS TO DIVERT 75% OF
OUR OF OUR ORGANIC WASTE FROM
LANDFILLS WHICH IS A MAJOR
SOURCE OF METHANE EMISSIONS.
HAVE BEEN RECETLY ADOPTED BY
CAL RECYCLE AND WILL GO INTO
EFFECT NEXT YEAR. MARK THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT DEVELOPMENT IN THE
WASTE INDUSTRY IN DECADES AND
HOLD THE POTENTIAL TO ACT AS
THE MAJOR CLIMATE MEDICARE TO
THE PRODUCTION AND USE OF OUT
BY COMPOST AND RENEWABLE GAS.
INSIDE THE CATHEDRAL BENEFITS
OF BUILDING WELL HEALTH AND
RESILIENCY REDUCING THE USE OF
CHEMICAL AND PUT INCREASING
WATER RETENTION AND OF COURSE
REDUCING. OUR DEPENDENCE ON
FOSSIL FUEL. IN ADDITION I
THIRTEEN YOU DRINK THE FAR OF
ITS- GOAL 220% OF EDIBLE FOR
HUMAN CONSUMPTION. AT A TIME
WHERE STUDENTS THE HAS DOUBLED
IN THE STATE. AND BANKS ARE
SAYING NOT TO INCREASES IN THE
MAIL. THIS PROGRAM IS MORE OR
THAN EVER. FOR THESE REASONS WE
ARE A LOT CANNOT BE ANY FUNDING
TOWERS. INTO OF I THINK THERE
CAN BE THREE. IN THIS PROPOSED
AND URGE YOU TO RECONSIDER
SUPPORTING THE REDUCTIONS OF
SHORT LIVED COMMITMENT THROUGH
THE STATE CAP AND TRADE
DOLARS. WE DON'T LIKE TO STAY
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE- CURRENT
PROPOSAL TO APPROPRIATE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE HELP
PEOPLE'S PROGRAM IS. MILLION
FOR CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE
YOU'RE THE CLIMATE. CATALYST
FUNDS THANK YOU. ONE EIGHTY
SIX. THANKYOU TURN MEMBERS
DIRECTOR MARKETS REPRESENTING
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST CARBON
CYCLE INSTITUTE AND THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK SPEAKING ON
ISSUES SEVEN IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
FUND THE HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM
OUT THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE REASONS MENTIONED BY MY
COLLEAGUE AT THE ENERGY B. WE
ARE ALSO ASKING FOR THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
ALTERNATIVE MINIMUM MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM IT'S IMPORTANT CLIMATE
SMART AGRICULTURE PROGRAM HAS
BEEN ZEROED OUT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY BERRY PRODUCERS MANY OF
WHOM ARE SMALL AND THEN SCALE
PRODUCERS REQUESTED OVER FIFTY
FOUR MILLION AMP DOLLARS TO
TRANSITION THEIR OPERATIONS FOR
WHAT MANY ARE HANDLING AND
STORAGE TO DRIVING YOUR
HANDLING AND STORING WHICH CAN
THEN BE CONTENT THAT WE HAVE
CONCERNS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION STAFF HAS
PROPOSED TO FIND JERRY NOTHING
PROJECT BUT THE CATALYST FUNDS
WE DON'T THINK THIS IS AN
APPROPRIATE FUNDING SOURCE FOR
SMALL AND MID SKILLED AREAS
WHICH ARE NOT THE CONDITION TO
TAKE ON MARK THAT FINALLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CARBON CYCLE
INSTITUTE I URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO RESTORE FUNDING. TO THE
URBAN. GREEN PROGRAM THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. YOUR CHAIR
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. TWO
MAKE A COMMENT AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE AND TO.
WITHOUT THAT FINAL A- OF
COMMENT FROM MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC WE WILL ADJOURN. THANK
YOU WE'LL SEE AGAIN NEXT WEEK.